[Music]
My Voice keeps on my soul keeps Rising
as I sing my song
[Music]
I'm still here
Corners down
[Music]
till I'm more than one day
tell us
[Music]
foreign
ignite the fire of a brand new age when
I hear my voice
[Music]
you can't believe
my whole
my voice
[Music]
better than
I've been bleeding beat down this
scope because I rock when it's the only
option second is
[Music]
so coming against us
and this ain't my final form
[Music]
I
hurt my hands me
[Music]
tell us
back
brush it down
next I'll be strong
[Music]
thing
here we go
[Music]
thank you
till I'm more than what they ask of me
[Music]
come on
believe you could be so much more made
for the moment in the era I forged live
from the minutes where the Legends all
born and the myths are forever when they
pen our Lord I hear
inside of the world clear I feel all the
hopes inside of the same fear the
Shadows defeated
[Music]
lacking the vision and asking why the
hell I would risk it I'm basically
different I'm everything they say that
is
all the pressure gets too strong feel
like I was born here for something to
prove wrong what was that moment when
you felt that sound I heard the crowd
Shake ground screaming one more round
Splash over the main stage I'm still
Brave battling the Giants are still made
the real face that's that choice ignite
the Fire have a brand new age when I
hear my voice
till I'm more than what they ask of me
till I fly in ways you can't believe
[Music]
of course better
played and beat down this
is good because I've arrived when it's
the only option second is
[Music]
the beginning
The Trenches so coming against us
on the floor
has been beard like art on the wall
till I'm more than what they ask of me
till I fly in ways you can't believe
[Music]
brush it down
next
I'll be strong
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
till I fly away
foreign
[Music]
me inside
I believe you could be so much more made
for the moment in the era I forged live
from the minutes where the Legends are
born in the myths are forever when
they've been our Lord I hear every Echo
inside of the world clear I feel all the
hopes inside of the same fear shadows in
the same years when they tell us that
it's gone but y'all I'm still here
ignite the fire of a brand new age when
they hear my voice
[Music]
you can't believe
[Laughter]
[Music]
I can't hold myself
our systems go because I've arrived when
it's the only option second is
[Music]
still coming against us
on the floor
my husband beard like art on the wall
keep them Evolutions constant
final form
[Music]
till I fly in ways you can't believe
brush it down
next I'll be strong prove myself
[Music]
please
thank you
[Music]
foreign
believe you could be so much more made
for the moment in the era I forged live
from the minutes where the Legends are
born in the myths are forever when
they've been our Lord I hear every Echo
inside of the world clear I feel all the
hopes inside of the same fear Shadows
it's gone but so I'm still
I'm still running back quarter on one
cap
basically different than everything they
say
s
that's that choice ignite the fire of a
brand new age when I hear my voice
[Music]
you can't believe
I've been played and beat down this is
the Lost System Scope because I cause I
ride when it's the only option
studies
[Music]
Ripple this is the beginning imagine
your boy a level two
running the trenches so coming against
us it's utterly specialist
soon as they hit the door
hurdles revered like art on the walls
[Music]
keep aching My Voice keeps on my soul
keeps Rising as I sing
[Music]
this
still feel
Corners down
[Music]
thank you
Horizon in a dream
[Music]
believe you could be so much more made
for the moment in the era I forged live
from the minutes where the Legends are
born in the myths of forever when they
pin our Lord
Shadows
[Music]
is everything
yourself worthy I live in the impact as
soon as I push forward and tell them to
hold that roll back I don't see any
limited lacking the vision and asking
why the hell I would risk it I'm
basically different I'm everything to
say that I hate this
all the pressure gets too strong feel
like I was born here for something to
prove wrong what was that moment when
you felt that sound and heard the crowd
Shake ground screaming one more round
let the lights flash over the main stage
I'm still Brave battling the Giants are
still made the real face that's that
choice ignite the fire of a brand new
age when I hear my voice
[Music]
till I'm more than what they ask of me
till I fly in ways you can't believe
[Music]
My Voice keeps on my soul keeps Rising
as I sing my songs
[Music]
split
no sure number one content as soon as
soon as the door hurts on the floor my
stars revered like art on the wall
s
till I'm more than what they ask of me
till I fly in ways you can't believe
[Music]
brush it down
next
I'll be strong prove myself
[Music]
Jersey
thank you
[Music]
till
I fly
to leave
[Music]
tell us
foreign
[Music]
is everything
yourself worthy I live in the impact as
soon as I push forward and tell them to
hold that roll back I don't see any
limit they lacking the vision and asking
why the hell I would risk it I'm
basically different I'm everything they
say that is
all the pressure gets too strong feel
like I was born here for something to
prove wrong what was that moment
screaming one more round let the lights
flash over the main stage I'm still
Brave battling the Giants are still made
the real face has that choice ignite the
fire I have a brand new
[Music]
till I'm more than what they ask of me
till I fly in ways you can't believe
through
God
[Music]
second is
negative
running the trenches so coming against
us
for sure
like art on the wall if they ain't in
the know better keep them informed
Evolution's constant and this ain't my
final form
till I'm more than what they ask of me
till I fly in ways you can't believe
[Music]
brush it down
next I'll be strong prove myself
Corners down
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
Japanese
foreign
say Showtime
title
image
[Music]
clean up
[Applause]
what's going on everyone and welcome to
Evo 2023 more than 9 000 computers in
total for this year that's that's insane
you gotta get a little wild though to
make it happen in these two wild uh new
wild thing in this hand cameraman I need
to see this what is that
oh man the combos hit different when you
smash it up
yeah is burnout Tuesday chips a big
problem and he gets the head butt on the
jump back there you have it sticky our
Killer Instinct champion
has done what no MK 11 player has ever
done before
welcome to day two of Evo 2023. now if
last night was any indication well you
do not want to miss out on the action
today we have an exciting schedule
filled with nothing but finals and I
hope you melty blood type Lumina fans
are ready because we are about to start
the top six right here on the main stage
[Applause]
[Music]
I see your hidden evil for I will the
brightest
[Music]
foreign
your hidden evil and with the world
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
are you all ready for the top six
let's bring them out starting with the
first competitor scroll for Millions
[Applause]
next up we have mo i
the next competitor is Korea wrestling
man
[Applause]
next one oh excuse me next one up on the
line is Jimmy J Tran
and last but not least we have Jane
[Applause]
oh
oh excuse me and we also have
die
[Applause]
give it up for the top six
all right without further Ado we're
gonna head on into competition
competitors will be able to head
backstage I'm gonna throw it on over to
Majin Obama and Jalen
coming at you live from Las Vegas Nevada
Evo 2023 Saturday morning look it's
already been a great weekend so far MK
did a really really great final last
night but you guys know what time it is
Saturday morning we had to come and
bring it to you this melty blood type
Lumina top six Maj Obama here with none
other than the lovely I'm jadelyn and I
am so excited that we get to bring this
to you live here at Evo 2023 this top
six is nothing short of amazing and the
action is going to be non-stop from
start to finish I cannot believe they
let me out the doghouse to talk to y'all
about this game on Saturday morning with
this bracket you can put Jimmy J train
in my bracket this is crazy squad for
million moai Korean wrestling man and
die on winterside Jimmy J Tran and Jing
evil defending evil 2022 Champion Jing
in losers side that is a nasty looking
pool of sharks on losers on the bracket
this is something that you know we
worked so hard over 550 competitors
Scott going through the likes of safe
Raiden you moai beating Kiri Medusa
Korean wrestling man beat Ronda Phantom
Shaylee oh my gosh it's just ridiculous
the number of competitors that they went
through to get here to this bracket die
as well getting matched up against
Korean wrestling man here had to get
here over Aaron Reno other North North
American Top competitors but also put
Jin in losers
it was so oh huge and you got to talk
about on loser side Jimmy J Tran here
got in I mean he lost a gin in pools and
then won eight straight he went through
a lot of the top talent for this game in
North America to get here I can't wait
to see what he does on the stage but
Jing who has arguably had the hardest
journey to this tournament it's crazy
he's the defending Champion but if you
guys don't know his original flight here
got canceled there was a whole there was
a big mess he didn't get here until like
11 30 or midnight the night before pool
started and uh they had to cross an
ocean across the country then double
back to get here but he made it and look
Jalen we've been talking about this game
for a long time uh you've been talking
about it especially for a long time but
the big thing with this game is this
game on a big stage like this we have
not had that super strong International
we've been looking for this is finally
it Japan north of North America we got
Korea representation this is going to be
a lot of fun to watch and coming up
first yeah going up again yes going up
against moai so the big thing is uh
Squad let's talk about him first sure so
screw it I mean very well-known American
player been coming off of a lot of great
wins taking things like the official
multi-blood type loom in a circuit back
in December coming off of a huge win at
combo breaker and coming in with this
coma so if you've been following Squad
at all you know that he had a lot of
different characters coming in at a for
him a disappointing fourth last year at
Evo had a little bit of a character
crisis found this coma and has have
found nothing but success since then
yeah you got to talk about moai too
repping that Kanto region playing got a
big big spot play Big play Spot one
second man that name is hard but that's
a legacy melty blood arcade that's a
that's a really important one and you
got to talk about his history with this
this IP this franchise right this is the
biggest tournament that this game has
ever had maybe we'll ever have and to
have an old head like him one of the
best sotskies in the old games but also
this is a theme of this a multi-game
player let's talk about these characters
coming up coma and rowa if you guys
don't see this game that much don't
watch enough Roa on one side two player
side like that right
lightning to cut off planes in the
screen try to control his face as much
as possible spot running coma it's gonna
be on him the pursuit he's a hyper
grapple character he wants to get in but
the big thing is do not look at his
health bar at the top left his real how
far is the bottom left corner of your
screen exactly and so while we've been
having this oh I having a lot of this
success speaking of meter building up
three counts of magic circuits already
being able to use it hard to drive
almost immediately Impressions
yeah that's the thing about this game
high speed high flying fast-paced
actions but the thing is there are a lot
of defensive mechanics to be able to
counter houses
that was right there that Moon drive
straight into the archery but it's
challenged by moai it was a great idea
from scrapbook Moe I was ready for it
such a strong Health lead too that's an
expensive bet but yeah one step ahead of
him like that
the resources used by Squad kind of
heard of going into this next round but
the thing is once again bottom left
corner screen if he can get two bars
into three bars built and he gets a
knock down on moai that could very well
be the end of the round very well could
be that's a really great Point okay that
was a nice DP coming in and now Hawaii
is the one stuck in the corner he did
have a small armor waited for the Moon
Drive activation went in for the low and
this is getting started once again
bottom left corner two counts with magic
circuit Spence one for that armor has a
little Invincible going in for the grab
this is where Scott really starts his
game the held Shield walks out of the
corner being able to side switch like
that and get this corner out against him
against fraud here but why gonna dump
some meter microcharge drops the
launcher over the lightning comes back
up pressure The Shield the B counter
afterwards switches sides put boy in the
corner we've got two bars with meters
you gotta spend it got one and then the
other one takes around break the glass
on him oh my God meter dumping is Squad
here but look at Mo wise Gage as well
four bars built here and for Road again
about sealing the mid-range like this
this character has like 90 screen
control you see it's important for Squad
to be able to try to make those Miss he
doesn't want to jump in the air and
block them because they can susceptible
to unblockable punish which is very easy
exactly oh The Shield was countered with
the beep by another shield from moai now
back dashing again trying again like you
said for that pressure squad though in
gets that first hit and like we
mentioned before once you're in that's
the scary thing
lightning comes out scrot once again did
shield in the air which is risky like
you just said
it's risky but it's better than blocking
in the air like that guaranteed the
damage but here we go command grab
mid-screen same side oh low shield and
fly gets out of Dodge there but this is
the problem full corner push here
shield for shield right after that Moon
Drive activation but you'll be on the
activation there was crazy
building here but look at all of the
magic circuit on the side of scrap
million four bars just activated Moon
Drive gonna be spending a lot of that
blocking that lightning coming in from
the quarter but now moai stuck has him
in the corner it can scrawn get out of
this
[Music]
command crabs what no way
that's two times in that first game that
squat that really big on that Arc that's
a command grab super boost so right
basically if you have to jump it before
the flash so that's two times moai got
overall on him really big there that has
to be a lot for the mental stack I squat
well known to be an emotional player try
not to let that get to him you can see
Stone Face right back into it foreign
[Music]
people up really easily
found with lightning here defensive heat
activation like this you don't know
it gives you health back while you're
not being touched but unfortunately
Scott got nothing out of that because
once again moai on the offensive and
scrot lost more than he gained during
that exchange where this character can
shine
low Shield big low Shield exchanges
there it is again and moai with the
cavity search gets the launch against
the round set point moai
this is incredible I mean Scott has been
practicing so much but moai is cool calm
and collected and has really studied
this matchup you can tell
that here
opening everything up with has got three
bars so moai knows he's got to be a
little bit more careful but it doesn't
even matter the way that he's using
these huge Roa Combos and locking scrot
down into the corners excellent okay in
the air once again
and that's what we said earlier that
unblockable is so risky there are
specials and there are normals in this
game that are air unblockable you cannot
guard them there so for the defender
against roast if they end up in the air
blocking the lightning he can just walk
up and he has a variety of ways to air
unblocks we can get guaranteed damage
guaranteed knockdown guarantino it's
just like this 4K and once again you're
gonna get there Shields at all and then
we BC oh my gosh and then the blood heat
was countered immediately so you got to
talk about that mechanic right yes heat
activation in this game you're
leveraging meter to stop the clock get
some health back and you get access to
supers as well when you're in that mode
however activating it is the scary part
it creates an unblockable burst style
effect which obviously you have to be
able to Shield it you have to walk up
and use them and use the the main
mechanic of this game which is shield on
defense you can call out call those out
or be just outside the range of the
burst and be able to punish it with
projectiles or strikes like that and
that's what you saw moai do a really
strong lead on this is the moment of
desperation for Squad he's probably
gonna pop in here back dash just outside
of range Make It Rain on him moai
sitting pretty in winners final and
winners finally wow and and such a clean
decisive game plan from moai came in
knew exactly what he wanted to do the
reads were there it was just a great set
to open this up and we are getting our
next players up which is going to be
Korean wrestling man versus die so
before we get into Korean wrestling man
really quickly wanted to highlight that
he is the PlayStation tournament's road
to Evo champion from sea winning that
full Evo package to get out here and we
have a little short video to show about
him to highlight his journey here
[Applause]
that I'm sure we'll get played soon
every year thousands of fgc competitors
try to reach the top of the Evo Mountain
and this year PlayStation's road to Evo
offered Gamers a chance to win a trip to
compete at Evo 2023
representing Seoul South Korea Korean
wrestling man wants to succeed and
follow in the footsteps of Jing's 2022
Championship run
he'll take it these are nothing but 2022
champion
now in the top six on the grandest stage
in the fgc he's ready to show the world
that he's up for the challenge but the
question is will the rest of Evo's top
six be ready for him
you gotta get props to PlayStation for
helping make that happen the prize of
course was a ticket in the flight to Evo
so we get our Seoul Korean
representative for this event and he
made it this far top six winner side
going up against the international
Japanese Man of Mystery what's cool
about dye is you know he he's a player
who if you talk to a lot of the multiple
players that out here they'll tell you
he comes from Dengue actually really
interesting he comes from dengeki and
kind of private not that many players
actually know about him but he's
originally from Osaka moved to Tokyo but
has made a very strong impression on
this bracket most notably huge upset
yesterday putting Jin into into losers
bracket he's also going to be
representing that Roa character but this
uh character on one player's side is
good I don't know this character's gonna
be a doozy so right so this is Mario
Mario the puppet character of this game
meaning that in addition to Mario being
on screen there are a multitude of other
characters we're going to be calling
them the nuns you're going to see them
have a lot of different Weaponry we'll
call them out as we see it but he is a
complex character that Korean wrestling
man has found a great foothold with and
can be incredibly impressive and we're
already starting off die great Roa
gameplay
what I really want to highlight too is
look at how Korean wrestling man opens
or approaches it's important to note
that he controls those nuns basically he
can control them from full screen up
close so it really is depending on his
approach how dye is going to want to
approaches see there this would really
careful really shines at his Okie it's
not so much about damage per touch as
much as it's securing the knockdowns and
then using the chalk room that's
spinning blade you know and that comes
out and throws that that is very unique
and very oppressive of this enemy for
this game and you'll see why in just a
moment yeah and also okay come back to
that in a second but we do have a moon
Drive activation from die putting Korean
wrestling man into the corner very
similar actually to what we saw with the
gameplay from moai it's a very similar
game plan and again they're getting
caught in that unlawful situation it's
funny too because Korean wrestling man
to win that event to get this ticket he
had to go through three of the top
Growers and one of them yes one of the
most Boi actions okay so we had heat
activation from Korean wrestling man was
made made it back to the ground just in
time shield for shield and then the
punish coming out from die the counter
Shield so if you guys don't know the
shield mechanic in this game essentially
is a Parry that leads to an RPS
situation but one of the things that the
opponent gets carried they can Shield
back so you saw shoe exchange there
leading into a big hit from Korean
wrestling man here that jump Shield that
don't neutralize the charge remote that
was really smart Okay a butt caught
again by the lightning so another thing
I want to point out is that the sword
none in certain situations can go
through projectiles and that neutralizes
a little bit of what Roa can do so it's
something we might have come up exactly
it's something you know Roa has control
of 90 of the screen with lightning yes
but he can't just back off completely
like that because he'll have to deal
with sword so it kind of forces him to
approach and try to attack Mario from
mid-range and right now has a full
corner push that sister is watching yeah
this Korean wrestling man that's a
perfect from die
what a way to close around Korean
wrestling man again coming out from
Korea winning that PlayStation
tournament package not getting a chance
to play 3D game yeah but I mean that
just goes and you saw there that's one
of the things you can do in this matchup
when Mario summons those guns to attack
you you can actually attack down there
for a little while and make them
unusable the problem is the Mario player
has setups to be able to punish that
bait that and he can get big return from
it as well
I like the way that uh Korean wrestling
man opened that it was a much more
definitive opener and again as you
mentioned the openings are very
important in this but once again die as
soon as we get a hit it is just
detrimental to the Korean wrestling
man's health pool again Rowan where he
really shines for me is the pressure the
zoning that complicated just like that
max range lightning strike takes this
micro charge just to be able to build as
much gauge as possible finds the low
touch Korean wrestling man in trouble
here and then activate Moon drive to
continue this combination he's gonna get
three counts of magic circuit is going
to go ahead and spend it for an arc
drive this should kill with the amount
of damage that it's about to do he has
4.8k that's ridiculous
but die here on set point for
reinvesting man are you awake
nice staircasing down for some pressure
here yeah
shocker Mill is set up but oh that was a
really interesting interaction
yeah the trade actually worked out there
for Dodge history investing man wasn't
getting able to confirm it but here we
go side split same situation
give me all the games charging oh but it
was punished he charged just for a
second too long of a second recovery
allowing Korean wrestling man to get in
and set up this corner cup we saw this
so much yesterday especially with the
shotgun with that overhead getting
opened up Korean wrestling man getting
that foothold building that fourth bar
of magic circus see what we were talking
about earlier with the counter play Die
showed early on I'm willing to hold up
try to Shield I'm willing to do
something when you do those double
blades coming out like that you see now
for me and wrestleman he's willing to
meet he throw him early throw him just
to be able to check that off it's an RPS
situation it's kind of like a mini game
you got to get out of there
it gives you a second just to see what
your opponent is doing but now Korean
wrestling man hit by that lightning
stuck in the corner this is
so good at systematically dismantling
what Korean wrestling man wants to put
on the screen
nope getting them the next touch for
Korean restaurant you have to imagine
he's looking for some way to activate
[Music]
we all felt it I saw it moments before
it occurred runs up Shields the
aggravation easy punish for the win die
really impressive run in this tournament
so far that's crazy Korean wrestling man
to me is a big X Factor in this bracket
and this Kudos oh my God I'm thinking
about losers Wild
I don't envy the loser side of this
bracket it is like you said it is
shark-filled Waters and it is terrifying
we're gonna get some good sets we're
about to get some good sets but before
we head to our next match guys we got to
thank uh all the people and all the
groups that help make this event
possible like this that help get Korean
wrestling man here exactly and give you
guys this top six bracket we'll be right
back with melting blood type Lumina
Chipotle's new Chicken al pastor is fire
on every level fresh chicken hot off the
grill a rich marinade of seared Marita
peppers and ground achiode balanced with
a splash of pineapple all combined for
the right amount of heat Chipotle's all
new Chicken al pastor is where fire
meets flavor
foreign
[Music]
Victory feels good
hey
[Music]
I'm ready
[Applause]
welcome back everybody to again Evo 2023
here live from Las Vegas Nevada Majid
Obama here with I'm jadelyn and we have
just had an explosive winners half of
this bracket but
yeah this loser's side this match that
we have coming up Scott Vermillion
versus Gene let's have fun with this one
this is uh you know Squad of course you
talked about it earlier disappointing
finish for him last year up look can we
put our cards on the table here sure
we've had what three countries
represented in this top six yes one of
these communities talked a hell of a lot
more Kaka on Twitter than the other two
and that's North America and the and the
head of that movement is this guy Squad
but you got to put respect on it he came
out for Evo Japan right got washed up in
bracket but the whole time he was there
it's business and he could you gotta
imagine he had his sight set on this
matchup right here gin on the other side
yeah you ask him who he's worried about
in this bracket in this event
this is one of the players along with
one other if it comes up we'll talk
about it but right this is the match
that I think squad has had his side set
on for for at least a year you know
definitely and uh we were talking last
night about how scrot and gin while
while Scott was in Japan played each
other constantly they were learning how
the other one works and so they have
practiced against each other but in
in Evo on the stage when as we said Jin
you know coming in here at almost the
last hour physically possible still
possibly jet lag scrot not coming from
as far away but you know is coming from
East Coast time zone how is that working
for him what's the mentality I mean they
are both so focused right now I know
they both want this you know Jin wants
to was tweeting last night about how he
would love to get a second title under
his belt squat wants that Redemption run
exactly and like like you said right for
a shin it's about if he's gonna get that
second one it's gonna be the hardest
path possible Right Here is insane
motivation is running super high now's
your chance you showed me the hustle
when you came out to Japan can you punch
your ticket right here right now get in
over somebody who has been a hard
gatekeeper and make a big statement
going into the spinal this
if Scott wins this that's a huge huge
barrier that he's overcome but before we
get to that let's talk about the
character selection here right you're
all going to be running coma of course
if you guys don't know if you aren't
familiar he is the grappler the default
Grappler of this game that is very
deceptive because he is very fast he's a
hyper Grappler and see guys if any of
y'all mess with Marvel whatever happened
to Juggernaut well I'll tell you what
happened they took him out of Marvel 2
and they put him in this game wait for
it till he gets four bars of the
knockdown I've seen this set before last
time
what came up
I've seen it but here's the thing Jin
has been waiting for this too Jin has
engine playing history uh the main
character they've been playing this for
a very very long time she has really set
up base beat looking out for those
tables that he will set up because that
is a great way to set have a little set
play have some knockdown but right now
squat getting in there getting that
micro charge because once again you got
to be looking at his magic circuit
because that's more important than the
health the meter is able to give him his
win condition like that when he gets a
knock down in the corner ends a command
grab stop OTG into armor okay Jake
Paul's out of the combo but scraw closes
the Gap like you said so fast that hyper
Grappler closes out round one pretty
definitive that Dash up running backhand
launcher like that hits so far away and
you see him again using that anti-air
crouching crouching punch like that to
be able to get this corner here three
bars built stop the yard
cue up the armor yep again and this is
the hard part for gin can you escape
this situation you have ways to do it a
shield interaction is one way just get
out of Dodge
okay the armor just ran out but Scott
Vermillion was ready for a counter to
jump from Jing go to punching back in
the corner from whence they came the
grab comes out neutral jump just to see
what team is doing the grab again big
throw Jing does not have a lot to work
with defensive heat activation
[Music]
now big combo here spends one Bart again
there's the ex table gets the knockoff
from that that cake extension is all
about damage and carry and then just a
simple low what history highlights she's
a very basic kind of standard character
she has item throw and then the ability
to run the most simple kind of mix up on
Okie but it's super effective she
highlights what's awesome about this
game oh my God that was insane the way
that Jing was ready for that was
incredible and then gonna go ahead and
spend Arc Drive manages to close it out
optimal truly optimal
and here's but here's the problem bottom
left corner of your screen that is so
much that is squats win con if he's able
to get in touch and take him to the wall
this is gonna get really nasty really
quick so for Jin it's about
not getting clipped by something like
that the recovery from that one touch
was all that Scott needed to get in
there and like you said look at him
spending that far he's on the other side
what an ambiguous cross-up in the air a
lot of melty blood if you're not
familiar does take place in the air so
you got to be watching the way that
people are controlling that movement
it's one thing that he sweet kind of
highlights nice what a throw yes with
the background into the wall like this
when Khan activated yeah we got power up
oh my gosh look at the moment we do have
that defensive heat activation from Jing
not is gonna get all of that Health back
going to spend the last bit of heat just
go ahead and get that Arc drive out nice
and simple Bento set just comes with the
overhead yeah but Scott has one chance
here what can he do with it
activation to help to confirm good
closeout from Jin now the big thing is
what you saw is really good counter play
yes on Armor activation from gin there
are four there are a few ways to beat
that armor you have to either nail them
with your heat activation you have to
win a shield engagement you have to
throw him or you have to hit him with a
super
two times out of three that ain't badges
he got two really good calls to be able
to stop that momentum building and it
puts far in a dire situation but here we
go cake extension to the wall look at
the confidence that Jin has coming into
this he was a little bit hesitant in
that first game but now that cross-up
too within the Allen Iverson the East
bro if you like ECW I feel like you love
this character man tables ladles and
chairs she got the whole the whole Home
Depot coming after you with this look at
that black Dash getting out of the range
from that what looked like that strike
throw situation it's a great way to mix
up history's pressure on their side Moon
Drive activated strot does not care
defensive tribe activation here but the
ball push heat activation he does not
care Moon skill right through the Bento
because heat is one of the ways that you
can break armor that was a really smart
idea from Jing but like you said Scott
doesn't care
oh my God
oh
good grab from Gene the Bento is behind
yep that's exactly where you do pressure
sandwich situation just like that
Jing looking so strong right now
and just like that you know it's that
point yeah screw it
big stop sign from those crouching e
sweet buttons gonna get his carry here
cake set for the extension the extra 800
500 800 damage however much same side
ball oh my God he held the shield too
long which allowed you to get that throw
going but once again Scott finding that
opening activates the armor that win
condition
just walk running at we get a clash
shield and the B counter is going to
open up jingle if you see a brother
looking like that glowing red coming at
you on the street
command grab three bars built
class rings there backing off but that's
the thing is oh the shield on this Pinto
explosion allowed him to do the B
counter letting him appear behind his
sweet but Jin did not care he was ready
for it they both have almost they have
full magic circuit on both sides
wins
doesn't even need it
gin moving on eliminating Scott from
this bracket but pick up subscribe I
mean uh awesome performance so far from
n a in this in this event I gotta say
and Squad of course being the Bannerman
I think for a lot of the North American
Community really cool to see him get
this far and be able to get the set that
he wanted probably didn't finish the way
he wanted but uh that was uh the set one
of the sets I've been waiting for that
was pretty good I it was nice that we
got I mean I hit the city of that set so
early but it was a set that I was really
looking forward to seeing and
gin cause we missed out on it last year
right that's a set that didn't happen
with the way the bracket worked out but
that was I think the set that I think a
lot of people were looking forward to
seeing but she could be the one that
ultimately moves on but we gotta talk
about this next match yeah I was going
to say speaking of sets that we're
looking forward to seeing Korean
wrestling man versus Jimmy J trip please
take and I'll say this Korean wrestling
man has been really impressive he this
game is about multi-game players and
Korean wrestling man is no exception to
that started with dbfz we should have
been Street Fighter five Street Fighter
six but this game is where he's made a
very big impression however you're going
up against uh I don't know man a lot of
people ain't gonna put him on the Mount
Rushmore or whatever but this is one of
the most awesome fighting game players
that North America has produced I know
we got a lot of Fanboys out there but
what really shines to me about Jimmy J
Tran regardless of what game you've
watched him in regardless of what name
you know and by you know he's got quite
a few uh but what really makes him
awesome as a player is in this modern
era where we're focused on players
becoming Brands and doing all the extra
stuff
he is a pure player and what I love
about him is his competitive mindset it
doesn't matter what game he throws down
it could be a third strike it could be
attacking it could be a melting blood
type Lumina he is going to have that
same cutthroat perspective on just
competition frames don't care about
feelings you know he's willing to put
the time in put that grind in and just
play and get to the just he has a strong
respect for your
competitor's ability to adapt to
whatever the game is whatever the
situation is and he exemplifies that in
everything he plays yeah and so let's
talk a little bit about CL the character
that he's playing because this is a
character we haven't seen yet so Ciel is
a really balanced character has a lot of
great tools you know with her key throw
she can keep you out Zone you out but
her close range motion is really
impressive as well she has tools to lock
you down she's got some full screen
options that are incredibly terrifying
if you make a mistake her game plan is
basic but it's effective what I'll say
is
along with Hisui CL is a character where
you can really see the in my opinion the
most awesome feature of this game is the
movement and you're gonna see that with
Jimmy J trans approach here but it's
gonna be hard because of this Mario
matchup that sword none is going to be a
constant threat just because she's able
to go through the projectile records
that Jimmy can do and of course like you
said emphasis on strike throw with this
character she doesn't have as much left
right stuff but that jumping splits kick
is a cross-up attack that you'll see
Jimmy J train go to a lot however locked
and loaded gonna get side swapped into
the corner most likely yes yeah we saw
this a lot yesterday again the overhead
with that Mario combo the character that
they are playing against will switch
sides but eventually is going to get
back into that corner the chakra none
again too being able to hit with the
overhead this is the Korean wrestling
man we're used to seeing with so much
offensive piece of fun he's a script
okay such ambiguous overhead movement
like you were just saying so much of
this takes place in the air and there's
a lot of fast movement you do get two
jumps to air actions in this game for
most characters and so he was able to do
that side switch make it really
ambiguous where he was gonna play the
thing about Mario too is his buttons are
very stubby he doesn't have a lot of
space control with them but they
function very well for pressure air
pressure in conjunction with the nuns
like you said he could create very
ambiguous situations deep big body
confirmed from Jimmy J here
unfortunately crop that could have been
much worse okay opens up with that
really nice glow set it was fast using
fast buttons low to open somebody up
because most of the most of your a
buttons in this game are going to be
five frames and Mr naps had a very lucky
break there being able to convert like
that off the whip but here we go Shield
BC and that's the struggle with this
character CL obviously she has a
projectile that she goes to is she
throws those keys those essentially
function as projectile Wreckers but the
problem is these nuns that reinvesting
men keep summoning they prevent Jimmy J
Tran from being able to get spaces that
was such a great deal super yeah so that
when you use those uh DP motions they do
have invincibility on them it was a very
safe option for Jimmy to use okay
coming in now so much pressure Shields
the heat activation this is huge and the
wall starter this is gonna be big damage
back and then the launch incoming no
gonna go with the key super here 46-25
damage on the table oh my gosh
Enterprise move Drive activation that's
it four bars he's got it yeah is he
gonna close it out with the ex or just
go straight into the arc Drive
fantastic Jimmy Mr naps putting them to
sleep
wow
that's the thing with cl she gets access
to Full Moon Drive like that four bars
now that strike though becomes a little
bit dangerous because of the threat that
the aircraft the air of anti-ground grab
gonna come into play I really like the
way Korean wrestling man has been using
that pre-round movement so if you've
been noticing everybody can move before
the round starts but they can't throw a
move so you're trying to get those
advantageous positions and Korean
wrestling man went for it but Jimmy is
so cool yeah look at this he's trying to
slow down the match now but that's what
happened you see there she tried to
punish the sword none like that but the
punch nun comes out in front so he
creates this kind of back and forth he
got punished for trying to knock down
and let me mobilize one of the nuns so
after that Shield activation Jimmy tried
to go for a launcher but now was able to
slide underneath with CLS really fast
great oh safe jump
kick
going in for this combo once again
building up their magic circuit wants to
get that ex hard knocked down
do it again do it again yeah
attack it and then this is big sword
super from this is gonna end with like
probably 3.6 or something like that no
no okay but blocks the shot Jimmy's one
of the first people to block that mix up
great guard
oh my God reversal super in the seats oh
my God Jimmy J trained on set point to
eliminate Korean wrestling man from this
event
oh gets caught in a sandwich situation
for the spear none not one that we see
as often from the Korean wrestling man's
offense
thing twirling like that in the corner
nice he was trying to base something
from Jimmy J text the incoming throw
that can be really ambiguous because
Mario can use the nuns to Shield what
he's doing and that throw gets really
scary but Jimmy the confidence coming
out here to fatal counters gonna get
extra damage after that held shield from
Korean wrestling man I was waiting for
him to show it that charged stand slash
attack she has that punishes low Shield
that's a low Shield call out button
[Music]
patience from Jimmy once again slowing
down the tempo of the match but he's
willing to guard he's willing to go okay
from here he's willing to block it out
okay there that could have been huge but
now Korean wrestling man stuck in the
corner put himself there I'm expecting a
throw pretty shortly no the heat was not
blocked that's the hard part with cl
when it's all strikethrough like that if
they're very patient they have good
reaction yeah though great conversion
off the moon skill to be able to get the
OTG like this Jimmy should be able to
build up another yep that's 50 jump go
slow on the other side that time Jimmy
Drake Jimmy j a blind pressure gets a
driver huge gets him with the low Jimmy
is moving on Mister oh my God Jimmy J
Tran
gonna be moving on loser's side over
Korean wrestling man but uh yo big UPS
to him as well because it was a pleasure
and awesome seeing him and competing
this uh this final bracket for this game
like that we've been waiting for an
international Battleground for this game
where we could see the best from Japan
the best from Korea and the best from
North America but I did not have Jimmy J
plan to be one of those guys but he
absolutely is and he's showing you why
with the way this set went down you're
looking at this replay right here right
before look at them this combo is fat as
hell it was and it was such a great use
of every single resource that melty
blood gives you it had Moon drive it had
all four bars it was exactly what you
wanted to do to close it out because you
never want to leave somebody with a
sliver and I love the fact that he he
used most of her moveset too right yeah
that anti-ground grab that she has from
jump
if you're on defense you can react to
that and punish her pretty heavily but
he didn't use it the whole time he
waited until he had full resources to
make it convert and convert as hard as
possible post it out at the end and it
hits Jimmy J Tran gonna be moving on
losers side I did not have this pin on
my fantasy bracket but I'm happy it's
happened I'm happy it's happening this
whole bracket I mean throw the bracket
out the window because this is melty
blood and expect the unexpected right
now though take a breath take a breather
we're going to throw it to a quick quick
break and we'll be right back with more
melty blood top six right after this
your Chipotle order just got extra the
fighter coins from Street Fighter 6.
order any entree in the Chipotle app
using promo code hdkn 236 and receive
250 fighter coins with yours visit
chipotle.com sf6 for details you got
this
only a handful of people in the world
can do it
you could be
the best
but it's dangerous these are incredible
steaks
you're going to be forced to make Split
Second decisions that could cost you
your life get out whether you like it or
not you are in this race
out of the fight
Gran Turismo based on a true story video
PG-13
Red Bull gives you wings
hello
[Music]
till I fly away
thank you
[Music]
foreign
ignite the fire of a brand new age when
I hear my voice
[Music]
my voice
defensive pregnancy
on the floor Ed like art on the wall if
they ain't in the know better keep them
I'm Evolutions constant in this
statement
s
[Music]
you can't believe
the soul keeps Rising as I sing this
[Music]
down
everything
[Music]
here we go
foreign
[Music]
keep strong so my legs keep aching My
Voice keeps on my soul keeps Rising as I
sing my song
beat down this is the rebound our
systems go because I've arrived when
it's the only option second is
this is
running the trenches so coming
against utterly senseless
[Music]
constant and this ain't my final form
My Voice keeps on my soul keeps Rising
as I sing
[Music]
I'll be strong prove myself
at you once again coming at you live
from Las Vegas Nevada here for Evo 2023
melty blood type Lumina top six gonna
continue and oh my God that was uh a
hell of a way to end off that last set
this next set coming up though is going
to be winners final first to three
Affair we got place by big one second
moai going up against GS dye in all
Japan Affair Fair here and when but man
yo real quick they got some people
filling in they will come come see melty
blood type blooming on a Saturday
morning can y'all hear me out there
hey Hanzo run the next set man let's get
this show on the road we are gonna have
a mirror match coming up here so it is
going to be Rolla andaroa the two of
these players have such similar game
plans and I feel like
the way they open the what's going to be
to watch is how they open their game
plan the big thing with this is because
it's a mirror match like this where both
players are gonna be it's all about
jockeying for position with this with
this matchup like this so it's going to
be about who can get just outside of
that Thunder range like that who can
make a good call on getting past someone
else's Thunder call and finding
Advantage from there they're gonna be
competing in obviously the same range in
a lot of time right right it's about
making the other player miss taking
advantage of that you gotta remember
rowa this character is very good at
cutting off Lanes of the screen like
that and you don't want to jump in and
block or else you're going to open your
up to yourself up to unblockable setups
so the big thing is being able to play
the spacing game using Moon Drive
activation to be able to pause the
screen see what's going on make a good
Shield call from there well no I think
the tempo is going to come into this a
lot because if you can change the way
that you are controlling the speed of
the match throw an incredibly fast
player but if you can slow it down
completely throw off the game plan and
the Rhythm you can have a significant
advantage and right now moai big opener
here lots of pressure
just like that that instant air Dash
jumping kick attack like that he's able
to get so low to the ground and his
buttons are very satisfactory for
hitting air to ground kind of uh
situations like that that Moon Drive was
completely negated with that throw but
boa is so willing to spend his resources
early to get an advantage Button he's
not getting too much out of it does get
the throw before it died yeah it's just
unfortunately he ran just out of the
meter from the heat activation
unfortunate the building is Gage nice
finds the high hitting the scramble
after that yo this that's the thing with
moai he's not afraid especially coming
from the characters that he used to play
he's not afraid to get dirty free and
scramble situations he's willing to bet
big in these situations run up DP run up
throws oh the Allen Iverson that was
such nice mix and now caught two here
building up this bar gonna throw die
into the corner hard knock down goes for
the load I was ready for it that time
jumps out of the corner and What A Catch
there with that she's really short
lightning into the bigger one awesome
reaction there just simple instant
instant air Dash check right there from
the with the lightning from uh die and
now it's Corner pressure of his own
again this is where this character could
shine slow shielding and with the
overhead the Fatal counter is gonna add
extra damage into it back dashing trying
to catch somebody jumping it's not gonna
come from it yet yeah that's the thing
with Broadway it's like even if you get
this touch right here and you're able to
get your combo get to an aircraft Ender
or whatever the thing is even if you
just end the combo back to that same
spacing standing under the timer yeah
you go get checked bro that's a full
cavity search when he puts his hand like
that in your body like that he's sleep
looking for something and he found it
moai and die to hide here
see again the jockey position here oh
and the combo after the wall bounce that
moai was able to get and the high low
that he's able to put in want to die
great four bars magic circuit gonna
spend one here have the hard knock down
as well reach up went first rap did it
again classic type of just like Mass
grab their Greek too slow to react to it
match grab again here we go die with
another chance here bar building
that's the full screen super that row
has access to Moon Drive reversely go
through the normals pressure time Shield
exchange and then they both neutral
jumped at the same time it was really
the same ideas it's such great gameplay
seeing their mirror coming together like
this
and again look at the positioning here
die trying to stay just outside the
timer so that he can yeah
and find that launch attempt
again that's just simple 3.2 K and then
reset back into the same position you
know it might be lower damage but
honestly lower consistent damage is
going to win you out and look at this
conversion to close out here for die
excellent conversions
oh I had four counts of magic circuit
because he couldn't find a place to use
it at the end that's the thing
especially against the character with
projectile coverage like that you can't
just get full screen and activate heat
because that's a free juggle you marry
the joke essentially so you have to find
the same activation in order to do that
you need to find a hit exactly shield
shield oh my goodness the way that he's
let go just in time so they're able to
take advantage here the slide right
underneath side switch gets the launcher
hard knockdown comes out and then again
the punish on that Shield that Shield
punishers have been excellent between
these two they've really been in each
other's heads with the low shield and
low Shield punishes so far in mid-range
bait and punished on the DP moai getting
a little bit desperate here
that's two that's two times he's willing
to just go into that last hit with Max
Peter clock out and take as much damage
as possible so as far as health values
you know row has got a decent amount of
health and with 5K that is almost half
of that life
the thing too is again look at how this
pressure to buy and low from moai oh
backdash could have been really risky he
knows that he has to make something
happen here this is a big round
it is I mean we are again we're in three
out of five for winners loses a brand so
there can be a little bit more set play
here and a little more time to adjust
but bullwin doesn't want to give die
that 2-0 Advantage yeah that's the
biggest that's the big thing especially
in this position and you see that's a
common type aluminum tactic there when
we talk about air footsies sometimes
being able to fish around your opponent
who's in the air the actions that they
take in the air are gonna give them
additional Landing recovery so what
you'll see at a high level a lot of
times is it's about maneuvering your way
using the momentum and movement that
this game gives you to position yourself
where you can catch your opponents
Landing recovery or just run up and go
low on him dump your meter to take the
round like Moana just did
that was a really great use of the
spacing the back dashing understanding I
think these two have such a fundamental
understanding of what the characters do
but also how the other one plays you
gotta you gotta put respect on the
character too this is obviously one he's
consistently been one of the strongest
characters in this game wow just
reversal lightning super just like that
yeah EGP action from die you could tell
that moai had something in that box
pocket too but die was just quicker on
the uptake and now here we go this is a
big chance for moai here if he's able to
retain Corner positioning here make a
play on the heat activation or we'll get
a big punish on this reversal attempt
that is unfortunate
huge trouble yeah that he has one of the
best reversals in the game but it can
also be a liability
lightning comes in oh again that was
another liability that could have been
detrimental but the slide under God his
legs go so far the shield yomi in that
game went in moai's favor that shield
and then the full screen tackle like
that gives you a free juggle if on hit
so like that he was able to just really
just leverage a really good Shield guess
there in the into the end into the round
the first opening here does go to moai
that double slide under really shocking
for position like you said earlier goes
with the overhead doesn't get it that
time it does it's going to continue to
open up dive but just a little at a
range but it doesn't matter because you
have that right
you have tools for every spot on screen
but why with the hard rebound here
that was a perfect another perfect
Boi one of those people that you know
just do it yo robot players have one
brain cell they share the same rates and
it's on stage right now single brain
cell on stage
nice again a big Shield BC this time
from die gonna get the wall
side switch once again throwing him into
the corner 3.7 K wow that was a good mix
chase down Tech on the grab look how
much slower we're playing oh God they
really do have one green cell but why in
the red dress but runs in the lightning
that's again this is the problem you
have to respect those lanes that he
creates you have to either get inside it
or be able to try to make it whip make a
call from there full screen ax2 gonna
close that out much cleaner from die
yeah they've had hard adjustments on
both sides but here we go this time
moai's turn
we talk a lot about in this game is you
get an advantage when you start being
the person who can actively adjust
faster than Europe I have seen more
baited in punish DPS this set so far
than probably the real weekend nice
finds the low touch again another
awkward situation after the LTD life
[Music]
that was dangerous especially because
Dai had four bars to work with he was
looking through for any opportunity to
be able to safely activate eat there get
some help back stop the clock moai what
a call with that super
you know what I love seeing is how
excited they are to be playing right now
are you guys excited for this Winter's
finals
it's just like that but why answering
back too got died locked and loaded in
the corner
back up but that's okay even that
situation you're looking for a text and
to be able to do lightning again to pin
them and look for a bigger opening there
he's trying to create an opportunity
where dye is gonna attack in the
lightning
all right side switch launch comes out
and just goes straight to the hard
knockdown nothing fancy but this is
guy's opportunity gonna build up his
third count of magic circuit which is
going to lend him so much feeder to work
with
the back foot here Shield bet after the
Miss Tech throw
after that he knew he was outside a
range just barely outside of range and
got big payback for it but boa right
back at you got the bars to finish too
and he's gonna do it I really like
though that he only chose to spend one
bar so he can come into this with that
meter and not have to worry about
building things up because they both
have full moon they spent a little bit
of it there but their gauges are
relatively similar yeah the big thing is
because that Moon gauge under the
character portraits that allows you to
do a moon Drive activation powerful
reversal option but it does have
recovery and it can get thrown but
basically look at Players like that just
use it to use the pause the screen and
react and see what's going on but why
leveraging his it's gonna get him buff
on his Moon skills as well super from
die ends his answer
wow that was incredible what a great way
to open this up die trying to bring this
back for them again using that ex that
full screen it's gonna be so great and
then the punish coming out from Moana
and look at the return here
grab all the way to the wall falling
jump C
shielded oh really delayed BC counter
but that does get dye out of the corner
yeah more I just committed the guard
Mash is low he's gonna build a third bar
here yeah it should by the end of this
combo yes if you yep gonna go ahead and
edit an arc drive that should close out
James Chen are you where's Dickson oh my
God oh God finished work moai could it
be my wife
three the three one three one moai 3-1
moving into Grand finals wow that's big
especially because MOA you know
obviously he missed top eight last year
right right but this is a player who is
very consistent in this game in terms of
being it president all the big
competitions especially in Japan he
likes to he plays a lot he shows up to
the weekly gatherings I mean I I run one
you know outside of a a game spear but
he is consistently one of the players
that shows up and he's willing to play
he wants to put in that grind he wants
to win in this game we saw him at the
announcement special right doing that
for exhibition exhibition with the
championship and he he put him on his
back and speaking of which coming up
next man Okay I uh I missed out on this
one yesterday but you you call it sure
so we saw this yesterday in pools this
was the winners final of a particular
pool so Jimmy and Jing went up against
each other Jing took it 2-0 over Jimmy
had some really incredible reads once
Jane figured out Jimmy's game plan the
way that he wanted to throw those keys
the way he wanted to set everything up
Jing was able to adjust there was a lot
of EX Ladle into the corn Corner into
that ex table there was a little bit of
the Bento setups and Jing was just able
to really get the adjustments that were
necessary to shut Seattle down
particularly taking her out of the air
eliminating that option what's so cool
about this matchup for the players is
that both of these players you see on
stage have a just completely different
mentality you know Bronson on Twitter
said that he does he truly does not
belong I agree Jimmy J train is built
different that dude is that dude is just
uh he is not common and their
perspective legit as well their
perspectives on these fighting games
these are both multi-game players we
talked about that so much yesterday this
game for a lot of players that play
poverty games uh attacking street fight
whatever game you're playing a lot of
players kind of found a second home with
this game and you're seeing that play
out on the big stage like this Jin we
got to talk about his competitive
history
long-term qualifier from multiple games
in the toke SBO series whether it was
melts blood react actress again current
code whatever the case may be uh Super
Street Fighter 4 Dan gecki blue if you
name it he's played it
this is just the game that he likes
right now and he's the one he's going
hard and and uh Mr Nash needs no needs
no further introduction I think most of
you guys know where this guy is coming
from but I remember watching this guy
playing third strike and doing some
crazy stuff with yurien and I was like
this dude is raw and then I saw him
doing some tech and stuff and I was like
this dude is raw then I saw him playing
Street Fighter 4 and I was like man I'm
noticing the consistency here this
dude's pretty good but again my thing to
me would I really take away from him and
just listen to him talk about fighting
games is the way Jimmy J trans
perspective on being a competitor being
somebody who wants to be the best what
kind of mentality that takes and man the
way I I've heard him on a certain show
kind of talking to another popular
content creator talking about um
having faith in your ability as a
competitor to adapt so after the loss
yesterday after Jimmy J train came out
for I went around Evo Japan came to Tada
guy Tuesday hey he hit me up he's like
yo where are people playing this game I
say coming to Sonic I Tuesday man and uh
he sat down he played with jyn for like
an hour and then we never saw him again
man a mystery but what I'm curious about
is what is Jin's response to this you
know you get this double jeopardy
scenario like this how is he gonna play
especially being like you said
leveraging shield and other defensive
mechanics to mitigate as much damage and
Zoning potential as possible from those
black keys that CL is going to be
throwing and one thing that we've seen
consistently from Jing is that he is
quick to adapt and once he understands
what his opponent is throwing out he
will punish that until the opponent
makes an adjustment very two very
rational players too and the big thing
about this is both of these characters
which you can see it's not really the
most crazy kind of movement they
highlight something very simple about
this game and it's the best thing about
this game the movement watch how these
watch how these players pilot these
characters yes the movement is what sets
melty blood apart from other series and
it's it that's what draws people to this
because you can move so freely
it does and look at the respect that the
two of them have to be but they are
caught with the air Ladle and the dust
set up this is the start of how Jake
likes to play clean into that ex table
because he's built the bar he also has a
bar here probably gonna no did not
decide to end an ex Ladle but that is
something I want people to watch out for
yeah so the big thing is those cake
extensions off a hit it's really just
about adding damage getting a little bit
more positioning so that he so we can do
that simple jump over okazemi they can
do it's very basic but very effective
just because of how visually ambiguous
what side she can fall on it and then
Jinky control and make her fall on
different sides so Jimmy J with this
hard knock down here Bento set the bomb
is Bomb is playing yeah okay and now you
have the ex dust which is really
difficult to move around but because of
that Jing was able to throw over the
dust and create the situation where
Jimmy could not get out of the overhead
does come out Jing so clean it's like we
said right if you like ECW if you like
The Dudley boys this is the character
for you she's coming with tables she's
coming with ladles we should come to the
chairs she's just jumping through the
air using Juggernaut brains on you but
here we go
Simplicity from Jing just jump out of
the corner nothing fancy but it's clean
so the reason why Jin is also setting
that Bento mine is because that's again
a lane you can cut off on the screen it
functions as a mine essentially so if
Jimmy wants to try to run in and press
offense he has to beware of running into
those mental sets because that's going
to give jyn a free launch the way that
these two are playing this is God like
using the rush punch down and here we go
this is gonna be good carry good damage
cake extension I'm assuming no not
willing to spend the bar here she's
gonna take the knockdown hard knock down
off that air super and now the double
jump there through the BC counter so if
you also press that button that's when
you get that situation where they cross
each other up in those sets and this is
going to be the hard part for Jimmy is
opening up the easily player especially
someone who's as good defensively as Jim
she's so Queen every decision is
tactical and it's calculated
and again just take my hard knock down
here
overhead coming out bento's set up Bento
with the cake goes for it
dust cloud lock you oh my god Jimmy this
is finally get opened up by the overhead
it's a shame that that whole 10 seconds
of him blocking was incredible and like
you said the visual confusion the way
that he was mixed he could not see the
character because Ciel was behind the
Bento and the table the cake set like
that takes place in the foreground so it
creates visual Mix-Ups like that exactly
Jimmy's still able to see the overheads
and blocks and he just committed the
guard that's something that this if you
listen to him talk about his perspective
on a lot of games especially
competitively option rotation is very
important for him whether it's mashing
on you know this this scenario or
committing the guard in the scenario
where normally we would look to do
something else here you go big air fatal
hit this could be big damage from CEO
this is launched or safe chop set up
four six four eight that's not bad
damage right now kicking and grabbing
right like we said before Striker is
super important for cl as a character it
is her this is her offense and we're
seeing it right here set up very quickly
throwing everybody
jumps against brief overhead that could
have been it but unfortunately Jane
catches it Jing went for a one thing and
a perfect from Jimmy
what CL can do if you can play that
strike though very well and Jimmy J
trans is obviously coming from his his
background he is very good at watching
opponents defensive habits you got to
think about how he plays Tekken right
he's used to looking for people hey what
kind of defensive techniques do you use
if I do the first two hits of the string
he's brought that skill and ability to
this game especially with regards was so
smart and then the projectiles coming
out Jimmy taking advantage of this
corner situation he's got full moon he
spends one count of magic circuit who's
he gonna do it again though the micro
charge something we saw so much from
Jimmy yesterday building it up another
huge hit from Jimmy
again big damage here is gonna be what
45-92
good stuck wins Jimmy
this could be really big he's gonna get
all of that vital Source the recoverable
Health back pressuring Jimmy back in the
court Jimmy patient I heat out from him
and that was scary he waited for the
last moment of the blood heat activation
if that would have gotten made it would
have been game
he got shielded Jimmy and the porter
gets hit with the overhead from James
big table here again gonna juggle him no
bars here to work with so he's gonna
have to take this and get the air
knocked down simple mix up here on the
same side
probably do an uh anti-back Dash OS
there able to snipe him with that low
reaching
[Music]
stop the clock
ten fatal counters
okay
Jimmy J Tran is knocking on the door
right here doing something crazy and I
just want to point out we're back to two
out of three
next game oh my God Jimmy J Tran versus
the defending Evo Champion Jing
oh wow this is going to a game three I
did not have this on my crystal ball I
didn't have anything on my crystal ball
at this point throw the whole bracket I
did not see this melty blood type Lumina
at Evo 2023. let's go in Double Jeopardy
too
the first times that Jing has used item
throws that is something he uses so
rarely yeah it's it's kind of hard to
use against CL just because of the
threat of keys right it's barely he's
further reacting she can you don't want
to try to play this item Pro game versus
her like that you have to use item throw
with different applications wow and
again look at how these oh there he goes
they work as Wreckers almost so you saw
there Jim was willing to press Jimmy J
just let it rip he did gonna spend the
ex here again this is such a consistent
combo Virginia agency I'm just doing the
jump kick say jump like that this is all
just like safe pressure and using the
reverse open system another big counter
hit this character in her offense is
again strike throw she's very good at
being able to punish you for Aaron
presses Jimmy leveraging all the meter
to go up set point against the Evo 2022
you
[Music]
okay okay this is a big one
Jane with four bars to work with damn
near
what's the approach trophy big jump
table
the cheek has everything to work with
don't think he's gonna spend it all here
he's gonna send one to that table
this Voyage here was so hard
does he have to give it up now though he
doesn't want to
take extension this is that clean
gameplay we saw so much yesterday and
which way is the trip same side huh
that's gonna close out okay so this is
big final round
oh my God I did not have this pen at all
Jimmy J Tran versus Jin
to see who's gonna go to lose his finals
the respect the way they're just walking
catches bright weaves through the
projectiles default Fade Away table like
this and three bars built you know he
just wants to go with the knockdown
every time take extension you're gonna
take the damage from it
gonna get that hard knock down all
shielded
oh what a wake up from Jimmy
cash
he's put him into the corner
oh he just spent one he's gonna build a
third one
the check on the throw Jimmy getting it
with the overhead he's trying everything
it can you have to be aware ex little
though this is the Haymaker
air unblockables the Finish like that
Jimmy's a Tran over the defense over the
defense winning 22 Champion that is
crazy Jimmy he's moving on to losers
finals wow
[Applause]
I am speechless I don't know what yo
this is uh this has been a fun one so
far man I did not have any of that on my
bracket man I did not see that cover I
just want to reiterate
jingus who put Jimmy into losers
oh what did I what did I say though
that's the way he is a loss
you just take it for what it is you
figure it out you adapt he came into
this set with a fresh perspective fresh
mindset and again was not getting caught
with a lot of anti-shield on keys he
just forced his offense forces mix up
and went to the safe jump okay a lot and
it worked out for him and he had some
fat Combos and huge opportunities where
he saved resources and right before this
we were talking about how during that
Winner's final set yesterday uh during
pools is how Jing was so good at cutting
off that air movement from Jimmy CL and
he did not get that opportunity I have
to say the adjustment that we saw in
less than 24 hours from Jimmy was really
impressive and got him so far in this
bracket and he is not done he overall
played a lot more grounded he went to
some of the Recca mix up with the
projectiles but that was uh that was a
crazy set man I can't believe that went
down that way but I I can't believe the
losers final match we got coming up guys
but look don't go anywhere we'll be
right back with more of this melty blood
type Lumina top six here at Evo 2023
at Chipotle real food always starts with
real ingredients in real kitchens when
you order Chipotle real food starts with
you whether it's in restaurant pickup or
delivery however you Chipotle is the
easiest way to Chipotle
oh no
super Rola
Victory feels good
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
hey what's up everyone we at tenno are
Beyond excited to announce the launch of
some brand new merchandise for Evo
beginning with our new officially
licensed Street Fighter designs which
include premium embroidered hoodies and
more also we have new officially
licensed designs for the King of
Fighters 15 Guilty Gear Tekken and other
fgc partners each tenno product is
carefully designed by fgc heads with
only the best material for maximum
comfort and style trust me you don't
want to wait to cop these
what's up everybody I'm Persia joined by
vicious and we are here for Evo
connections presented by acnt y'all been
seeing us all weekend we've been putting
in that work but with all these
exclusive games and demos I think it's
time for a little bit of play what do
you say oh yeah I've been looking
forward to this all weekend long let's
get it let's get it hey oh sorry I'm
sorry no sorry setup I was so ready I
was so ready I was like you got to play
me for the setup all right
what
oh yeah that's how you feel playing
water damn
oh no
yeah oh that was sick I didn't think I
was gonna trade the way it did I'm doing
it
give it to me oh
[Music]
God
yeah that's another thing yeah I'm gonna
go I'm gonna go with Kenshin he looks
the coolest
he's praying
I
got one
you got back breaker oh my spider
what does he do after that oh
girls let's go this is what I've been
looking forward to all weekend all
weekend
I cannot wait
time Daddy's won't go long I love it
[Music]
oh no am I dead
we broke the tie breaker it got a little
bit sweaty at the end but overall we had
a lot of fun right I tried my best but I
definitely need to play like 100 more
games one is just such a tease
um absolutely slowed forward I'm glad
you guys made that connection as well
it's been an absolute blast and you've
been tuning in to evil connection
presented by a t
what's up everyone I'm here to let you
know that chipotle is leveling up Evo
2023 with a dedicated Community Lounge
at that Lounge they have mini pickup
brackets with fun competition all day
winners will walk away with some nice
Evo and chipotle goodies they also are
doing Special giveaways for example a
daily unique pin giveaway if you'd like
to check that out but for attendees who
just want to chill and relax they have
charging stations as well as a main
stage viewing Lounge for you to check
out all the action right here on this
stage over there at that dedicated
Community Lounge but don't worry for
those who are at home and viewing we got
you you can get involved with Chipotle
by partaking in their giveaway their
text giveaway do not forget Chipotle is
giving away 14
000 free burritos make sure you text
information below so you can enter for a
chance to win now the competition has
been exciting and thrilling and we gotta
keep it going so commentators take it
away
welcome back everybody to Las Vegas
Nevada here for Evo 2023 and if you want
to see the conclusion of this melty
blood type Lumina top six
can y'all hear me out there
so with that said we're gonna get into
our next match this is the losers final
it's gonna be your first three Affair I
have no idea how we got to this point
but it's gonna be Jimmy J trying rep in
the United States of America going up
against dye from Japan
I
I was talking earlier I had a bracket
that bracket is far and gone
been completely destroyed Jimmy the
surprise player I mean it's not a
surprise if you know history
but I got a surprise but it's a surprise
to see him taking down champion after
champion after Champion but the
mentality is there can he keep it going
against the likes of dye who's been so
strong only so far losing to the mirror
the big thing now though to me I'm I'm
looking at this set and I'm I'm thinking
pressure's on die Jimmy at this point he
win the losers outside of pools he's won
10 sets in a row in this game
and you just you can't understate how
difficult it is to make it through
loser's bracket yes you're playing more
matches but you're also playing people
who are at the top of their game
dropping down out of winners the
pressure is always on there's some
there's certain people that can that
respond well to that pressure that is
the people that respond negatively to it
Jimmy to me I think it's just kind of
ice cold about it you just sit down and
play if I'm still in losers I can still
win that's the perspective I love seeing
those white tees out there let's go
so of course this is gonna be a robo
versus CL matchup CL actually because of
the threat of keys Roa has to be careful
about where he throws lightning it's
easy for cl to kind of dip outside the
range and be able to punish with full
screen full screen keys and then or of
course her full screen super he has a
full screen super as well so you might
even see kind of like a like a kind of
standoff kind of approach to this
because both projectiles can be kind of
dangerous to throw out against the other
characters the thing about Ciel though
over Roa is that she does have an
advantage with the range on her
projectile it does give her a little bit
of an edge in that full screen game but
Jimmy doesn't want to play and that
jumping split kick that you saw from
Jimmy there that hits on both sides
that's a cross-up button as well so
going to the air with it finding the
Fatal finding 4.365 damage and the
corner that's a big win for him died
though willing to swing for this back to
the wall has beat her gonna queue up in
the super is it gonna be same side or
other side same side bro
staggers is pressure he's able to find
the mid hit there gonna convert here off
the Jump to see that shot air chopped
like that
[Music]
saw that flash when Jimmy was blocking
of the missed Shield attempt he knew
that that Jimmy was looking for an
opening to try to Shield like that right
let me hit the brakes for a second
there's the shield he goes in for a
punish gets the round so CL is able to
alter her air trajectory it can
completely throw up her game plan if
that was something that happened they're
giving Jimmy the advantage of this first
exchange here but Jimmy has shown you
this a lot that's gonna be really
important for this match because of the
threat of roller skp those air super
Enders for Jimmy where he spends a bar
and gets a safe jump set up
such a good combo here from Jimmy the
micro charge as well has to be able to
get that 50 to activate Moon Drive
Jimmy's gonna take the return from that
I love that he did not spend the meter
there he comes in with so much you have
to be aware about CL espec when she's up
close like that she has strings into
that standing charge slash as well
that's naturally kind of frame trap and
be able to catch Magic
but the Invincible reversal option from
Jimmy somersault
OTG full wall push for personal DP
these two are playing such a cerebral
game right now this is definitely it
feels like I know scares you don't scare
kind of match for sure it doesn't the
throw comes out speaking of not scared
that throw is just so great but it
worked yeah that's that to me is also
like a winning point for him being able
to integrate throw into his offense is
important for cl just because if it
opens up for the rest of that strike no
pressure that you have but here we go
die with a good leverage this Gage here
to close out the game goes to the level
three five okay damn he's gonna drop a
5k Arc Drive finish on you die up
one game
reminder that the remaining games are
three out of five so we are going to
have some active adjustments being made
there's so much you can do with an extra
game
see now yeah just shocking for position
both players are looking to get an
air-to-air counter hit to be able to
convert like that but either player
willing to press any big buttons and
give them the opening no yeah I mean you
don't want the risk you don't want that
the technology for both players opening
here from Jimmy I'm gonna take die into
this corner heart knocked down after the
ex Ender yeah
that jumping split kick like that jump
and put this Fabric in the air
unblockable Jimmy's been so good about
not using that jump and unfortunately
does get caught there by the umbrella
yeah or something like that but easy
reaction from Dodge lock him up with the
lighting get that double roundhouse
unblockable and create this pressure
scenario throw you back to Center Stage
for the throw in that situation because
Jimmy's blocking has been very good when
he commits the guard yeah
here you go super yeah do it again it's
not even necessary after that lean round
from die
die is playing at such a I mean
Immaculate game but if Jimmy can make
these adjustments I can easily see him
coming back position
he has to be where a moon skill
lightning because it hits a little bit
further but if you can get into that
spot and make that whip with a backlash
or something give yourself a huge nobody
right now they'll die able to find the
big touch no bar to work with gonna take
us to simple air throw Enders follow the
sea Jimmy willing to Shield I'm willing
to wait I'm willing to punish you one
bar built Now Launcher 3.5
another big counter hit touch here Moon
Drive activation big drop oh I'm gonna
give this guy I've seen way too many
matches with this guy do not give Jimmy
J train the opportunity especially with
four parts
to be able to convert like this in the
corner has so much to work with sister
sister
caught with the overhead Jimmy working
his way back into this match die can he
if he wants to but now we're gonna get
another ex Ender building up that third
bar with that Micro Charger oh my God
hard call out on the shield
we're seeing those adjustments as Jimmy
we're seeing them right now can he
continue to make them and get high in a
place taking us back to church
this the real Sister Act safe jump off
the air super
Bowl falling kicks
oh Whoopee Goldberg eat your heart out
oh
he's gonna build this fourth bar David
here he's gonna go into nope
they're not taking anything die you
better not met oh my God
no don't heat activation stop the clock
if Jimmy is willing to back off die take
your HP that's fine dump your meter like
that gets caught low unfortunately died
not enough Peter to be able to make this
game hurt a lot 2.8k that's fine still
has his pressure good break on the
ground from Jimmy guy position
oh my gosh beautiful conversion from the
intro he's got enough it's over that's
Jimmy J trying baby it's over
take me to school let's go
foreign
[Music]
here
One Touch situation but Jimmy gonna get
an opener here built with his third bar
he's willing to pay be patients wait it
out attack the grab and then just runs
upstairs
activation into the Invincible reversal
smart from die but Jimmy was making a
comeback yeah this is a back and forth
this is a back and forth
uh open up low
you can get me now in this corner
recovery though it Shields the lightning
and then Jimmy with that fast movement
speed pushing die into the other side he
has been leveraging Shield quite a bit
not necessarily going for any of the
follow-ups every time
again
[Music]
what is tasty Steve do it again
guess the launcher though from zai had
three bars sitting on almost full moon
if he wants to use it he's gonna spend
one there for that full screen ex same
side though open up
staggered pressure they're gonna work
out big for dog gonna close out this
game 2-1 advantage over Jimmy J Tran
Jimmy though had some really good
moments there the throws were great I
mean we talked about it earlier strikes
are so important for Ciel and the way
that he's mixing it up making it
unpredictable is so important to note
yeah and on defense has been really good
for him too you could tell his intent in
a lot of these scenarios he's either
committing the guard he'll commit the
shield he's making like some some pretty
big commitments and reads on he's trying
to make reads on dye's offense but right
now dive with Advantage here first to
three Affair die up two ones
really respectful in this first part of
the game this is what we're talking
about with air foot season the way
they're leveraging their Arab Mobility
options their fastest air-to-air buses
like this they're looking for a big
counter hit me that worked out okay
by the IAT after I thought it was so
smart
sometimes it just doesn't work out like
that but the big thing was he got past
the lightning he did and then an opener
here for Jimmy Max rain's damn dude that
kick like that unfortunately unable
to close out on them that was such a
delay on the B counter frogs die but
Jimmy had the opportunity to turn around
and block it that was important
he's playing around that range that I
pointed out earlier like seeing a lot of
Dash blocks Dash mate he's trying to
beat out a big response to die whether
it wants to be lightning or something
else nice flipkick
that happens sometimes it's unfortunate
but Jimmy not phased was able to put
that Shield away that could have been
huge but die being able to make this
workout spending a lot of meter here
with this new Drive activation he's
still got half of it left and it's going
to be one away from moving on set point
for die here against Jimmy J Trans
in melty blood type aluminum I think I
was gonna say that this weekend
all the shield is held too long and so
Jimmy was stuck in recovery allowing dye
to get this open yeah
push towards the wall throw him out just
oh just to dash back in intercepted
again that proud to be from CL that big
two speeding swinging uppercut it's
really big difference trying to get
these opportunities for big conversions
like this once again charging always
making sure that moon is available in
case they need to drive for Activation
big opening punished here for Jimmy
though can you see him showcasing a lot
more reverse feet it's a multi-plus
specific mechanic where you can chain
normals backwards it's a little bit oh
my God the falling jump scene that was
huge a huge opportunity for guy here you
gotta meter Side High
but yo clap it up out there for Jimmy J
trans
system
that was awesome to watch I didn't
that's uh that's a pleasure I I never
thought I'd get to talk about one of
those guys man that's cool when I was
playing third strike and watching him do
work with Yuri and that was uh never
something I thought I would have to
change the view but I'm glad it happened
with this game right here today
and coming up next is going to be grand
finals man this was a hell of a set
though for losers I nobody saw Jimmy J
Trey doing work in this tournament like
this
and looking at this replay the way that
Dai was able to close this out and move
into the winners by or the grand finals
just such cool calculated gameplay the
ability to adjust and readjust use every
tool that melty blood hands you and use
it so well to shut down the game plan
from Jimmy Jimmy taking out absolute
Legends in the melty blood and fighting
game Community like I said we you gotta
understand he he dropped in the losers
at the end of his pools play match
he won 10 straight stats to be able to
get here and to get third place at this
event like that and uh like I said
that's uh that's I keep saying it's a
surprise to be honest with you it's not
that guy any fighting game he puts his
head his mind to uh you can always
expect them to be a top level competitor
just again his perspective on
competitive attitude is always something
that kind of stuck with me just hearing
him talk about it but coming up next
baby this
it's been a long couple days it's been a
long two years I've been waiting to see
a bracket like this on I've been waiting
to talk to you all about this game for
two years bro I can't believe they fed
it to me on Saturday morning like this
with Jalen of all people but coming up
next this is going to be the grand
finale
play Spot big one second moai going up
against die here in melty blood type
bloom in the top six finals for Evo 2023
this is going to be
batch of all time it's going to have so
much counter play I still expect the
mirror so it's going to be a little
ridiculous but before we get started
can you guys make some noise from melty
blood type Lumina grandfather
s
[Applause]
I gotta admit Jalen you uh you should
sell you you should be in sales I bet
you should be doing like this you should
be selling the insurance policies or
something
the weight you just pitched me this
rower mirror match that we're about to
see I uh I was buying it I was buying it
for a little bit but I know we're about
to see some a lot of zoning we're about
to see a lot of and again uh beats on
defensive patterns right that really
came to play when these guys fought on
the winner side was callouts on whether
you want to crouch Block in mid-range
whether you want to try to go for your
Shield option taking in you know tick
throws is obviously a big part of this
character's pressure as well but the big
thing is jockey per position being just
outside of their lightning range where
you can Dash up and quickly adapt or
Shield call out that what they want to
do with their zoning patterns and how
they cut off Lanes in the screen this
character is of course a zoning monster
but he does have good if if not basic
good standard up close pressure thanks
to his instant air Dash in those big big
jumping buttons that he has
I
I've been looking forward to this
for so long
when we got to have melty blood at Evo
2022 it was so exciting and we keep
talking about the international
competition the number of people who
were able to come out from a multitude
of different countries in particular
yesterday we had someone from Spain who
was just unbelievable and here we have
two of Japan's finest fighting it out in
Grand finals I'ma tell y'all right now
moai he looks like a goofy dude he's
always all smiles and stuff what he was
telling me before Evo he said I'm coming
here I want to win
[Music]
he's enjoying the moment but right now
this is a roller mirror match if you can
see them trying to space each other out
full speed get out of Ranger skill
lighting like that but why with the big
touch so far
Winner's side advantage to moai as well
so in case you want to make sure and if
you're at home because mirror matches do
get a little bit difficult to die is in
the traditional custom with the white
moai is in the darker colors of that
blue and what we want to point out to
you guys is again the counter play here
right watch for being able to the
spacing around lightning set but also
watching how these players block how
they shield and watch how the other
player counters that activation with
that strategy yeah and the lightning of
the ex lightning we're going to see that
so many times because it's a great
zoning tool as well as punish tool there
it is once again yeah Health Shield that
time you gotta imagine but why takes
notice of it jump shielding on each
other but moa's the one that gets the
hit he's got the bar to finish it
barring any drops and there he goes moai
clean once again
[Music]
then pre-round movement is very similar
and then again charging once again a die
able to get this opening
just so cool that's what's so good about
the lightning it's like if they jump in
Pocket cool I get it unblockable if they
sit and block it cool I get a mix of
them yes knock down into the corner oh
just uses the raw launcher yeah
let me see what's up there I watched the
oh
we go air ball and for side
swapping no Center Stage
oh my God the awareness to know that he
was looking for the heat activation like
that doesn't even know West backlashes
tap dances around the activation
Shield comes out this is giving Die
Another chip okay he's gonna close up
that was very scary for my watch that
drop could have been could have gone way
differently but why with game Advantage
[Music]
one of the strongest players in the old
days but oh why since release has gone
to this road this roller character he
identified the strengths early on
showing you why here launcher hard
knockdown comes out afterwards that b
jump was so smart
exactly the dash is delay it see the
shield fine the shield hit them as hard
as possible 4K in another drop you're in
the same situation you got the same
problem
twice overhead coming out launch here
let's close it out 3.5 K doesn't matter
because it ends the round he's so strong
moai is looking
ridiculous
lightning right there lock him down like
Akon lock him up
oh what an interesting object does it
again yes your PC it goes to the ball
gonna get the side switch here and again
Peter has been built for die he just
hasn't had the opportunity to use it no
that's okay
yeah then lock it down with lightning
runs up takes a slow match here straight
up just confirm the low
three bars built ends in the hard
knockdown nothing fancy shielded and
then once again just that launching
option it's a great opener and then you
have double lightning slide underneath
going to use it a third time and then
end in an ex with that screen
but high on reads he saw that with
Shield got the low touch unable to
finish with it
they're flying in the air those VCS were
getting them out of it back oh it's
caught though not gonna do enough
the low does come out the front dive
so much meter no he's got he's got the
round that's it
oh there it is even if you have to spend
the bar you do it in that situation just
get to what's important is get to the
next round
the thing with my why they're even
they're even on that on super they're
gonna die with the advantage on the moon
gauge yeah and that was a fatal counter
as well that's a big pickup again
straight to the wall and an air grab
gonna drop that time doesn't go for the
jump kick but he was looking for the low
was looking for a high Shield Maybe
I think Mo I thought that I would
anticipate that so didn't wanna didn't
want to have to worry about it mixing up
the pressure is such a great thing and
now once again one slides another slide
there goes into the ex that's awesome
rotation here that's our midi throw
broken
Shield same idea and then the slide
underneath from the line scramble your
man my wife has really really pulled off
really good leads in scramble situations
like that
again
is looking for something dying trying to
find the opening with Shield though and
then the delayed launcher afterwards
they both just backed after this that's
a common Shield scenario there's the
display a launcher out of the shield
catches a lot of options that you
wouldn't expect
once again it's so effective
prostates
the throw comes out afterwards trying to
reverse the situation but the lows moai
one round away okay on tournament Point
here Evo 2023 for type luminous
but then the shield he went for because
there were so many highs and that means
that might go low for free that third
time's the charm here meter building
gets the Micro Charger between falling
jump kick no grab hold Shield that was
so risky lightning lockdown
but winding on the other side do I need
to spend Gage just to get out try to
give him a shot of suppression
it's a speaker version opportunity three
bars yes
you're right that was huge that could be
something that completely changed the
tide of this suspends the bar here
same side oh my God that was so
ambiguous all starting from a fat DC one
comes out there crosses up otherwise if
once he gets lightning at close range
like that and die here
with the advantage went in for a low
that was risky but now using that back
dash that could have been caught so much
earlier using the ex lightning to come
in the low caught from moai he let him
live
activation
to make the play here yeah what is it
Moon Drive occupation
a little axlow gets it he puts it around
that's part of that post Moon Drive
activation yomi there right if he would
have gone to a different option instead
of guard like that he might add a shot
of it
slide comes in but the weight died
floated out of the situation so great
caught in the air though and you see
that jumping chop that Roma has in that
situation where he jumps up uses his
fastest airbun to get a fatal counter
like that easy conversion to the ground
Japan moai
let's go let's go
and this is a player who has been in the
hunt for a long time he has not had that
Marquee win for him to come to this Evo
Japan that's Evo this Evo 2033 from
Japan sorry and be able to get this win
over some of his Rivals like that wow
and yo they're gonna give him the trophy
here that's your melty blood type Lumina
Champion for Evo 2023 everybody give it
up replace five big one second give it
up for moai
[Applause]
what a tournament I did not
been the ending kind of a surprise I'm
not gonna lie some of the names you know
we saw coming into this I was like yeah
I could see that yeah I expected but uh
man the way this played out and the way
it went down I did not I was not
expecting that man that was crazy I
wasn't either
but I'm so happy it went the way it did
it told a beautiful story from start to
end over 550 people entering a franchise
record set here at Evo 2023 and
everyone give it up for your top six of
melty blood type Lumina for Evo 2023
so we're gonna start from down the line
right tied for fifth we're gonna start
off with scrot Vermillion one of again
the leaders of the North American
Community came here didn't go the way he
wanted this year but big UPS to him
fifth place from Korea Korean wrestling
man doing work with that Mario and then
in fourth place
Jing coming all the way from Japan
fighting all of that travel to place
fourth here at Evo but hey I don't you
guys already know this guy's name yo
clap it up third place at type Lumina
for Evo 2023 Jimmy J Tran
in second coming out of seemingly
nowhere with this incredible Roa we have
die
Japanese man a mystery but the winner
for Evo 2023 type Lumina give it up for
the old man
moai
hey Mr Lee give him a hug man just give
him a hug bro come on
laughs
he wouldn't Vlog like three times but we
gotta get that swag
oh yeah so the prizes this year third
place you get a bronze stick
second place gets silver and of course
the golden sticks
Evo branded like that moai finally a
champion get clapping up for this whole
top six everybody
[Applause]
incredible yeah I'm happy uh man I can't
say how happy Anna was to be able to do
this like this I've been waiting since
the game came out to talk to y'all like
this and y'all gave me a hell of a
bracket to do it with but look Jalen I I
think that's it for our block you got
anything you want to say or leave them
with
play melty blood look I'm uh I'm
I'm really excited for what the future
holds especially for the French play
games you know we got uni 2 back that
came out of again seemingly nowhere yeah
but I can't wait to see what you guys
if you like the game man just play the
game bro but I'm looking forward to the
future I can't wait to see what we got
coming coming out and uh and also coming
coming forward to look in the next year
but that said I'm done I can't speak
anymore yo thanks for watching melty
blood type Lumina top six here at Evo
2023 we're gonna catch you guys next
time don't go anywhere though kof 15's
coming up that's gonna be a crazy
tournament I'm telling you come back
with it
our hands keep shaking but my heart
keeps strong though my legs keep aching
My Voice keeps on my soul keeps Rising
as I sing
and reinforce whether that is
the only option second is
[Music]
imagine
Brothers
[Music]
constant and this ain't my final form
keep shaking but my heart keeps strong
though my legs keep aching My Voice
keeps
your Chipotle order just got extra the
fighter coins from Street Fighter 6.
order any entree in the Chipotle app
using promo code hdkn 236 and receive
250 fighter coins with yours visit
chipotle.com sf6 for details
sir perhaps a new hunting ground
Creighton wants a hunt I'll give him one
he'll never forget better take him out
before they find the lizard
this gunship will quit I do not want to
be Liverpool
Red Bull gives you wings
oh no
super Rola
Victory feels good
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
I'll be strong prove myself
good
afternoon
[Music]
here we go
you can't believe
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
so I'm so
ignite the fire of a brand new age when
I hear my voice
[Music]
you can't believe
my voice
[Music]
scope because because I've arrived when
it's the only option second is
[Music]
defensive practical this is the
beginning imagine your boy you're level
two
my front trenches still coming against
us utterly specialist
on the floor my style has revered like
art on the wall if they didn't know
if I'm Evolution's constant and this
ain't my final form
[Music]
My Voice keeps on my soul keeps Rising
as I sing
[Music]
Corners down
yeah yeah
foreign
[Music]
ignite the fire of a brand new age when
they hear my voice
[Music]
you can't believe
My Voice keeps on my soul keeps Rising
as I sing my song
because I've arrived when it's the only
option second is
[Music]
number one contender
tenderness
[Music]
constant and this ain't my final form
till I fly in ways you can't believe
[Music]
I'll be strong prove myself
Corners down
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
believe you could be so much more made
for the moment in the era I forged live
from the minutes where the Legends are
born in the myths are forever when they
pen our Lord I hear every Echo inside of
the world clear I feel all the hopes
inside of the same fear shadows in the
same years when they tell us that it's
gone but y'all I'm still here
99 seconds is everything y'all have
prove yourself worthy I live in the
impact as soon as I push forward and
tell them to hold that roll back I don't
see any limit they're lacking the vision
and asking why the hell I would risk it
I'm basically different I'm everything
they say that the arcade era live in my
spirit don't tell me to move on as soon
as all the pressure gets too strong I
feel like I was born here for something
to prove wrong what was that moment when
you felt that sound and heard the crowd
Shake ground screaming one more round
let the lights flash over the main stage
I'm still Brave battling the Giants are
still made the real face that's that
choice ignite the fire of a brand new
age when I hear my voice
[Music]
My Voice keeps on my soul keeps Rising
as I sing my songs
[Music]
as soon as
Jaws on the floor my style has been
veered like art on the wall if they
ain't in the know better keep them in
form Evolution's constant and this ain't
my final form
[Music]
I'll be strong prove myself
everything
[Music]
here we go
my voice
[Music]
songs
believe you could be so much more made
for the moment in the era I forged live
from the minutes where the Legends all
born in the myths are forever when
they've been our Lord I hear every Echo
inside of the world clear I feel all the
hopes
[Music]
so I'm still
ignite the fire of a brand new age when
I hear my voice
[Music]
you can't believe
My Voice keeps on my soul keeps Rising
as I sing
[Music]
no better
till I fly in ways you can't believe
[Music]
I'll be strong prove myself
thank you
[Music]
here we go
till I fly away
[Music]
foreign
ignite the fire of a brand new age when
I hear my voice
[Music]
you can't believe
my voice
[Music]
foreign
till I fly in ways you can't believe
[Music]
oh
back brush it down
next I'll be strong prove myself
I'm still here
[Music]
there's enough
here we go
[Music]
till there's
foreign
[Music]
so I'm still
ignite the fire of a brand new age when
I hear my voice
[Music]
you can't believe
My Voice keeps on my soul keeps Rising
as I sing
because I cause I've arrived when it's
the only option second is
[Music]
defensive practical this is the
beginning imagine your boy a level two
running the trenches so coming against
us it's utterly senseless
[Music]
soon as they hit the door her jaw on the
wall got Jaws on the floor my style has
been veered like art on the wall if they
ain't in the know better keep
[Music]
till I fly in ways you can't believe
I'll be strong prove myself
[Music]
please
here we go
[Music]
my voice
foreign
[Music]
ignite the fire of a brand new age when
I hear my voice
[Music]
you can't believe
My Voice keeps on my soul keeps Rising
as I sing my songs
[Music]
this is the beginning imagine your boy
you're level two
Adventures so coming against us is
utterly senseless
revered like art on the wall if they
ain't in the know better keep
[Music]
them in for final four
till I fly in ways you can't believe
[Music]
Corners down
foreign
till I'm more than what they ask of me
[Music]
songs
foreign
[Music]
My Voice keeps on my soul keeps Rising
as I sing my songs
better than that
this is the rebound our systems go
because I've arrived when it's the only
option second is
[Music]
it was
the invisible this is the beginning
imagine your boy you're level two my
brothers
[Music]
My Voice keeps on my soul keeps Rising
as I sing my song
[Music]
I'll be strong prove myself
I'm still here
Corners down
[Music]
here we go
my voice
[Music]
foreign
ignite the fire of a brand new age when
they hear my voice
[Music]
you can't believe
My Voice keeps on my soul keeps Rising
as I sing my song
reinforce better than it is
[Music]
defensive pregnancy this is the
beginning imagine your boy you're level
two
utterly specialist
I know it for sure number one Contender
as soon as they hit the door her drawing
the wall now Jaws on the floor my style
has been veered like art on the wall if
they ain't gonna know
if I'm Evolution's constant and this
ain't my final form
[Music]
My Voice keeps on my soul keeps Rising
as I sing my song
[Music]
five
welcome back everybody we got Evo
connections presented by a t my name is
vicious here with the artist Ali and
going by the first move that I've seen
that really caught my eye 2.5 D and I'm
here with a man who wanted it himself
first and foremost what's your name man
how you doing hi my name is Chris uh
nice to meet you man it's absolutely
great to meet you no I've seen you like
over the years with some really really
impressive stuff but I've always wanted
to know what out of all the pieces that
you have here is your absolute favorite
you know if I had to pull out just one
piece I'd have to say it's probably the
uh kernel sugar campfire thing that we
have here long time favorite Corona
sugar fan and it just brings back a lot
of nostalgia so you got good taste my
man you know we got plenty more to go
through in the artist alley I do believe
Persia is under on the other side
somewhere let's take a look at what
she's got
it's Booth not only a legendary artist
but a legendary Marvel infinite player
as well I'm so excited to see you how's
your Evo been so far it's been crazy
tradition this is crazy it just makes me
happy to be here well I'm happy to see
you here again as well like I said
legendary artist has been at evil many
times and it's only getting bigger as
we're here I would love for you to share
your favorite art piece oh my favorite
artist is the ultimate
two years
two years ago yes I love the way you
transform all your favorite characters
into cats if you're a cat lover out
there you definitely want to check out
wave Chan's Booth it's so great to see
you and chat with you really quick
vicious what you got going on over there
this is one of my favorite booths that
I've seen throughout like so many
different confessions now I actually get
to talk to one of the people behind it
all first and foremost what is your name
and how you feeling hi I'm Madison
feeling great love the energy at the
show super sick actually now I I
personally have four of your prints I
had the one punch man the Pokemon one
the Cowboy Bebop one as well as the one
piece but I had to ask you it's been
bugging me all day because you have so
many different cool ones which one of
these pieces are your absolute favorites
probably Samurai shampoo which I have
over here uh this piece was inspired by
a Tarantino film posters I'm trying not
to get out of here like it's it's kind
of hard to try to make that connection
between anime and gaming it's just such
a such an easy connection really no
doubt well I appreciate your time that's
all we got for the artist Ali there's
plenty more to look around but in the
meantime enjoy all the action it's about
to come up here on the main stage
Evo 2023
uh
let them know what top Eight's coming up
Let The Arena know what top eight is
coming up
[Applause]
all right
this is a game excuse me this is a
franchise that has stood the test of
time first iteration of the game was
1994 and it is now 2023 and we are still
celebrating the King of Fighters
let's check out this kof-15 now before
we bring in our players let's kick it
[Music]
La Puerta
into others foreign
[Music]
thank you
wait wait one more time are we waiting
for some kof 15 top six action what are
we doing here
thank you that's the energy I need keep
it while we get these players out of
before we start the action can we please
get the legendary E.T to the stage
[Applause]
all right can we get lasted up here
lasted
come on up Lester let's go
[Applause]
yeah
and here comes an absolute staple no
stranger to this danger mad okay oh
[Applause]
another Legend takes the Evo stage in
multiple games but this is his prime
Zhao hi
oh
[Applause]
yeah all right I need I need everyone to
make this a loud one Make some noise
and one more time for our final top six
competitor give it up for more
all right crowd give it yeah give it one
more crowd this is your kof top six
let's do it
all right commentators hell pox and Cole
let's get this started boys
all right baby
I do believe it's time for some more KY
with 15a here at this beautiful Evo 2023
weekend I am your host Hill Pockets
joined by the mysterious one the
powerful one it's been a long time
brother but once again we are together
again Colton Max how you doing brother
oh I am fantastic yes I am called the
boys is Laos the accent is thick and the
hype is boiling Under the Skin we are
here to raise our voices to call for the
glory of these Champions because we are
playing the game of the people The
Humble people of this world
and I know the crowd is ready man they
begin ornery out there they've been
getting hype in their seats they're
walking around they can't have enough
and they're about to just get a little
bit more
it's time for top six and what about a
lot what about the lineup we got up here
oh they line up being fantastic so many
countries being represented right here
and this is the story we will be leaving
today we are going to witness these
Champions become Legends on the evil
stage we have people from Korea from
China from Taiwan from Mexico from Japan
five countries fighting for their legacy
on this beautiful game that's a pretty
that's a pretty big spread brother and
honestly man there's a couple names that
were in the polls the brackets earlier
uh didn't quite make it most notably zjz
previous year's evil Champion did not
make it into the top six picture so
there will not be a repeat from that man
but the evil Japan Champion xiaohai is
here sitting pretty on the Winner's side
looking Unstoppable also we have of
course lassit who was part of last
year's top eight for all the way from
Korea that fantastic Maiden it's
back and of course Jeremy so he is going
to be very very dangerous can't forget
about the ashes even Amanda Ash was
clutched the other day and we expect to
see more of that from him Matt kof
returning to kof top six another finals
day the original kof Evo Champion here
to reclaim the crown possibly I can't
wait to see it that's right and yeah
there you go they are here ready to dish
it out we are going to see from X gear
E.T from Kor lassit ready to fight each
other oh man speaking of previous evil
Champions E.T the kof 14 Evo Champion
back in 2017 also reaching grasping for
the crown
but he's got a lot of work cut out for
him he is still building that Onslaught
that he calls offense and we cannot
forget that last week in Mexico he
wasn't labeled to win yeah man third
place match back to us baby yeah yeah so
he of course wants to polish that
tarnished ground oh the selfie yeah
let's go that's how he moves into a
false sense of security Nancy lasted is
the kind of player that wants to like
hug you before and after the match but
during the match he's just strangling
you for 20 minutes pressure absolute
pressure that Lassie will be bringing
but here we go the characters are
selected we will be part of history at
this top eight it starts let's make some
noise
I got no predictions here let's just see
how it shakes out reactions a plenty
coming
oh it's gonna be fantastic let's go oh
he looks nervous this is how we start
you take a breather a moment of silence
a number of Peace yes get a lot of
oxygen drink water right now you guys
are gonna need it somebody give me some
water by the way yeah please
but here we go
it's going to start with Isla against
Lippy boy himself so here we start and
of course it is going to try to start
his own offensive with this series
trying to already push Maiden could into
the corner so last it's starting to
defend in this moment as evil starts and
kicks off not a ton of damage Mountain
up yet but at the same time lassit in a
bad position stuck in the corner E.T
unrelenting with that offense but
finally got slow down a little bit Psych
I was kidding hard knock down what's for
breakfast oh oh finally great grab get
out of there and now you're in the
corner pot with Elegance which style
with so much hierarchy ET just get out
of the corner just like that that jump D
is literally just designed to cross up
so when she's in the air you almost
gotta guess like hey is it gonna be left
or right depending on the button she
presses
okay now we can show me time
everybody would love some German time
I'm here the last name is unable to
start any kind of momentum I'm gonna say
Sherman may not even hit no time here
man oh my God this is oppression
absolute pressure from corner to corner
from coast to coast Jeremy can't travel
oh finally and now you have to deliver
as much damage as possible we're gonna
see the activation and some loving Parks
break in the back and the people are
loving it this is exactly what glass of
needed does to get some Rhythm back in
his step to get some bounce back in his
life not gonna kill the Isla but still
one more touch should do it oh trade E.T
will take that all day no not the day
one
which of those
pressing the bottom execution
idealation by
Etc but the problem pockets is that Ash
doesn't have a lot of money does not
have a lot in the pocket right now so
you get to play this a little bit frugal
okay great and here over there with the
projectile Ash Crimson can he be the
hero last his needs right now a hero to
Korea the anti-hero as it were no for
sure he's stealing everyone's Powers
let's see
I like it get it where you can brother
oh
here we go
great conversion over here fifty percent
only one bar this is the gold foreign
there is no no resources to keep going
that is a courageous play against a BJ
sailing in on you like that yeah you are
completely right the buccaneer Queen is
really making some moves at this moment
oh the slap respect me
what a challenge over there by E.T ex
time eating great representation here at
Evo 2023 and oh man that might be enough
because he's got two more bars to work
with that's gonna do it
oh such a beautiful girl sort of deadly
character bijanet the queen of kof right
now remember she doesn't have any like
full body ground-based rehearsals it's
got to be an ant here completely right
poor girl
the privilege right here that's what you
get when you did uh dedicate your life
to piracy it's looking pretty sharp
though lasted kind of caught on his
heels the entirety of that game uh gonna
need a big adjustment here gonna have to
start out Stronger Faster against Isla
at least not get pushed into the quarter
as quickly as they did previously okay
back into it we have the first point oh
I didn't mean that literally yeah he
went forward and tried to win everything
on that launch Bunch oh no but now it
gets open up and against the corner
there again again checking on those
suits checking those samples Anita is
simply released
oh no he's out of options I'm in your
mind boy
you show me a man that wake UPS
rehearsals and I'll show you a man
that's run out of ideas
[Music]
now assure me she has to shine lassit
leaves her Ash to be honest was a quite
fantastic but he needs the second
counter to do something just ET is not
allowing that great block and we've seen
some amazing things from glass and show
me over the not over the years
why that Rob that opportunity that
doesn't have to deliver a big punish
he's not taken still got three powers to
work with no activation no activation
he's trying to to save the resources and
playing footsies right now don't blame
him really he wants to kill with the
next touch so he's sure he wanted to
spin three bars there it is this is what
I just needed perfect and the plan
worked 37 seconds on the clock Sherman
is going to get at least 70 back and
that means he has three bars to fight
this video net so let's go
I was gonna say it's getting a lot of
challenges to slow down the PJ but he
just got equipped with the Parsi into
the many many missiles okay then wake up
rap I like it pushing forward on the
same side
checking it down and then going up yeah
sure we actually got some of the best
little bees in the game honestly those
low profile low D also really good great
uh distance on that comes up pretty fast
as well that's gonna hurt this is the
chance of loss is needed a lot of love a
lot of thoughts
yeah yeah level three let's go why not
right why not right do it why not
who would be that girl right now okay
the meter exists to blow it burn it
so let me close
he unflapped why unbothered how would
you do it I just wake up grab said he
should have killed me when you had the
chance you know you are playing K15 when
you wake up and grab that's for sure he
tried his best but the ass coming in
with one bar not a terrible situation
here but it's gonna say well they can
actually get what what
[Music]
that that was a
H that was odd yeah to be honest yes
Arduino entertained people oh we're
entertained for sure because the
cronin's on the screen four bars
everybody loves the Cronin anchor match
yeah man this is well loaded four
cartridges on the magazine you want to
talk explosions
you want to talk about fire throwing
anything
I didn't think it was going to catch
that that was a little bit outside
bringing the guns uh let's see I'm
trying to go forward trying to push two
bars for the ass though you better
believe if he gets the low B at any
point he's gonna activate he's also
trying to get that third one oh that's
gonna be it it's enough it's gonna be
enough little one let's go
E.T it's going to move forward into the
winners finals lasted we'll have to
survive
outside I I think there's is it
throughout the day I think there's three
out of five at trying to make up his own
rules on the floor
[Applause]
wait wait what's going on
it's a little bit about two out of three
a little bit of a discussion between the
judges and the players
yo he mixed everybody in the room bro
oh an ET he was honestly believing that
there was still a little extra path to
work he said no no you can come back for
a third time bro I got a little bit more
left I want to keep playing with you
come on
mushroom match I want more of that Ash
come on sadly for us it's only a tour of
three until the finals could happen
again though because last is not out of
this yet yes of course he's going to
survive in La Fiesta La Pachanga that
place called the losers bracket the
party where no one wants to leave and
everyone will be fighting to the nail to
stay in that spot what a way to start
these uh top six Mighty helper I knew
they were gonna come out swinging I knew
they were going to give us all they got
at the beginning these guys do not hit
the brakes ever when it comes to playing
klf and E.T just demonstrated it all
over lasted beautiful play and
absolutely needed you know because I
imagine like we were talking about smash
factor x he definitely wants to pick up
or he might have been lacking previously
yeah want to be tightening up a little
bit of those weaknesses that he had yeah
so I'm excited to see him move on but we
got to move on as well to Mad kof versus
xiaohai and this is another evil
Champion evil Champion Showdown right
now yeah that's just an incredible
situation of course let's remember that
fatigue day with the yellow t-shirt
where okay have became champion of the
world here at IBO and of course uh Xiao
Haiku is not shy to that kind of
scenario the night that started it all
and xiaohai also Evo Champion
2014 kof 13 Evo Champion over tokido man
this is actually a Monumental Clash of
Titans right now yeah they are they are
at the element this is their Prime
environment these are Hunters these are
predators on their field and everyone
it's a prey for them let's watch it
shall I oh look at that he's bringing it
down again no man I can't believe that
thing still looks as Immaculate as it
does right now he's
there's no rips in it there's no creases
nothing it's still in perfect condition
well of course it is it's always in the
Box it's always in the Box priesting
condition you can't you do not deserve
to watch this I think he only whipped
out the stick today man he's like Hey
where's my golden sick it's time it's
time ladies and gentlemen look at this
technology man look at this advanced
technology brought to you
by kwamba digging the Dazzle job too
yeah yeah so it's going to be IST mad
kof against Quan batoju Xiao high so now
this is going to be so so insane
yesterday my KF was playing out of his
mind he was not mad kof he was insane
okay he was definitely living up to the
name mad kof showing as usual not a fan
of blocking when he don't have to that's
why he plays Clark no he's so good it's
not good Clark
if anybody here in the building in the
top six stage is feeling comfortable
because I guarantee you they're all just
clinching diamonds right now it's
xiaohai because he's already qualified
for that final spot at the swc
Championships 2023 taking place next
year in the springtime sometime yes
you're completely right the winner or
possibly depending on what happens the
runner-up of this tournament will be
getting another spot down and there will
be more qualifier spots throughout the
rest of the year and that's and that's a
shout outs to the people behind that
event shout outs to that circuit we
Esports now we are keeping the kof
legend alive to Make Some Noise for
these dudes
that's the Roar of the evil crowd no
other crowding they will look at these
people look at these beautiful beautiful
people come on love to see it man thank
you friends and family for coming out to
join us for evil 2023's Kayla 15 top six
and we're just getting started and of
course thank you everyone that it's at
home also watching this being part of
this phenomenon seven depth 17
000 strong and this is going to climb up
all day long because this is evil baby
the biggest evil in history and two are
all part of this we're just getting
warmed up baby
oh
oh yeah who gets first hit
look at that team that's an honest the
an honest True Team of alpha males you
talking about kill no problem yeah I
agree not today they definitely let you
know who they are up front come on let's
see can shall hi
defeat demera he is the man against the
mirror right now look at the team we
have keys we have Clark we have Hayden
and he is trying to prove that he is the
mirror he is the one who establish the
Rhythm in this game oh and you're gonna
need some Republicans for free okay
disrupt the show offense possibly
definitely designed around not being
able to just smash buttons on him he
does have three different counters that
can cover all those whoa
not gunshot here but also not really
liking the looks kidding oh look at
those he said don't even try it where
are you going super long hey and the mod
kof is beating that close down C is a
menace if he's beating the meta right
now Kyo broke it no bruh the criminal is
broke the king of South town bro the
most manly of men that's for sure
do something about the Buccaneers I
don't know man that back dash Harry will
be a forever present always
care what a challenge from Salis though
he said nah too many frames in between
big window never your turn never to turn
against VG netarius as you see blood
look at these looking forward
you're out of the air try it again that
time no jump CD for you
a timing change for map K wife who is
pushing forward let's see trying to flip
it one two three the kicks are on making
him fly investment trying the person's
Advantage got end up getting clipped by
the Harrier being that's gonna lead to
Pure damage we're gonna see it once more
oh this guy is so beautiful man the top
best of the tears that's for sure
definitely but that was still mad
Caleb's Point character the geese was in
first the cars come in about to get
three bars that means every air-to-air
going to be ex tackle possibly in a
gator roll possibly in a ddg possibly
into that we're shovel slamming he does
you are complete life with tea okay I
believe that overhead just keeping the
run and the carriers yes this is the
game now this is why the meta is strong
Oh waking up with the throw Clark also a
character that if you do the hair you'll
be a little too close he can definitely
punish it with the S grab won't even
have to now he's gonna blow it all he's
got to get Max damage from this from
side to side and we are going he's gonna
turn her into a pretzel yeah look at
that um
oh the humanity oh the pain
people are waiting for it put it about
six who is arriving Pockets who is
arriving we got Cronin coming in with
three bars almost three and a half still
dangerous can't just jump in but still
court with one bar air-to-air going to
be ex tackle for sure money well spent
on getting rid of that piece though
people are losing their minds for Clark
look at those hand tears getting a
little bit of extra resources
are we going to invest yeah we go not
enough for the rifle still
oh he did everything on that Mateo F
back to Dash was so ready
we challenged it nice
is unable to confirm right there
using the PT button oh fell for it
you got him
one more is gonna do it oh okay no he's
at two that was too easy
oh what a challenge over there
so howling with one bar the corona can't
do a lot of damage but still dangerous
with almost two bars
he's trying to crash against the people
either occupation no don't want a block
over there he was more than ready Matt
Caleb's going a little too mad here
might need to calm it down
round one
he got it he got it what a way to
survive the instincts of a hunter
someone will say that's a fee oh games
[Music]
with me
she said I don't want to play footsies
with Cronin no problem we can do that
look at that man compose myself one of
the people who could be called a God in
this in this series in this franchise in
this game and the coolness I like this
concentration coming from moth Caleb
look at that murder face yeah he's back
he's back from the same moment and he is
ready to deliver some pain I feel like
this guy has been seeing things quite
differently than a lot of other players
for some time not only in season two but
in the season one and we're seeing the
culmination of all that hard work coming
out but he still has one hurdle he has
to close it out against shy because
right now he's doing such a good job of
just limiting shanghai's best tools in
the kill in the beginning and coming up
roses going into the anchor round it's
just that last interaction oh boy this
is looking bad for Matt Taylor on a
territory offense doesn't end just there
you got to hold all that frame advantage
that's super big CD but now it's the
turn of map kof can he open up that kill
possibly enough if he wants to keep it
going yes sir
that's perfect to the last impact
scientifically
delivering data if this was a math if
this was physics mod kof now has to
survive with his Clark but what can he
do the court was cut against the vision
and now
material weapons hoping he can get
through this show with minimal damage
and resources spent so let's see playing
neutral okay oh he's not really able to
confirm over there a little bit of pasta
spaghetti here but get out of here
strike and here we go we are gonna
discipline this ball this bad boy level
two okay break it back when I'm here hey
let him hear him he's not a bad bad boy
the great equalizer
Clark Steele is here Pockets Park still
with one bars honestly not a terrible
situation the area game is still scary
against anybody to es tackle and as soon
as he gets too bars you probably get a
solid hit and turn into a maximal
comfort at the same time it speed last
time Clark
time car time against this visionette
again command grabs dude a lot of moves
that are kinda unsafe against command
grabs like uh B Harrier right there man
I think map kof is trying to save some
passion take some money
against the pirate it's going to be so
so hard
is he close enough there it is there it
is you can't just do that against Clark
especially in the corner oh he was so
ready man was waiting for that but he
said it's a plus place to pry uh about
the price to pay no ex
you wanted to hold the corner I respect
I respect you want to hold the corner
who challenges it no overheads no high
levels empty jump let's see if the
carriers did again he makes me double
Concordia
gonna handle this though he's got some
big normals here but are they gonna be
in the right place at the right time and
right now no sir three bars on Beez in
that side how does he build so much
meter all the time
she's never broke they made eyes too
strong I'll finally the Moon is coming
out those blades in the arms
[Applause]
such a convincing Victory on that thing
number two he's gonna move forward he
will face
no other than E.T and that's a rematch
yeah man that's a rematch classic that
is an evil rematch classic right there
man and now we will have to move into
the losers bracket but before that
pocket we will have to take a little bit
of a breath because man those matches
those matches were simply insane and you
can see for yourself right here man this
clutch played from Matt klf Clark
decided to dump all the meter on it turn
into a pretzel and get her out of the
building in game one was so close to
take that game number one and the
momentum the child High build it with
Cronin was simply good enough to take
him into game number two what a way to
start these stupid people are you not
entertained
yeah they are we're definitely
entertained but for now stay that
emotion and we'll be right back don't go
anywhere
that Sizzle that's the soundtrack of
Chipotle the soundtrack of Chipotle oh
yeah you come in you're gonna be hearing
that Sizzle that's how you know we
always have fresh food
fresh is what you stand for that's
exactly
[Music]
oh no
super Lola
Victory feels good
good
morning
[Music]
thank you
registration for Capcom Pro Tour is now
open over 2 million dollars is on the
line for the season with the first place
prize of one million dollars to the
Capcom cup 10 Champion winners of the
online and offline Premiere events will
also Auto qualify for a spot at Capcom
cup 10. open to all players in good
standing so check out capcomprotour.com
for scheduling and to find a qualifying
tournament in your area
so it's far from over and we are here on
the looser sides of the rocket Pockets
now is the time where things really
start feeling dangerous as they say
secret swim definitely the model of the
loser side of the bracket here mad kalef
having a squeaker of a match with
childhood but not enough to get him
further in the winter side of the
bracket going to go up against
bar and burner with ET in the first game
of the day
going to place off against
it's time to shoot him up I'm roasting
moku who is a young man was playing
everybody here this weekend if you want
casuals moku's definitely your man right
now yeah man what a player all the way
from Japan trying to prove that the Land
of the Rising Sun has also a good Legacy
of kof Champs she's fighting for the
owner of his people of his brothers in
arms very very young as well man just
getting the career started out and I
have been impressed by him ever since I
saw him start playing KOA 14 uh the
dominance the creativity the uh the
solid the the solid gameplay sticking to
the game plan he has all those things in
space he really just needs more
tournament experience I don't know I
feel like this guy could be the most big
thing you are completely right I hope he
can travel a little bit more that he can
go forth as at worldwide competitor
because he has showed us so much and of
course lassive we just saw him uh that
team so strong but of course he will
have to face this also not very
and of course with that with that one
who simply it's a beautiful girl to see
oh and no lunchbox for you the carrier
is here that's why she's so good man
it's really hard oh we just rehearsal
that you have to kind of play bijanet
that way where you're like you know what
I know area view is coming and if I just
block it you're probably just going to
disrespect me some more so I have to
give you something to think about it
I'm changing it that is the danger of
challenging her jumping because carrier
B also changes the trajectory of her of
her jump so if you try to anti-air she
might just blow you up for the whip
already right now oh all the way over
there
okay I think okay I see your kid boxes
extended her boxes they're they're nice
pretty good pretty nice oh the trade
let's see little by little baby couldn't
wake him up giving her a little bit of
his own carrier kicks I think that uh
anti-air is in there
trying to maintain the oppression to
maintain the offensive right here both
of them very humble in terms of of uh of
resources it's got a challenge
so good but not the tech and maintaining
the occupation okay the big hitbox of
the of the skirt it's gonna take it
still very close first match
oh we change uh Germany's color
interesting green color maybe it's a
little bit better green uh better look
maybe maybe green is good luck
trying to bring uh some theory of color
here lasted and not with the anterior
that's going to be a completely full
health Jeremy we are super even even in
terms of uh bars resources what can long
do big problem in common yeah man
long fast great normal stance CD that
right there is a nightmare to deal with
oh look at that the opening hour unable
to confirm right there now you're not
gonna be kicking me on the air sweating
that girl with guns here you thought you
could jump back I don't think so oh oh
the pressure against the corner let's
see unable to get out of there oh what a
challenge
oh my God we only for computer right
here by Mark
oh the crime the crime everybody got
opened up raise your hand if you gotta
open up yeah um
oh man I need some Park medicine after
that one oh that was a little bit of
extra
oh
challenge here my last hit
running for her not investing anything
will not be denied these throws bro he's
just going in
they jump back with the kick great stuff
over here so close man he's a nail
biting
and the ass coming in with almost five
bars this is the best Ash ground that
Placid has dealt with yet oh my God are
you kidding me this is gonna hurt oh
look at this oh ah are we gonna do the
best yes no let's see if they're
stinging keep it very humble next touch
is gonna do it and even not The Knot's
gonna be sub 50 seconds not a lot of
that life is going to come back oh no
he's able to survive he has the
resources One Touch can he bring the
movie can he play Kick the button and
show us
bro we're talking one in activation
territory right now
there right now why yes oh man that was
perfect
that's what he needed the money maker
was right there oh shoot the levers The
Patience by mocking he knows no no no
you have to shake it you have to forget
about that mistake that's in the past I
might have startled him focus on the
computer
never show the kind of uh vulnerability
to your opponent
to stop to stay cool you have you have
to stay as collected as a 23 year old
oh my God oh my God he can do it he's
doing this for all Korea
we're back into it that was so close I
think it lasted uh outside of that error
uh looking at closing out that match I
don't expect him to play this any
differently maybe a little tighter there
uh it might be on mote to actually make
the adjustment here yeah I'm okay I've
been playing so good and the hardware
kicks are going to Pushkin against the
corner look at the damage look at how
much she can do oh and getting open up
clipping in the feet the sleepy boy
wants to wake up she does it all baby
he's not allowing that oh what
I call the pillow is not working
to make a move great finally getting the
launch punch extra damage I need the
neutral again the idiots they are so
good so good can't jump on bees
and a she can jump off she wants me you
were no jumping she's simply does it all
foreign
it's hard not to be frustrated here you
know uh you got two and a half bars on
the Sherman but every time you attempt
to get something started the abusing a
is in the perfect place at the perfect
time for ER yeah man I mean look at
these oppressions against the corner of
food oh my God
it's simply giving all his resources to
keep uh Jeremy against it and he's gonna
challenge with the down two with the 2A
oh my God Market is playing out of his
mind right now yeah the box is playing
amazingly right now just every Harrier
be in the perfect place every jump every
button finding the mark unless it's just
unable to bind any aggressive it's
putting nothing solid has to make
something happen here this is his last
leg literally most likely
right here running out the clock knowing
that he has two full-time characters and
everything that he does with these big
energy extra credits oh what a jumping
Pro changing from that distance Jesus
it's such a beautiful girl such a
fantastic character and monkey is using
it as a craft oh
my God that's it OCB for no don't
let it clap unless it with a big smile
of his face a champion as always going
home
with this uh this place
what a man I I told him he's a bad man
he's a bad man that more Make some noise
for Lassie people come on
[Applause]
what a champ
new new blog on the scene man so good
and that kind of playstyle is really
hard to nail down because you saw he had
no fear about activating or executing
any of those bjna tools at any time uh
even if it was a situation where it
might have been blocked and he might
have been a little bit unsafe it might
have been a little precarious there he
just went and did it again he just kept
going in and lastly just didn't have an
answer for it yeah man leads they win
Compass also confirming those uh Diamond
keys to those yeah from so far getting
into it each one of those openings was
uh making big money and you can't yeah
and when you're playing someone like Ash
and you can't play at that range because
you're already getting pressured into
like what could be real damage oh
stifling really a man and his craft that
that's two of his craft class of course
that beautiful Buccaneer Queen beignet
but well now we have to move forward
another match another International
match and now it's going to be all the
way from Mexico de la come on
[Applause]
absolutely fighting a war to give the
top six
of course he will be fighting one of the
strongest on the world and a Mexican
Slayer to wish for you to be sure that
is no other than math KOA your first kof
Evo champion
there is no T-shirt now
will that be would that be the
difference I'll be honest the T-shirt no
T-shirt I still got in my pools and mad
kof still got on top
let's go what are some media playing uh
for cinta Negra
he is really a player that has been
doing so much work lately getting top
places on many International tournaments
like combo breakers like CEO and uh also
delivering a great examples of skill in
Mexico Oh another selfie yes can we go
don't fall for it
he didn't even smile he was like yeah
yeah get it over with
look at him
of course mad kof all geared up
isolating himself from the public from
the crowd getting those headphones on he
knows that he is on dangerous Warriors
right here on these evil stage he's the
focus man the role of the couch will be
so much distracting at times
for that yeah he will feed from the
chance of our brothers so now we will
see forget about that he will feed on
the theme of the training stage for sure
like here we go
against Matt kof Korea Korea against
Mexico oh this is going to be so
exciting I'm gonna lose my mom my boy is
right here I'm telling you I'm feeling
the same way right now iori is in the
building oh
it's gonna be so hard that team I am so
scared of the team
he's Clark and Hyder
I've already seen how much the geese
kill matchup so I think what was going
to show him something a little different
here with Sal had so the mortgage
showing the same thing as ripping them
apart later on anyway let's see
the moment of silence here we go the
Crimson Kyo against the Winer looking oh
getting checked the Vintage it's so so
big he boxes from that friend Lord
get a boy
man
oh don't touch me wake up grab get off
got good range on it pretty fast so it's
kind of it might be a little bit more
difficult than some other characters to
do that shoulder track than a lot of
kills are used to go for something to
the Charter strike that's a big
strategic big reformatica making the
Mexicans spend that far and uh
pigeonette the buccaneer Queen will be
here with only one well not two bars but
okay the carrier in a change timing
spending everything to get this out of
the way I like to cash out there I do
agree
I think that was super Tower
pressure
fresher but man kof resistance like a
champ
ions
being super smart and knowing it's the
matchup running down the clock he
doesn't want the pirate Queen to get any
kind of a regeneration she's still
pretty healthy in that regard though so
I'm going into the next round without
much help still makes her fairly much
into touch territory uh especially
um
perfect perfect spacing over there
now we have Clark it has not the best of
times against pigeonette but of course
we are talking about mad kof man okay
well proving that oh no he's gonna do it
he's not gonna kill but that's gonna be
a lot of damage oh yes and it seems that
everyone wants to bring some
Chiropractic adjustment and yes you're
saying maybe you're a pretzel oh look at
that
feel that in the morning oh for sure
oh no he tried some tricky stuff but not
till it was so ready that might be the
only downside to be Harrier is that uh
you actually have to commit to that
super slow fall and the oppon could just
run underneath you and uh now let's see
with the most Mexican of yours this year
can he do it
that was fantastic
[Music]
good damage for Clark coming up putting
them back Center screen
a little bit of resources again those
look forward that was a jump heavy punch
that probably would have been edges oh
long range Nails 25 seconds on the clock
oh boy he's gonna take this with Clark
two Ken Stein three
my God
[Applause]
yeah man raise your hands for that
Clarke looking like a complete monster
right here
my heart is breaking whereas a media can
bring it back I know it but of course
the Titan in front the Titan to beat is
a complete monster my dear hell Pockets
well it's got a bracket full of like
challenge impossible uh players in this
bracket right now so uh getting anywhere
here is a tremendous victory for anybody
uh but once again
the world why he was a evil Champion why
he is an evil Champion it could be
another one for a moment going for the
predictable
delivering to the people what they
deserve oh yeah
he is providing right now great blocks
over here by man curb yet again that
defense from from the Korean Titan
that's so good that show is cooking but
that Jump City skip neutral
he's just suspending everything that
jump D super fast good way to interrupt
a lot of uh air-to-air like situations
like that sorry no beautiful activation
[Applause]
look how it's waking up get him out of
here
looking strong
now let's see if he can climb these
walls any air to where it's going to be
so painful but oh goes for the Common
Ground he's completely naked I think no
resources but he's gonna play these
combo he's gonna play this like you are
an El Barrio
great placement on all these options
from level right now great timing as
well right in the needle in a lot of
these situations he's really breaking
the war into my qf pick me up big
Knuckles over there the turn punch
coming out there
oh classic the classic open the arms out
oh nonetheless sub 30. going into the
secondary battle here Guero assamia
still up a half a character basic yeah
and he has two bars to work now
let's see last time uh he got uh begin
it
got completely canceled and uh it's
looking like that yet again hmm breaking
the neck
what from that distance he must have
stuck something out
if you know something it he knows
something playing that perfect spacing
somebody clipped that in the chat I want
to see that later on
we're gonna bring the topic to SNK but
now the one who is bringing the pain is
finally able to get something moving but
no Mankato says he's not your turn it's
mine oh you're back into the corner
you're down you cannot sit on your hands
against this Clark bro you can now play
Passive BJ net not being a factor for
the Mexican player now he's in this
exact same scenario that last time with
Yuri three bars that's a lot of salsa
but the Korean player let the Mexican
cook
oh
I think weddle's gonna have to get way
more aggressive than this right now he's
doing a little bit too much passive play
backing up there we go we want to see
those trades here
it's a bouncy Old Reliable
being very careful
clipping toes apart no confirming yet
again another one man he didn't like the
distance on it I guess I'm the role not
caref didn't want it to deal with the
con Sito
oh sorry this is definitely some uh high
level pressure right yeah man you
definitely have to watch this one
closely
that's the range that where Samir was
trying to avoid him and of course Mount
carrot is going to invest big here he
has the pository now I I was so good for
Argentina after that jump or something
or sub 30 here man almost up 20 man you
have to make something happen here he is
not going to win on a timeout and he's
done she's not gonna win at all I think
his last character on his last game he
has to make something happen right now
and we are going to spend the neither in
order to pass above Clark he's Gonna
Take It
oh what's he got for The Hider no he's
gonna cut 40 tops the hydrants got 30
percent easy job here
[Music]
oh when he's trying to bring the war
into this military mind Mastermind be
careful
and now Matt kol caught on his heels
getting gripped all over the place
Widow one more test it's gonna do it
down
[Applause]
and the complete crowd is giving it to
him holy crap oh
what a moment to realize
wow he got in his brain bro
I told you
the most Mexican of yours this year is
proving that yes Mexican
all right
kind of calm it down a little bit there
because I think we saw a little bit of a
little bit of uh cracks no the game plan
might have fell apart a little bit there
and mad kof with the big adjustment here
already also got to calm down yeah man
after that they had for sure are shaking
the heart is beating
but he's gonna give the kids
and now a good positioning while you're
going to the pressure is on yes the
train coming in the station here because
we know what happens when kill gets one
confirmer knocked down and he's in the
corner too are we seeing Coast to Coast
kill pressure
with that defense but look at the bar
some more pressure
patience now and just like that where
are you going
and she's going to steal another game
another character how you feel it Colt
oh I'm feeling I'm feeling my in my cart
I'm feeling it in my chest bursting
gotta fry tingling but then I click oh
yeah we'll always be a menace and this
Clark has been such a nightmare for
world
hmm
let's see still I'm a character here he
says he cannot jump
yeah
oh he went for the command prompt kiosk
came out first grabbing the common
Grabber oh
[Applause]
see unfortunately
what is going on man oh my God
[Laughter]
[Applause]
absolutely emotionless in the cafe of
that sequence unfortunately is going to
be thinking about that give me that
chance oh dear three bars for hiding
right now still alive oh right right now
where do asimi has played with so much
house money he can let it ride wow
[Music]
finally she has the chance to shine on
these evils evil Stitch let's see there
we go yeah give me the keys baby oh I
love you
okay okay
put in the corner here but still life
lead in his favor
but don't get greedy because there is a
lot of money on materials pocket and you
know what cars that could do oh oh the
cross-up hasn't really been able to
respond correctly to that cross-up
situation yet
all the way over there hail Mary
you mad man
Chester spin here no way out of this you
left her alive is that gonna have to sip
out there we don't even need to yeah
yeah Checkmate over there
checking the queen
it's so dangerous how many times we have
seen people like this but now he's Yori
it's a one touch oh one touches
he's gonna win he's gonna break the
curse she's gonna break the card oh my
Lord oh
it was the T-shirt no of course not but
but like ah my God what a champion Make
some noise for malcolf please I'd rather
in arms
definitely did the damn thing here this
weekend and we'll see him again I'm sure
man he's definitely going to be a big
problem for everybody playing k-15 in
the world punches his ticket to another
game in the loser side of Thompson such
a heartbreaker men both Korean Champions
are going home at
same step Mexico is going to position
itself on the best four countries of the
world in Kofi Salva but of course
someone's got to lose yeah sadly we have
to see both Mark kof and Lassie go home
but who are who is not going home and
anywhere is us you guys stay here we
have to take a break after that we'll be
right back
your Chipotle order just got extra the
fighter coins from Street Fighter 6.
order any entree in the Chipotle app
using promo code hdkn 236 and receive
250 fighter coins with your order visit
chipotle.com sf6 for details
gives you wings
all right
foreign
[Music]
thank you
here we go
[Music]
soldiers
foreign
[Music]
what's up everybody and welcome back to
Evo connections presented by atnt I'm
Persia and I am joined by Supa m in this
super crispy Leroy cosplay and we got
sugar too you can't leave sugar out what
is the importance to you to connect with
the characters that you cosplay as oh
absolutely it's incredibly important
when Leroy Smith came out I really felt
like this is me and it came out in a
very tumultuous time in America and the
community received it I actually cosplay
only characters that I play in games so
to be able to play a character that
represents me I absolutely had to do
this character this was a special build
um everything that you see here was hand
designed every inch of the Dragons were
completely redesigned from the ground up
sugar actually took a whole week by
herself I sat there in my kitchen with a
cotton ball and dabbed every bit of
detail that you see on her right now so
this is the one and only sugar that is
out there love to hear it and honestly I
think at this point Evo truly isn't
complete with out all of our amazing
cosplayers are there any other
cosplayers you've connected with or you
know met for the first time all right
well met for the first time I met a ton
we had a cosplay competition this year
the first time for Evo and the original
inspiration for this costume was because
of my locals it was just the local
tournament they said we really need some
publicity would you mind doing a cosplay
and I love those guys and I really feel
like we should all really be supporting
our Grassroots in the fgc and supporting
our locals so shout out to 404 Esports
you guys are the ones who made this
happen shout outs to Greg lanted he's
the one who put all of this together and
shout outs to the community out there
I'm doing this all for you guys you
already know trying to win this first
place cosplay competition and just go
out and support your locals guys amazing
exactly support your locals don't forget
it I hope you've all been enjoying the
show thank you so much for joining us
and we're gonna send it right on back to
the main stage
hey we're back with more Kayla 15 top
eight top six action excuse me here at
evil 2023. oh man it has been one hell
of an afternoon already and I feel like
how many matches do we have left it
feels like way too many to count yeah
man this is the story as we have lived
that we all will remember it
who was taken home by Moke from Japan
now we move forward we moved to the most
privilege of spots in a tournament we
move to the Winner's side of the bracket
winners finals the exact here and it's
up
going to be against
or it's going to beat your excuse me oh
man I can hardly speak this is Dewey
legendary rematcher this is Evo 2017.
Kayla 14 Grand finals the run back here
and it could happen again you never know
these guys have been spraying it up with
each other for years and both kof games
all kof games Ed could only come down to
this two players that have a very strong
statement on being the best krf player
in history are right here facing each
other absolute specialist of the kof
franchise and of course some of the most
dangerous players in the world this is
the mgc the cream of the crop of the fgc
right here on the evil stage damn
Pockets Can You Feel It in the Air it's
electric my breath is short bro I can
hardly hold it all in oh here we go here
we go anyone will kill to see these kind
of finals and we have it here on Evo
2023 let's go make some noise
that is a man an argument that a lot of
Villas will be coming now that she is
proven to be one of the best characters
in the game yeah I need to be one of
those players who have come close to
stopping this train that is how high is
dominance in Taylor 15 so far just not
able to seal the deal enough times uh to
make it count but this could be the
turnaround here okay let's see we've got
these evening
available
what's so good right there is how high
proving taking these a little bit extra
further a little bit more of salsa right
here from Shanghai but regionette is
here and what a confirm our appearance
make that happen a couple more times
what what oh he couldn't have meant to
do that
okay great thank you sir
it's always investing like that he's he
believes in uh in capitalism he he
invests when he sees these kind of
situations and always makes the most out
of it
oh no this tale's about to get away with
so much else money talking about
Investments oh yeah oh
no wins of change
right now it's he in a lot of trouble
here on a second character almost gone
into his anchor this isn't going to get
rid of him no not gonna get rid of okay
there we go
perfect spacing over there nothing's
giving any kind of risk nonetheless
very very strongly one two three
bars here you can do all the damage with
another judge
we didn't he wants to kill with those
bars he wants the resources he wants the
Menace to be here what a great contact
from me I want to pick him up
with the left investment what a what a
way to turn things around
ET finally making the wins of change
blow in the in the uh in the direction
of
his own business that counter hit was
everything man that's the kind of play
you played at the top level Kos
[Music]
the most 15 match of them all
and who has the strongest right here I
don't know man this could be anyone's
game it really depends on the decision
making here this is a real good footsies
this is gonna be a lot of damage he
activated off of that yeah
going off to actually go for the gun
he's trying to go for the Christmas tree
oh here we go shall high with such a
dominant display look at the play
England bro oh got a smudge on it 24
karat gold remind everybody this is a
three out of five since this is Winners
finals so two more chances for et to
turn this around but man what a dominant
anchor around for shall high there the
truth is that uh xiaohai has to bring
the box because if not the the spotlight
with reflect on the eyes of its
opponents like he's taking care of his
opponents in fact actually that's a good
point no no dirty Advantage the glare on
that stick might be blinding
let's go we are going to see this
as the concentration look at he looks so
fresh man he looks as if nothing is
happening he's he's playing at the
living room on his house yeah
this is his environment
BT right now just has to find a way to
get so high uncomfortable
very tall task indeed
start some Rhythm right here
to get out of there and some pain for
your trouble
oh nice
oh we had that real quick
get to the cake for the corner the
pressure is done
I think YouTube has taken a little too
much uh making a little too much too
many liberal jumps he's probably gonna
try to work the anti-air angle a little
bit more or maybe sound like my back out
but now that he did take a beat first
trouble
using all that that Mobility from Isla
it doesn't want to be close to to kill
one to make this uh
no where are you going
[Applause]
the one in doubt Great Glass Yeah man so
much privilege right there with the
armor and everything but the damage is
done
he needs one simple confirm and it will
be over we will have an evening oh there
it is only half a bar needed
Shanghai will be coming with three
complete bars
Kenichi turn this momentum around though
because Xiao I still have three
characters it's a mirror match our three
bars have the three bars it's a mirror
match and it didn't go so well uh
current here Beyond its key watch he got
the momentum the last time
for him so let's see because right now
it's how high heels completely on the
offensive
he said no you cannot get that for free
it's not a safe jump brother out of love
we are going to have a pressure over
here who is going to win the turnout
far away from the reach of that of that
sea oh what a wake up yeah
we're gonna see it
I'm not even gonna say it I'm not even
guessing he's gonna punish with La
Chance
get out of here she's so beautiful
Shanker oh she's so beautiful man oh my
god dude what a way to comfort what's in
those shoes bro you want to come you
call
whoa
I'm not gonna be enough to kill yet but
I like the damage nonetheless he has to
make it happen quick though
gonna be very close if he kills him
I am not gonna allow that to happen one
two
bring the wins out
oh
that's so good at that yeah
each time makes a hit so big
stomped on her I'm standing man xiaohai
right now just letting the clock run DT
on his last character on life support oh
it's going so bad might be able to do it
here see the cheap damage
yeah he felt it in his bones gets out of
there and it's going to be Shanghai gets
game in number two shower continues to
bring gang round in this matchup uh
didn't even get to the Cronin this time
on his side of course we are on finals
so that's why we are going into game
number three you have another chance but
imagine turning this around against
xiaoha it's uh so so hard man
yeah I mean there's there's definitely
something to be said about uh how people
play fighting games how people play kof
and then how shall I plays klf and it's
like the complete antithesis to a lot of
good players game plan ready
let's see one more chance he's like
what's up
like that that has to match
that momentum is keeping on so this is
maybe watching but what if he needs he's
his life dominating his first match oh
there's a big one is coming oh that's
gonna be no no he was unable to build
the bar at time and time but now he's
gonna use it
this is the what he needed this is the
this is watching you this is the
momentum shift wow I did not see that
round coming from PT at this point but
he needed it when he needed it
cam
[Music]
so many options when they are away from
Earth from the ground
unable to open terrible
is Gonna Hurt
excited let's go for free that's okay
got the trade either and fell up on his
point there
but we need some bicycle
some piece got from Chile it's what E.T
needed which is left and he is moving
forward against
that one it's stinky with four bars that
could be less than one touch okay it's
gonna be too fast
finally got her out of there uh had to
spin two bars on it though I guarantee
you he does not feel too bad about that
now completely not that's a hard worker
girl for sure she's making the
difference right now and even
the resources advantage that he's using
right here in the perfect way no OTG
like the pressure one two
keeping the check it's quite a
tremendous adjustment here on DT's part
yeah he's making yeah
and he's punishing quad for that
[Applause]
oh more high quality cough kof from
everyone look at this crowd look at La
Familia
Brothers by Kos maybe not by blog but
just by Passion
oh my friend dude
this is what it's all about man what a
way to come back with these laps that's
the uh uh the cartoon who is making the
difference is oh we're going for a
pyramid oh really now remember uh
definitely sung the Praises of Isla at
the earliest times of cable 15's
Inception before release uh so he has
some experience with her obviously I'm
not saying
a slouch in comparison to ETS but this
is as far as I can tell in recent months
unprecedented from what I've seen oh my
God you're going straight into the
character select picking the character
that is giving him the troubles
that's a big adjustment by no holder
though you shall hide and I gotta say I
think you just must not like peaceful
abusion
you probably didn't feel too Wildlife
either but would rather take his chances
with that and then maybe not pay off
here the question is
the problem
I don't know I think this is the
decision of the pro oh I mean switching
switching uh
yeah I agree but we don't know we never
know we don't know what's going on he
may have a completely different view of
this than we do and right now the joke
okay let's stay on point is working out
for him oh my God
the problem was not killed that's for
sure yeah he was feeling fine about the
kill match up there and now the the
solution from the equation name as E.T
has the name of
oh that's love range hey and now we're
going for the old classics trying to get
for the knee and taking everything in
control both the carriers are in time oh
what two this is going to push all the
way to the corner
literally see South High's Comfort
levels Rising as he got rid of them
who wants to play this slow game who
wants to push forward and look at it oh
no you will have to come to me and
finally he says okay I'm coming open up
not gonna spend the music and get rid of
him wants to save him for this next
round
oh that's upon us bye bye oh dude you
were afraid of something now question
Isla against the vision a matchup when
E.T might already know a little bit more
about that situation than he was he's
the Pisco from Shanghai as good as the
one from ET that's the that's the
question bye-bye the grad because
pushing the fort
was like yeah I want you to pick this
matchup because I know exactly what I'm
supposed to do with this situation I'm
gonna put four bars that's gonna be big
for Xiao High one in fact could be the
end of Jenny
oh get out of there out of the air
that's it
these are not looking as refined as the
one from ET but still able to do the job
that heavy punch is all you need baby oh
look at them so focused
grown in four bars it's gonna be so
close the drill is not kidding oh that's
that's a gift that's a gift and xiaoha
is taking them
hard knock down
the corner I like a cat a chance here
we're gonna see the most kf15 match now
only one bar
grown in against Groening will stop
basically three three bars of quarter
three forms of salsa
between both players here though two
three touches possible oh yeah
because the turn
knows
[Applause]
she knows
that he actually came out and the big
mistake from E.T is going to set
Shanghai into the grand finals on the
Winner's side please celebrate these
Warriors Make some noise
one of these play tragedy tragedy indeed
man I feel like saint of last year's
Grand finals against cjz just the
erroneous input just as if it was
written by the Greeks by the Classics
this is a show of glory and tragedy at
the evil stage my God you have to be
here and you are if you are watching for
home thank you very much and the people
here are living it make noise feel it
[Applause]
the chant is about Mexico
is going to take onto the stage and he's
going to find to fight sorry Moki all
the way from Japan the Land of the
Rising Sun it's going to be a killer
match both players with a ton of
momentum on their sides right now making
out of the loser side match uh with
legendary ramifications at all times
this is also very important for the
worldwide KO have seen because Eve
whereas I mean he's able to do this he
will place the American kof the all of
American kof as part of the best three
countries in the world as part of that
Elite that we have been seeing a
dominate for the last years in this game
so this is so very important can Guero
samija push all of the American people
todos Latinos even our North American
Brothers
we're fighting for a continent now all
right
all of America being represented by What
man does the Mexican look at that our
Pianist on his back yeah the samurai
right there
this is shingwa promotion Moke
and of course
oh God
oh man this big theater yes man yeah
yeah yeah
Shakespeare Boulevard
he's definitely got a face for like
camera yeah maybe I don't know if movies
he would be
perfect for them
and everyone I don't know if they are
there in the in the crowd uh but we
followed from Mexico was abroad uh some
some weird faces I saw that another how
did they just have those ready to go
that's that's what we'd like to know
faith they knew they knew it was they
knew he was company they knew where it
was happening that's sick
there's a chance right there right oh
ready to take on
fellow Champion here Mulk remember this
is two out of three
this is losers semi-finals
so it's going to be incredibly dangerous
of course mauka is going to start with
vision that's a very interesting that
Guero is starting with the Yoli the
character that helped him to Rob so many
others during this tournament yeah I've
been seeing him put his glory in the
backs for the longest amazing season two
but uh maybe he likes his potential
particular matchup a little better oh
that was so close or he just wants to be
Janae to be in the back
he was more than ready oh
the young man is proving to be a killer
the kill coming in against the almost
full Health Vision a breaks the throat
oh man blows up the 3D
gotta eat all this damage and take the
corner you'll get grabbed on your way
he's speaking of dominating two full
years of evil and still doing it here
she says no don't touch me Criminal oh I
don't care
hmm
not gonna get a lot of damage here but
he needs that just to get something
going here on offense all right Train's
starting to pull out the station
it's all day long
they are providing they are providing
Japan with such a good path and in the
mirror match can gueros Amiga own to be
Janet made the difference all hail to
climbers of the vision AIDS are long and
then the googly oh that's a great
crossover says I can open him up again
oh that's terrible
is feeling the nerves the kind of sun
shaking oh man that's some hard
offense to deal with
you wanted to hold on to that music
possibly might be able to do this for
less than two bars
oh what a cross-up that was insane from
so high oh he's able to confirm monk is
working on a no CP to welcome
to this top four and he's gonna get it
damn ocv man this is two out of three so
one more chance for weather to turn
around but what a dominant normally
normally people say the Japanese uh
Nationals are super respectful but there
is no respect coming from mocking he is
just going forward and fourth but of
course we saw this situation before
Craig was losing against uh against he
was able to turn you around so there is
still hope for the Mexican Warrior
actually he's being very special he's
pointing out the letter like hey you got
an opening there you got an opening
there you got an opening there just want
to let you know you're open yes yes a
little bit of a of a beating right here
but Pockets This Is The Moment of Truth
mirror match there again he felt
comfortable
and the order was his change the chess
game of kof is being played
uh
on point this time once the mirror match
might be able to turn everything around
multiple say yeah bring it on bro
[Music]
perfectly tanned he's really making a
show right here finally whereas I mean
is able to start something but the
difference itself is significant
yeah man Mark started so fast
Richard
from playing from behind him he's
definitely been able to shift the
momentum in previous matches so not out
of it yet but mostly not taking his foot
off the gas here hard to do it what
on the same side and crossing over to
garnish how high was he when she did
that
not looked like he knows every single
Pixel of those hitboxes that's for sure
and he's looking so strong whereas only
able to deliver 10 damage oh but the
common practice one over here burning
it's a beautiful place and on the corner
can he do something that he can he
change the future
perfect got cancel over there mock is
playing so refined he looks in that in a
fantastic moment right now yeah he is so
sharp right now almost Unstoppable by
the looks of it Guero having such a hard
time just getting him to commit to
anything that might spell do for him
this might be
end of the piece of a no he holds on to
the meter here no
grab no grab
why why at this moment why did you
saving the major
no not like this oh
that's why you spend that's economy baby
it doesn't matter all right 26 seconds
on the clock he could have finished it
off at 38 but unfortunately decided to
hold on to the meter and uh here comes
to go along with one and a half bars
also a big problem most teams yeah oh
god oh double up and down Mark is
showing that he can bring the mix of La
mesqua okay now we've got the chance
going forward
is starting to get some momentum bought
the difference from monkeys because the
turn is over allowing mock to get out of
there trying to fish give him some line
Against All Odds and got clipped with
the jump d
ude
so strong from these young Samurai all
right you're already on anchor once
again what difference does it make here
has to make a big one though
yeah that was great no burn
with this with the city
and the little the little hand to make
the cross-up we're gonna see the full
damage oh okay she's smart one for the
grab still a lot of damage nonetheless
oh yeah he can do it
oh all right this happened last time we
got down to the Yore and he already
started cooking oh foreign
[Applause]
is going to move forward to the top
three but please
make some noise from the Mexican Warrior
wow
literally got buried in sand there that
was wild my car keeps crying of course
but against such a strong display there
is no argument there is nothing to say
only congratulations to Mark moving into
the top three of ebo 2023 wow Japan
getting so far away getting so far up in
there and these guys no stranger to each
other Mark always in that picture as
well but once again Weddle doing the
darn thing here at this Evo 2023 k-15
tournament and even though he didn't
make it in the top three I think he did
he did us proud he did everybody that
plays for sure in this region proud so
definitely give it up for Weddle and
we'll definitely see more of him as we
now have an Esports tour to look forward
to it she's gonna keep traveling for
sure yeah La sangres Tech I will return
no don't doubt about it but now Asia
Pacific once again at the top Echelon of
this kof man they are so strong and they
play so so I'm so fun to watch it's like
sharp you cannot be not entertained by
these fantastic players our business our
brothers and sisters from Far Far East
Asia definitely love to see them working
we're about to get a lot more of that
but first we gotta break to throw it too
so we'll see you in a little bit stay
tuned
Chipotle's new Chicken al pastor is fire
on every level fresh chicken hot off the
grill a rich marinade of seared Marita
peppers and ground acchiode balanced
with a splash of pineapple all combined
for the right amount of heat Chipotle's
all new Chicken al pastor is where fire
meets flavor
[Music]
because
PlayStation
oh no
super Rola
[Music]
[Applause]
hey we're back with more Kayla 15 action
here at Evo 2023 top six are you ready
for the final stretch ladies and
gentlemen only three only three Warriors
are left they all come from different
nations from different lands but share
the same passion on their plot this love
that you also have the love for kof
there is feeling like we've been at this
for years and it's only been two days
honestly man I feel like I aged like at
least five years just watching these
matches and top six yeah man it's been
such a real A Thrill Ride sorry oh oh
English failing Skype is climbing at
this point we say what we're comfortable
with man so if you gotta drop it in the
native tongue I'm all oh
people here in the production team will
look at Madison
we're gonna keep it in the Universal
tongue English
so we are going to keep out yeah the
picture we are all friends and brothers
bound but kof now we're gonna see monkey
against
[Music]
gone down to losers finals here this
will be three out of five and he's gonna
be fighting his way hopefully to get
another shot at Shanghai or it could be
monkey the young upstart with an
opportunity with a shot at the king Yeah
man so good I want to see E.T try to
prove that that Islam is one of the best
characters in the game she has so many
options maybe some people say the
chillax in the damage department but it
doesn't matter when you can oh assistant
and of course I want to see that
beautiful beautiful Korean Korean kick
lady the
tycooned it down huh the crime to be
honest we haven't we haven't seen that
much of her during these top six like
mock has been so dominant with BJ net
that uh long has fallen uh outside of
the spotlight I think the few times did
get to really cook uh it was monstrous
it was a monstrosity but we quickly
ended up seeing two three we just
emptied the sand buckets you know
kicking over to sand castle and married
his opponent let's see again this is a
game about air superiority who is going
to be the queen of Earth we know that of
course Jenny eats a queen of the Seas
but here Isla he's trying to deliver
something because he's not gonna hit me
so the rules of mock are also very
interesting oh forget about what I was
saying because right now if he is like
the first big damage I was gonna say man
we already know he kind of likes his
statue the B is the name versus not
entirely uncomfortable with it might
even feel there's an advantage for his
yes you are completely right 50 is done
one opening was enough for months to try
it where are you going go look at the
Grange I have cans I love cans what's
the what's that uh the JoJo's pointing
them like yeah get get her now here she
is long if she's going to do her craft
is mock going to cook with her okay he's
still ready the fans from mocking he's
so good I find like we're gonna slam
that girl to the ground keeping it on
are we going to spend it yes here we go
I agree make the economy grow spend the
money he's definitely gonna get all that
life back as well there if you might
have held on to it for a little too long
you might not get 100 and here comes
inside I hold
not working time off but the moment that
he wanted to go forward he's gonna get
heavily punished
in the Bruce trying to stay out of the
corner but no
the ET is not allowing that to happen
finally use the guard cancel to get out
of there and his kids with a grind right
there invention earlier how he didn't
get to see much of being along and I
think largely because he's very stronger
not a lot uh going on in the engineering
department they're trying to have to bet
it all on a well-placed bouncy or a
well-being going underneath a misplaced
jump attack but ET not calling for
either one of those scenarios and those
were two bars spend on the Garb cancer
to get out of the pressure from ET and
was unable to do it so that's big money
lost for Mark and ET is moving forward
and now cookies against the corner
because he's gonna fight his way out
yeah that's a deceptive fact about it
and we are going from coast to coast
because now is it they want him oh that
was so nasty like
disgusting move over there by Morgan who
is finally waking up with his character
I'll leave that safe on there oh we got
him oh made him look I am in your head
let's see but we are gonna have chronic
with with almost four bars
and that can turn sand into glass that's
for sure and we're gonna see it
immediately
because he wants to exp to be available
for the extra damage possibly
oh wow
wow Banger bringing the gun into a field
office
the tricky stuff uh bringing the tricky
tricky stuff that was rough man I don't
think that Mom's ready to punish that
list but hey it worked out for et right
people would say that it was on purpose
that was the medies of buttons not not a
whiff
water
[Laughter]
nocito
so let's see
um
in the push forward what changed what uh
Evolution
[Music]
show was right here right now I'm
actually expecting the CDT if we can
actually perform better in this matchup
even though it did go his way overall uh
I think he really likes this map
it looks like it oh great
Johnson fire pressing the bottom yes
again he's so ready for the young tears
but now he will have to live in this
corner and how is how is he going to ski
Escape
oh
but in my mind it's in your mind and the
rings are on
the prediction oh sadly no Punisher and
everything had to turn around oh yes
this is what
[Music]
kind of an easy job for this long year
might just spin one bar
yeah that's a little difficult yeah to
be honest and I like that pocket didn't
work for it but it doesn't matter
because he's gonna get opened up going
for the reason but monkey was ready
against his uh defensive options are
always on point to be honest for this
young Japanese players blow back two of
them and the cross-up in the last moment
we're gonna have luong with 60 70 kills
and a lot of salsa he's going to have
money to invest and I want to see the
beautiful Taekwondo
[Music]
that's actually kind of problematic for
the future
and the one can just do a real kick out
of it out of the way oh here we go
oh the shutter strike so damage not seen
oh no no when it drops no no fetus right
now all over the floor yeah I hate to
see this kind of thing happen get him
out he became my arm made out of smoke
the morning I went from there
he's going to change to chase that run
sadly we are not seeing that much of
wrong from Mark I hope he's able to keep
this game up so we can see more three
bars with the crew he definitely helps
out in that compartment
might get to see the Crone in here but I
imagine the way he's playing this right
now we're definitely gonna see uh taking
her uh 50 out of kupri's blood
indeed that's a lot of work that the man
of sand has to do
something
are we gonna play some metal us bro
that's a that's a good down season I
don't know a lot of people that played
he made a bat no they're way over there
going for the overhead
bucking is able to deliver last
characters Cronin three barns cookie
will have to play humble
play honest and he's spending them a
little bit out of range
extension from uh
best jumpsuit in the business
using the Clones
get out of the corner somehow okay
trying to stay out of that range but it
is still climbing up that resources bar
yeah threatening right a little by
little monkey suspending all of his
money in uh very little to be honest
yeah
we can put damage up on you real quickly
these resources for that so it's going
to be another touch before he actually
pushes
yeah I am sure it was a big for me tea
there's nothing at the big boot no
defense
no respect
ET without fear and Pops him up in the
air I don't know if he jumped back to
ask or what but that was unfortunate yes
yes
waking up with bottoms man I said
no fear at all over there by E.T
doing in a fantastic way you gotta do
what you gotta do yes and he's he I love
that he's not playing with headphones
man he's feeling the crowd oh yeah he's
up to them a fan of enjoying the
Ambiance hour I love that from a good
player look at him he feels comfortable
he knows that this is a step in order to
get his revenge
and make history hit on the evil stage
meanwhile moku might be getting a little
sweaty here and
get a little bit more hard production
work out of him man because
just not finishing off he just wants him
ahead of him in the most pivotal moments
let's see because Isla has been the key
for all of these victories
like how much damage was it was more
able to do to wear as a media with Jenny
with the pirate Queen and
ET is shutting her down and that's a big
variable in this this might all great
punish over there reaching with the
carrier and spending the bar in order to
get all that real estate with the corner
carry
yeah you play this game enough and you
start feeling great when you're like you
know up a character but some people I
feel okay as long as uh they got the
resources I feel like himself is okay as
long as he's playing this particular
matchup the way he wants to play and win
or lose the same side I believe I don't
know I got opened up that's for sure
challenge over there by NT great blocks
all of the players that have been
attempting to do those cross-ups do not
have not been successful he is so ready
on that defense side that's a stand yeah
well I am not counting
I suck at man that's for sure
level two
that's 50 seconds you might get close to
100 Health back there
how you're gonna get out of here how are
you going to escape from the volcanic
we're not so smart we made it in time so
that's what I was talking about the
previous game he's using that DS wheel
for the wheel kick in the air to change
the trajectory of the jump paint up to
dx9 and get the bonus so close for the
shutter strike but there are no
resources yet again for Mark always
playing humble because of the use of the
barter in this match
so good that he's gonna get the bar
against the corner once more and give it
some line give it some breathing space
he wants ET to make a mistake
long it's out yet again to quickly he
can do it he did it last time I'm
playing very very safe now EP is on a
hunt he is pressuring on and look at
this you're already in this situation do
you love to be on the corner he spends
about to get out of there yeah man he's
throwing out all the meetings right now
unable to escape his left right next up
what's up you're gonna be big damaged
one more setup that's all the instant
over here that's exactly what most
needed he needs to give her this
position right now 40 seconds on the
clock he's going to get a lot of life
back here but only one bar to work with
50 percent
cookery with two bars grown and he gets
another one it's a touch of death and
this is the last game from moku if he
wants to survive for another one
otherwise he's going home okay let's eat
teleports
against the corner he's fighting his way
out oh he's not respecting he's not your
turn I'm pressing buttons oh he wants
the baby out so bad right now come on
give me another one oh
he got him oh
McGraw E.T takes it and loses final
three out and he is gonna catch his run
back the jump boy growing in to be a
world champion Make some noise for maku
what an answer to that dresser most felt
desperate that he had to continue the
offense by any means necessary and E.T
just played him like a fiddle you just
got to give them one chance to these
level of players one chance and they
will take it Marcus says thank you to
the crowd he is going home with a berry
very honorable third place but now it's
about we saw Heroes now we are seeing
Thailand we're actually here man this is
the run back from 2017 Grand finals E.T
Shao high
oh so much
are you ready people are you ready DC
the last the last stretch two Warriors
are here two Warriors of Legend both
evil Champions and they want another
stick another Golden Stick under
collections
I'm telling you bro like this match up
back in 2017 send chills to my spine oh
yeah I signed the way they were playing
that so intensely everything was perfect
and then the diamond moment Don't Wake
Daddy occur are we gonna see it happen
again is this Don't Wake Daddy part two
no no it's going to happen man don't
wait Cronin and again like the the team
that are being used in this Moments by
E.T uh I like it man like they are
really pushing forward the meta of this
game in such a way it's like we want we
are able to uh to expectate this shift
as we see E.T there ready to face his uh
strongest strongest rival and he's
looking super sharp right now uh it
looks sharp at the beginning of the day
he's looking sharper now
and there he is
there he is with the technology
don't look at it
you don't deserve this cake I'm sorry
man that box is tripping me out he's
like what if he just makes like a sudden
motion to write and just rips it open
right now have you seen him play he's
got to have such calm hands yeah they
never move he's like programming
bringing the code or something not me
man I can roll up on him give me that DP
on that rage on the rage no but we are
talking about Xiao high right here
I am sure like he is like a like a
master pianist
you're bringing a symphony you know I
wouldn't be surprised if he does that
yeah yeah he could for sure he
definitely looks like he plays Vienna
let's go let's go because we have indeed
two artists of their craft the best of
the business and look at this ground
these are the grand finals why are you
not making noise can't hear him baby
make they won't know that this is scary
yes yes they are
Beautiful People La Familia
in the Senate of this tournament on the
toughest point
it only can get better Pockets here we
go broad finals give me the hand thank
you thank you for being here dude I
could not think of a better place to be
than right here with everybody ready to
witness the Colossal class that's about
to occur shout out to everyone that's
made this happen so far the production
staff the other commentators the players
themselves the audience the fans the
sponsors the viewers S and K that's a k
it's all coming down to this such a big
family man all United worldwide by the
law of this beautiful beautiful game and
all of the passion that we have for
fighting games let's go here it is last
but not least the poll judges oh they
pray for him baby yeah
Warriors true true warriors on the
brackets but here we go we go to the
winter wonderland in order to make
things happen as cool as it can be
thank you
it's gonna be a hush over the crowd for
this one man because this is going to be
so tense right now these guys have had
absolutely legendary matches in the past
and I don't expect that this will be any
different
how high pushing toward what it is
like unable to deal with it oh but now
finally gets the opening a little bit of
a mean space jump and E.T it's going to
provide from it oh the little knee
perfectly way going for the kick but his
life is more than ready with those big
anteaters oh pressing the buttons that's
how I move forward baby what a great
backup to stay out of the dirty houses
oh
what's that that counter hit once again
for this quick kicks pickup wow it just
goes in why not exactly I can't do it
you could do it too if you pick Kyo of
course we are not playing neutral today
buddy
no footsies I have so much options I had
a big mistake by E.T xiaohai is gonna
take this gift because he's gonna do the
most out of it 50 out of your life by
one mistake this is what happens when
you play against
you had that opening oh oh good guard
canceled there level two get that damn
and she's out of there I do agree
get that boy out of the way that's still
a lot of leaders man but hey I agree uh
like you said we're gonna go up against
this here uh two bar Isla and yeah uh
xiaomi sticking to the he's the
secondary Patriot very interesting it
was the challenge the last time it works
out let's go in this specific scenario
too
the activation and look at that also
getting the after kit on the same side
the no mix-up mix up oh tricky tricky
stuff
High well she has so many options in the
air that you have to think about
sometimes the simple ones the one you
forget yeah man and if they wanted that
also bring the most emotional damage
because because you feel like a fool
you're like oh I just didn't work wow
that means like finally showing up oh
wow height with the statement yo what an
action are you kidding me oh we're gonna
have a fight back he has some resources
on the same side also not going for the
change bro another mistake what's going
on I don't know what thought he was
doing there but
oh big big mistake over here and he will
have to shake that from his mind he has
a reason to work on he has to beat this
Legend six times in a row so he needs to
forget about those mistakes and look
into the future Pockets yeah I know I
get to forget about it too because I'm
trying to figure out what he was trying
to do there but at the same time maybe
he meant to do the level one super so
he's got to move on beyond that and we
are hopefully gonna get a sharper AET in
the second game of this Grand Final set
but xiaohai on the other hand give him
all he can handle
let's see all these lights up and go
this is what it needs
it's an opening character to control
this kyokus who has been doing so much
damage on all these top six yeah that
will be that he's supposed to utilizing
there almost reminiscent of the cool
will be in season one where you jumped
on and you just got hit
just indeed just at the beginning one
now okay the first Now Rich he has to be
outside and out of character Mrs space
bought on over there by Shanghai but now
he lands at it
staying out of there no no the second
jumper was so ready I was a little
telegraphs called I don't know man that
was huge for sale I don't know oh my God
he had everything oh
[Applause]
the most complex okie doke setup I've
ever seen oh if we are going to take it
as that now in the mirror ET is gonna
take it super fast
confirming it yes but it's an even game
and Kyo is out of the way this is good
for him he needed to get that opening
character first
oh man pace is blistering right now
keep the engine running right yeah
maintaining the momentum that's the plan
over here what the block over there but
it doesn't matter
he's definitely thinking about front
side left side this time of the backside
just only human you are only human but
but okay he's fighting back
going all the way over there not
spending any kind of research just
wanted to know combo that was big he
comes the corner oh suddenly he gets
into it no open up and she gets kicked
like a dog taking The Shins stop
approaching he said
okay okay middle side of the middle part
of the stage opening up front on the
below Zone good Michelle has comfortable
with this character
switched totally in his favor right now
not allowing ET to build up any momentum
and it means I'm spending the resources
in order to do much cloning as much as
possible High DP for you very
interesting take by Shanghai
having kids back oh no the dirty hands
trying to catch something but out of
range get over here
definitely want to get the most of that
we're gonna be super even Shanghai will
have a little bit extra bar
two and a quarter
but E.T will build his own in a first
touch there we go oh
perfect timing that lawyer but no
commitment to the slide afterwards from
HD
activation is gonna be big
but of course for him for healing and
ciao I have the advantage at least in
resources I know maximum available
anymore but I eat xiaohai with three
bars that's going to be a kill situation
yeah it doesn't matter what happens a
touch six of them
foreign
but the the humble crown and it's unable
to deliver the kill couldn't get an
extra bar there unfortunately and he's
still One Touch territory for E.T
getting three bars for South High oh
shout High plane and he knows that he
can't the touch
he has the touch
the reaction she doesn't have the power
Roblox
like a hero oh boy well we are in Vegas
oh yeah you come to bed
you have to place the odds to ladylock
shout out to them Terry by the way
didn't think he had that extreme oh look
at these people so happy Oh La Familia
let's go
let's go having such moment right here
on Las Vegas Nevada
on the stage of evil
Shanghai against E.T Legends battling
For Your Glory For Your Entertainment
people
left in the pocket right now he needs to
whip them out
oh that guard Point baby it is so
generous
oh and then again
just to learn the lesson
it's cooling right now and I can't look
at the corner shutter strike that's
gonna be it for Isla man maximum offense
from Shanghai here it reaches so far it
will always touch and shall hi now
deciding that his Kio will be almost
full kill one bar the perfect start to
keep the dominance of xiaohai into this
stage yeah man can easily slow it down
though Shanghai right now putting the
pedal to the metal going 80 miles a
minute oh let's see the carrier start
not going to kick the pressure is on Kio
is wanting to fight his way out with the
bodegas but of course the carriers are
thought always so survival and they are
hitting and we are going to get
something now no we gotta hold all of
that and get pushed out of the corner
though that's a pretty beneficial
situation for Shanghai look at all that
real estate
the challenge for me ET is so good he
said did I catch you trying to jump
again I thought we talked to this lesson
the last time oh my God you were
thinking that you have a chance but I'm
gonna wake up with the
every second spent if we reach 99.
wow but still the damage is done like
yes it it hurts but not that much not
that much uh it's Vision a and very easy
kill territory for this oh there it is
and the region it's just that like deja
vu we saw this on game number one they
confirmed as she's falling yes
golden letters for Shanghai having the
road all clear to take this game number
three one full character up over the
anchor Conan though the eight Corner
does have five bars you're very
dangerous oh yes but how much the
question how much would you spend uh all
of it right now man
now it seems that ET wants to get to
keep some on his pocket that's B though
that's why he's up there and I'm over
here
getting the fourth one immediately so
this Cronin is still super dangerous one
big boot and one level one uh one and a
half bars would be enough to end uh Isla
but is fighting this
already
wow he whipped it down see
hmm
what I was telling you one and a half
bars now he's not gonna have the live
feed here but I think the momentum
definitely is feeling like it's in DT's
hands right now it's easy but this is
even Pockets can he steal the game
had so much fun Advantage oh that's
gonna hurt
something yeah yeah that was so close to
the ground man I thought she was going
to miss it oh
and be ready people
be ready yes
this is tournament Point evil point
first how high
was his own
are we not gonna get a bracket reset
here
all Productions looking at me right now
just like they want to cut something out
on that kof tournament no recent yeah
that's it that's an exotic situation for
sure
always changing the Rhythm Pockets he's
so uh flexible so barbiable like like
watered itself
am I gonna change the pace here for E.T
oh
let's see
the damage that that he was able to
provide over there
I don't know I don't think we're gonna
find out obviously because this might
differ yeah he's going for the Double Up
Kicks and with the dancing heel the
Turning boy
we are going to eat the second character
B Janet she has to really provide right
now because Kyo is looking healthy
healthy one and a half bars almost and
just cooking up wow
and now you are you're engaged you are
in your room and that is scolding that
it's hitting hard so how high right now
just putting on a clinic with this kill
pressure all right good response from
E.T two bars left he's gonna hold this
right hard knock down what's up next oh
he went for the sea but childhood did
not let go keep him patients with the
defense knowing that each one of these
kids is
bigger yeah cheap damage over there
making kill get took his knees
[Applause]
there he finally got the kill out of
there a decent amount of Life coming
back to him as well but this Isla has
been kind of a problem for him as well
he's kind of getting the taste of his
own medicine here yeah but all of those
times like he was sending uh Como right
she will count the time to leave a
little bit longer this time but we will
have the setup here let's see lots good
stuff over there by E.T still staying
alive the carriers finally to get out of
there spending one bar moving forward on
the other side
you would never believe that would cross
up until it actually does time to expand
it let's go another one oh what a great
idea for me to just in times I'm not
gonna give you the opportunity
he had it
Let It Go began it trying to stay alive
Isla with four bars providing all of
that delicious delicious salsa too
Cronin whoa what's still fighting
patience in such a fantastic way finding
the moment where he feels gonna make the
mistake and now we have a very very
dangerous Isla with nothing to lose
cornered not even Man Four Bars yeah
she gets a touch she I would expect me
to go
oh
the challenge over there with the DP
come on and saving it for anchor throne
and bro it's coming down
this is 15 Cronin against Cronin there
are five bars for Shanghai can this be
the end are we going home or are we
getting another game are we crowning him
let's go oh
he say no shut up muscles man I can make
it believe it
gotta believe in yourself man ET
definitely leaving in the buttons here
six a finding the mark
imagine imagine this crawling with fire
bars it's so dangerous man
[Applause]
you gotta believe
make noise people
and number five yeah
you have to believe that's why we are
here
[Music]
[Applause]
play from
wow oh fantastic
what a way to send this game on this
stage
the pressure water there ah he's saying
it I got this he's becoming Mexican I'm
feeling it oh I'm feeling it too
oh well this play out as it did in 2017
man
let's go guys game number five can I can
I hear a shout for game number five
there it is
he's tremendous
looks like he has the momentum on his
side but the patience the cool way of
playing of Shanghai oh wait then you're
so historic
so well post always Pockets yeah
so privileged why oh yeah he's the
poster boy don't forget that oh the grub
no no yes come on grab it interesting
hmm
he's like a turtle there oh but what a
challenge what an option what a pickup
oh yeah go down like that don't go down
like that he wanted to go for the chips
of course
oh my God
oh he's feeling it and now in the mirror
match of course one touch from Shanghai
good meal the end oh okay wait for the
double crossing I was deep enough
over extension by E.T is gonna cause the
character
with the advantage now in terms of the
money El dinerito
all right man
what's this Fusion they do keep it solid
stay steady
just has to get down pasta oh that's a
pink one oh my keybanks to keep it up no
full body trouble here that is
unfortunate look at that look at all
that real estate from side to side
you for the fake
talico said the pirate girl but no he's
like fighting back she wants to deliver
Pisco
oh
how is key able to make that big mistake
at the start Shake It Off and and begin
to play again like the best that mental
40 to this insane pocket only a true
Master as they say recall oh God and now
shall hide
he's going to be going back into it
two bars can E.T do it again can we have
a balanced reset right here
all the people want to they want more
kof and I do not blame them
you're honest grab it to grab the
overhead stop on him no reason one more
oh he's like that bro
here we go
there is no resources enough we are
playing combo chronix right here losses
about to get another bar right there
okay next touch is gonna win for E.T
possible not for South High
how can you jump against this character
they're your movements
from this
next test is gonna kill okay here we go
ex just to stay alive trying to get for
something great block Staying Alive
against the corner keeps pushing on he's
going forward he's gonna get guard
broken
[Applause]
give up on it
again everything is trembling right now
on Las Vegas
away
the patience oh my God
[Applause]
he's going to take it so close oh man
denying the reset
denying the glory
shall hide if you're ever 20 23 champion
well deserved man oh my good Japan
Champion now evil world champion wow man
what a monster what a legend
Make some noise
make he's jump make your Chomp listen to
it
oh my God what a tournament what a crowd
what a moment to be alive
oh look at that
so fantastic
so many memories after these the glory
of all the world the most humble of
games on the biggest of stages
everyone United for the passion of these
fantastic fantastic title ah what a
fantastic way to sign off this year's
kof 2023 with authentic chaos humble K
with no bars only neutral
heck of a tournament called heck of a
tournament
I couldn't have shared it with someone
else man thank you very much for having
me here today about crew to every single
one who makes these seven possible as
you were saying the voluntaries the
production crew our Eye in the Sky have
been making sure this bridge all over
the world look at these Champions these
are your top six players and of course
your Champion make some no noise
[Applause]
yeah you're completely right yeah so so
great
ah this is just
so so many
so many great characters
players man starting with
lasted in fifth place baby give it up
for them
[Applause]
and up next we got Matt kof
and in fourth place
give it up for the kid
on third place we are going to have moku
for the second place makes Make some
noise for the man who made us believe
eating
and oh man each he's gonna qualify for
that SNK World Tour final spot since
xiaohai already received the spot from
Evil Japan but man this guy's
indomitable in first place your evil
champion
these of course are your Champions these
of course are your top six kof
winners yeah
best in the world baby yeah the elites
the upper Michelin cream of the crop
Fantastic look at those sticks man oh so
elegant
they are high qualities I wonder if now
after this
it will be uh using the blink new bling
I mean he might have beat the game a
little bit right yeah that don't look
too bad actually fantastic shout outs to
everyone who made that possible look at
those every single year the evil stops
everyone just steps it up great great
stuff all and all of that and all of
this is thanks to you our friends our
people who is watching from home who
came here to play to be part of it
keep your locals alive keep the
community to life because this is how
they can grow this is the potential we
have as a community as the FDC
[Applause]
the audience at home has been amazing
the fans all over the place we thank you
uh and we've got more to come you know
yeah there's more tournaments happening
this year yeah so much in in the road
against this next year for all the kof
fans of course the SNK fans so many
things going to happen very very soon
and I am so glad that we can share it
all together we saw it players in this
tournament we have players from Peru
from Colombia from Chile from Taiwan
from China from Pakistan from Morocco
from Mexico from the states of course so
it's such a big familiar pocket it's
always so good to see that we can travel
all over the world and find someone a
friend over there who loves the same
things that we do I don't man it's a
great feeling but speaking of friends
man I got two friends up on stage I feel
too oh baby we got Josh and Oda from S
and K here oh give you guys there is
something a little something special so
let's go over there because they bring
some news
uh I saw somebody yeah
all right it's been a while everybody so
Oda at producer at SNK and Josh
Weatherford assistant producer on kof15
[Music]
so we know everybody's still hyped from
those awesome uh fights that we just saw
but we have a few announcements we want
to roll here so go ahead and roll the
trailer please
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
city of the rules
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
so we got our own like world tours and
stuff coming up and obviously we got new
content coming for KY 15 updates for Sam
show and obviously the new fatal Fury
coming so lots of good stuff coming for
SNK fans
thank you thank you so back to Colt and
Hell buckets in the booth
oh man we are going to be analyzing that
video
weeks bro oh my God it looks so good how
will people howl the Lord the wolves are
back
oh
my god oh my god dude and then we can do
one oh that's character refinements what
got to refinement oh lord it's gonna be
a nice year 2023 man but the best is
just to come man the best is just to
come but for us man that's it isn't it
that's the end of the show yeah it's
just that moment but of course just the
start of this amazing amazing day stay
here able is not going anywhere we still
have a lot of battles to fight Pockets
yes we do man I hope I'll see you guys
at the casuals later on I need to get
them reps give me that damage we're out
of here peace love you
still coming together
[Music]
like art on the wall if they didn't know
that
evolution
[Music]
ways you can't believe
Corners down
[Music]
here it's got extra the fighter coins
from Street Fighter 6. order any entree
in the Chipotle app using promo code
hdkn 236 and received 250 fighter coins
with your order visit chipotle.com sf6
for details
you got this
only a handful of people in the world
can do it
would be
the best
but it's dangerous
these are incredible steaks you're going
to be forced to make Split Second
decisions that could cost you your life
get out whether you like it or not you
are in this race
get in the fight yes sir Gran Turismo
based on a true story radio PG-13
Red Bull gives you wings
[Music]
on the bathroom
[Applause]
[Music]
PlayStation
here we go
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
all the hopes inside of the same fear
less
[Music]
I
see any limited lacking the vision and
asking why the hell I would risk it I'm
basically different I'm everything
everything is
living foreign
[Music]
second is
on the floor
has been veered like art on the wall
uces constant and this ain't my final
form
[Music]
till I fly in ways you can't believe
brush it down
next I'll be strong
[Music]
with you
Corners down
[Music]
thank you
Horizon in a dream
[Music]
ing
believe you could be so much more made
for the moment in the era I forged live
from the minutes where the Legends all
born in the myths are forever when they
pen our Lord
Echo inside of the road clear I feel all
the hopes inside of the same fear
[Music]
s running back quarter on one cab 199
seconds is everything y'all
self-worthy I live in the impact as soon
as I push forward and tell them to hold
that roll back I see any limited lacking
the vision and asking why the hell I
would risk it I'm basically different
I'm everything they say that I hate the
arcade era live in my spirit
with all the pressure gets too strong
feel like I was born here for something
to prove wrong what was that moment when
you felt that sound I heard the crowd
Shake ground screaming one more round
the lights flash over the main stage I'm
still Brave battling the Giants are
still made the real face that's that
choice ignite the fire of a brand new
age when I hear my voice
till I'm more than what they ask of me
till I fly in ways you can't believe
[Music]
this is
throwing our System Scope because I
cause I ride when it's the only option
second is
the big
two
trenches so coming against
revered like art on the wall if they
ain't in the know better keep them
informed Evolution's constant and this
ain't my final form
till I'm more than what they ask of me
till I fly in ways you can't believe
[Music]
from this from this back
brush it down
next I'll be strong prove myself
I'm still here
[Music]
thank you
you can't believe
[Music]
foreign
when I hear my voice
[Music]
my voice
defensive pregnancy
evolution
[Music]
My Voice keeps on my soul keeps Rising
as I sing my song
[Music]
nothing something
foreign
[Music]
thank you my voice
foreign
[Music]
ignite the fire of a brand new age when
I hear my voice
[Music]
you can't believe
my voice
my voice on my soul keeps Rising as I
sing my song
[Music]
because I ride when it's the only option
second is
[Music]
my brothers
on the floor 's revered like art on the
wall if they ain't in the know better
keep them evolutions
[Music]
my soul keeps Rising as I sing my song
anything
[Music]
here we go
now
[Music]
till I'm more than one
till I fly
[Music]
all around
foreign
[Music]
of a brand new age hear my
voice
[Music]
my son
when it's the only option second is
my brothers
on the floor
that's revered like art on the wall
constant and this
till I'm more than what they ask of me
till I fly in ways you can't believe
[Music]
Corners down
here we go
[Music]
thank you
as I sing myself
[Music]
foreign
side of the road there I feel all the
hopes inside of the same fear
s
[Music]
quarter on one cab 199 seconds is
everything
yourself worthy I live in the impact as
soon as I push forward and tell them to
hold that roll back I don't see any
limit they lacking the vision and asking
why the hell I would risk it I'm
basically different I'm everything they
say that I hate the arcade era live in
my spirit
with all the pressure
she was born here for something to prove
wrong what was that moment when you felt
that sound I heard the crap Crown
screaming one more round flash over the
main stage I'm still Brave battling the
Giants are still made the real face
that's that choice ignite the fire of a
brand new age when I hear my voice
[Music]
My Voice keeps on my soul keeps Rising
as I sing my songs
[Music]
you make them feel amazing
trenches still coming against us
I know it for sure number one Contender
as soon as they hit the door
hurts on the floor
on the wall if they ain't in the know
better keep them informed Evolution's
constant and this ain't my final form
[Music]
Rising and I dream
s
keep aching My Voice keeps on my soul
keeps Rising as I sing
[Music]
this
I'm still here
I'm fine
[Music]
here we go
thank you
[Music]
shaking
My heart keeps me
[Music]
good morning
believe you could be so much more made
for the moment in the era I forged live
from the minutes where the Legends are
born in the myths of forever when they
pan our Lord I hear every Echo inside of
the world clear I feel all the hopes
inside of the same fear Shadows defeated
all of the lights in the same years when
they tell us that it's gone but y'all
I'm still here
ignite the fire of a brand new age when
I hear my voice
[Music]
you can't believe
my voice
[Music]
when it's the only option
too my brothers
has revered like art on the wall
I'm informed Evolution's constant and
this ain't my final form
[Music]
run this back
brush it down
next
I'll be strong prove myself
I'm still here
[Music]
thank you
till
[Music]
I fly
all right we heard from Psy games devs
yesterday there's so much excitement
from the open Beta especially since we
are about to meet our top six players in
Grand blue versus Rising are you all
ready
all right well let's bring them out
right now starting with the first
competitor slash GG
[Applause]
next one
up next
Camaro
[Applause]
and now we have JFK underscore JP
next up
diaphones
and lastly but not least we have both
oh
all right give it up for your top six in
gray blue versus Rising
[Applause]
all right everyone we got to continue on
with the competition I'm gonna throw it
on over to ebonic plague and Mike Ross
hey what's going on everybody Welcome to
Grand blue Rising Evolution
2023 my name is Mike Ross and I am
joined by the Beloved the legend ebonic
plague what's going on I'm the Beloved
Legend yeah you're sitting right next to
me the Mike Ross ain't nothing Mike Mike
Ross Ross oh I appreciate it uh we're
gonna see some of the best Grand blue
rising action we've seen uh ever in your
life it's gonna happen here first it's
the first time you're getting a sneak
peek at what the potential of the future
of tournaments can look like and right
now we have six killers that have made
it thus far and have outlasted everybody
else in the tournament
what are some of the uh highlights that
you you expect to see so far I mean okay
so that's like a real easy question
right because the whole tournament
obviously but yeah let's talk about it
for sure so the two people who I'm I'm
gonna be completely real with look
incredible and look Unstoppable right
now are both slash and go about it right
okay Camaro being basically the best I
don't think it is it is allowed to be
contested that Gamera is the best player
at grambly Fantasy Versus right that's
just how it's been he's got the gold
stick to prove it that's right got the
credentials but you know we gotta run up
against uh Japan uh Brethren JFK also
shuabu versus Slash GG so I mean you
know got that going on then we're gonna
find out who is going to be fighting the
illustrious diaphone and the incredible
buff right yeah shout outs to die phone
2 for uh getting top six as you know
kind of made a mention that he had uh
just kind of turned the game on and
tried to get ready and do some last
minute practice and it seems that it
paid off to get them all the way up here
um but right now it looks like we were
going to get slash GG and chewable on
the sticks
best of luck to both competitors of
course I definitely have a you know love
to see you soon I don't want to say his
bias but you know always seen chewable
or uh show up whenever it comes to Evo
performances with grand blue yeah
I'm gonna be unbiased it's going to be
even commentary and I hope both players
win and have a great time
I know you want to sing the recent pop
song
no but for real though okay so we're
gonna have slash g versus so what is
most likely going to happen is we're
going to see fairy versus probably Andre
um that's what shubu hasn't played for
most of this tournament but again you
know this is uh a new version of the
game right and Schulman was already
known to play multiple characters so
there's a chance to lose because you
know I I'm always gonna put it out there
I'm never gonna stop Mike is smiling
because he knows exactly what I'm about
to say even though if it never happens
again in my lifetime okay Suarez is
still on this game
okay
the character is grayed out right now on
that screen that is not getting picked
although you're right that would be kind
of cool to see
yeah no I mean I mean so Andre or um I
mean six has been kind of a point of
contention for this version right
because of the knockdown change so a lot
of people have been like six is kind of
weaker now because of that huh
um but I don't know we saw gouda almost
made the top six right with the
character so and uh right now yes you
kind of mentioned too slash has just
been on a tear going against everybody
along his path to get here so far so
this is uh gonna be shoebu's moment to
try to step up and see if he has what it
takes to stop this uh this madness he's
he was hovering over Grand okay
everybody in that crowd knows about all
right
but here we go this is it Evolution 2023
the first match of grand blue Fantasy
Versus Rising top six open Beta
tournament let's go
[Applause]
there we go right now yes yeah so this
is the anti-zoneer versus what would
normally do this owner now the one
that's a really nice thing for Fairy
this in uh this this version of the game
is that the fact that she can go into
guest pets from the lights and there it
is immediately at the beginning of the
game so now she has that mid-range
control that she you know didn't get too
excuse before it's really strong right
he's gonna be able to get a lot of meter
to quicker oh yeah everybody's being mad
here right now because there's so many
different versions of uh meter usage
nowadays right we've got the Horizon the
Raging strike and using immediately the
brave counter just stick it out you use
the three three point you use 50 meter
but at least you don't die it's
something you were mentioning to it
about how uh people were concerned about
the rating strike how how critical it
could be but people have found ways to
avoid it in an escape it so it's not
just yeah you could not just getting
opened up by it all day yeah yeah the
the top six definitely has shown like I
mean okay I want to know slash has no
more for every point
slash can't get out of raging strike
without doing something preemptively
right it's got to be a Dodge or It's
gotta be ultimate
GG with a very strong game despite the
fact that he used most of the meter and
use all of The Bravery points very
quickly
oh okay so I like it so shubu's game
plan here is clearly to win punish the
the normals as they come out
still just so risky but you got to be
perfectly on point with that and I mean
because he's showing that right now yep
double stab that's so hard to deal with
because when you deal with the charge to
have yourself to do with the frame did
afterwards the CX happened very very
fast gotcha don't whistle button
you were correct
okay yeah papa jump out right there with
the lights I'm not using that far heavy
it goes very very far forward it catches
the jumps and everything like that just
a strong tool from Andre in general oh
very good okay
good defense right now
yeah okay using that sweep I mean so the
triple attack was shown earlier to be an
overhead right yeah so we had to have
changed it up to sweep to try and catch
now with the ex pull in but again you
don't get a hard knock down like you
used to and she will be using that to
Advantage that is a change that
everybody is gonna have to get used to
once this game finally comes out you're
not getting your heart knocked down
after the ex pull in that move it's you
got a different factor for it now you
got to use it differently
don't have to worry so much about the
Oaky
yeah well they're definitely not setting
GG on top because then you get into an
overhead or low or what have you that's
right
this is like the frequent Zone you you
refer to oh yes yes the grand Blue zone
right here you're talking about the
grams on my phone right here
very dangerous spot for uh Slash GG but
it's uh safely whipped out of the Border
yeah oh and the two weight right there
has been a complete turnaround for that
first round and yeah you cannot easily
use things like dispense versus this but
ultimately guess that's another story
yes
putting off the dive kick the throw does
come out and yeah some people are
preemptively for attacking so that kick
it becomes real nice for it all backed
up I'm gonna use the 5H on the whiff
barely yeah that's what you were talking
about you got to be careful with that
move because you still got a block yeah
I mean it comes out too quick well the
problem is is like you know maybe the
Andre player is scouting you trying to
dodge and then the counter hits you
trying to dodge right it can just be
real scary engage
the first game right they're going to
shoot West Coast fights
okay
thank you thank you
oh my God this is gonna be oh no yeah
that could have been absolutely huge
damage now if you get heavy counter hits
in this game there isn't now a slow down
in a cinematic angle but it's also just
Mass damage they may have upped the life
across the board but the damage is crazy
that you can still get yeah
definitely has some really good defense
up
yeah well I mean your defense usually is
the name of the game for an honor player
right
oh no
that kind of damage here
okay yeah
[Applause]
oh no yeah
so slow gonna be able to get the
follow-up after the ex and that is
another round shoot look I'm on set
right now
I mean
great
crossover in it's got the corner going
nice Dodge right there gonna use the
guest fence pull in and run nice Vision
so so right there the throw uh change
the throws are now faster than seven
frames so actually uh attempted the
throw is a meaty and it ended up not
working because it was too quick
got to adjust the timing and delayed a
little bit oh air Perry
right out of his mind right now he's
playing like he's trying to win
okay
yep because this gives you an actual
this is slash is a moment to actually
get the offense started but doesn't get
any Success With It
really needed that moment oh no again
the throat changed just bodying people
right one more chance right here with
the Raging strike has the brave counter
no choice
it's going to be moving on to Winners
finals congratulations
holding it down for the West Coast
that's you right yeah
oh look at the crowd the crowd's getting
hyped yeah they got body pillows we got
signs all right
let's go thank you everyone for joining
us we got a crowd for grantly Fantasy
Versus Rising top six thank you
everybody everybody showing their
support that's awesome and uh
unfortunately you know for this next
game we might have to see a team kill
here but that's what happens when you're
so dang good at the game you're gonna
eventually get this far and you're gonna
run into your brethren yeah yeah I mean
you know we'll technically call it
America versus America and then put
Japan versus Japan right that's right
that's right we are gonna have Chimera
and we are gonna have JFK but they're on
the same team it's not even just like a
oh yeah they're both Japanese no it's
they're legitimately on the same team is
what you mean by the T kill yeah yeah I
mean but that's why they got where they
are they're two phenomenal players one
of the best in the world if not the best
and uh gonna try to run it back and
defend that Crown what's gonna happen
who knows
it's up to uh up to the feet yeah well I
mean so we talked about it a little bit
earlier is shown to be probably the best
player on the planet for this game right
I don't think there's a bait I don't
think we can refute that he's not at
least top two uh you know that kind of
thing right
um JFK has shown to be one of the best
lancelots you could ever look at in this
game and uh despite some of the changes
that a lot of Lance block players were
talking about well
I don't know it's doing pretty well
seems to be working for uh for JFK here
yeah I know so most of the Lancelot
players from what I've heard of don't
really feel that he's as strong as he
possibly could be but here we're seeing
uh somebody begs to differ yeah well
some people definitely don't
uh enjoy the changes yeah yeah yeah for
sure right but you know it's not
enjoying the changes is definitely
different than the character getting
like the Nerf gun right yeah you want a
one-button win right you mean six
success
last players are working hard they're
working hard well one of the one of
these two is uh wow it's like that money
you know there's an entire crowd of
people that I think could take you yeah
I'm not making it out here alive I know
now but but for real though um so one of
the things that we are definitely going
to be looking out for um in regards to
Lancelot yeah is uh ultimate turbulence
ultimate tournaments is now his Dragon
punch right so you really got to pay
attention to that
um because when there's 50 meter on the
table Lancelot now has Dragon punch
right uh whereas before it used to just
be an ex but they changed the way across
the floor
and you know things are not the same uh
now now also uh the uh the the staff
that goes across the screen yeah that is
now a 623 input instead of six six right
they've changed a couple of things right
but um you do not get a combo mid-screen
off it on counter hit it wall bounces
off the corner now okay so she will get
a million percent damage yes that's an
adjustment yeah so they still try to
keep it strong in one area of the screen
but like try to take away the craziness
of it in another area you know it might
come into play might not uh in
particular I think the punish game is
actually going to be on camera right
because UL has always been known to be
this with punishment monster having you
know the uh the forward advancing
buttons far-reaching far H as well uh
the medium one is the one I'm talking
about we're at Ford advances uh and look
at that yeah rep your brand wrap it
let's go JFK camera
who is going to make it the winners
finals right versus
[Music]
they got the best captions easy
tricks won't be enough to Snuff out my
flames
you can back that up
one of my favorites is uh is when
Pharaoh fights Eustis she goes that gun
won't help you here
we go okay
now things have changed very quickly
protects the throw
yeah they're so patient
well that's the name of the game of the
ground like uh right it's like you
really want to fish for the little
nickel and dime hits or you can you know
try to get a counter hit off with punish
let's do something big so the patience
is incredibly important
[Music]
JFK did have a brave counter available
yeah but opted not to use it because you
get a lot less damage mid screen than
you are going to be getting it uh you
know uh
and then sometimes you have to just take
it also hilariously enough skybound art
uh off of like a 5 8 might just kill
right here
100 pretty important
from either side
you don't want to whip anything huge
because that is a whiplunch tool for JFK
oh there's the Ultimate Dragon Punch
Yeah gets out of it I know I'm right
back at you yeah
so they both have Ultimate Dragon
punches but Gamera was looking for JFK's
that that was one of those things where
like I don't know if you've done this
but when I play sometimes somebody will
do a uh an option and it'll remind me oh
yeah that option's there I'm gonna do it
too
that definitely happens
so jump to get out oh nice so sneaky
that Lancelot movement yeah unique
action to go back into the corner
there's no way to come out and expected
that right okay
and there's that wall down there right
yeah that's the change yeah
so yeah the corner damage is uh is still
pretty good for for Lancelot he's just
not getting as much mid-screen I think I
think with the design philosophy was to
try and like uh homogenize between
damage a little bit
yeah I agree I agree with that change
raging strike right there again
opting to take it huh
yeah well I mean you know what it worked
out yeah
okay this time I feel like yeah every
time you have to do it you don't have a
choice yeah that would have been the
round which would have been the game
yeah
okay there it is
picking all the right spots for it you
you mentioned that that was going to be
one of the key factors here we're seeing
a great usage out of it too yeah yeah no
I mean so that's the same thing we've
only had about 15 total hours I want to
say it this game so far right that has
been totally playable with with you
count both Evo and the open Beta so we
haven't really gotten 100 of the
ultimate skills idea right some are
better than others clearly and an
Ultimate Dragon punch is always going to
be good
there we go again some nice decent
Corner damage
being able to put back Camaro probably
is back on
love how JFK's movement with lanceloton
willing to back off in the Camaro
approach him yeah
is it safe to come out no it's not and
there it is right there no ants here
whatsoever from coming up
yeah it doesn't want to doesn't want to
take that corner away right
[Music]
[Applause]
is a very tired boy
oh no ants here again turbulence though
coming down with it he's gonna try to
get as much chip oh no fake it out for
the throw but again that increased our
attack window but there it is
six two three
[Music]
battle two engage
the whole very offensive start right
there and I mean
clearly Gamera not ready for it because
did nothing right yeah
some success
try to get the link on that one but
wasn't close enough to the corner
unfortunately yeah you do not have to
answer you do not have to do the Raging
change right you can link off if you're
close enough
[Music]
drops the combo though and you have
frame traps right into the rest of it
The Stance cross trains and I mean JFK I
think honestly is in a pretty good
position to be able to just kind of
nickel and die but oh try to go to the
ultimate Fireball and gamero was already
on it
there it is
now on Match Point
yeah nice safe pressure with the Jabs
right there basically just embodying
just not trying to do too much that'll
allow JFK to get out remember you want
to stop uh the lens block here from
trying to jump out right wall jump out
Etc right we've got a lot of options
[Music]
take your turn back yes that's right JFK
understanding what the ul's options are
and again understanding what ul's
options are Delta jumps great
Effectiveness pushing towards the corner
and everything JFK's like great
paper throw all caught sleeping too that
wasn't a No Escape and that is gonna be
a raging strike but no no follow-up
didn't want to spin the meter
oh my God the defense is on point
there it doesn't can yeah blocking
forward with that far am you can catch
people walking back doesn't really
matter nice gets caught yeah tried to
cross over right oh there it is Strike
Force the brave counter
[Music]
yeah I see you
yeah this movement is super crazy right
now
Point yeah
it's been 100 with those DPS yeah just
forcing the brave counters too because
that's gonna take away meter and a
breakpoint there's only so many of those
you can do around
the ex right there yeah this is super
tense because they cannot make a mistake
only 16 seconds left on the clock too
you gotta remember that's a thing okay
that was a True Guard string so that's
why it did not break
and here it is right before JFK had the
chance to be able to Brave Conor because
there wasn't enough meter you need 15.
he had like 39-48 something like that
not quite there Gamera sending his
teammate into losers and uh Gamera will
go on to face shoopable and winners
finals
play and it made so much sense because
one
one from either of them put them in just
such a bad position all right oh my God
that is a big stick oh yes oh yes
I've seen the pictures of it being
played on setups that's not playable it
is that's too large
operated by three people I won that
person right there okay
I'm sorry oh yeah I'm not uh not capable
to use a stick of that size that's
amazing
uh thank you so much everybody for
joining us here for Grand blue Fantasy
Versus Rising top six here at Evo 2023
we are going to get into more to more
losers action here in just a minute but
first we're gonna take a quick break so
please stick around and we will be right
back
at Chipotle real food always starts with
real ingredients in real kitchens when
you order Chipotle real food starts with
you whether it's in restaurant pickup or
delivery however you Chipotle is the
easiest way to Chipotle
oh no
super roll up
Victory feels good
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
hey what's up everyone we at tenno are
Beyond excited to announce the launch of
some brand new merchandise for Evo
beginning with our new officially
licensed Street Fighter designs which
include premium embroidered hoodies and
more also we have new officially
licensed designs for the King of
Fighters 15 Guilty Gear Tekken and other
fgc partners each tenno product is
carefully designed by fgc heads with
only the best material for maximum
comfort and style trust me you don't
want to wait to cop these
welcome back everyone to Grand blue
Fantasy Versus Rising top six here at
Evo 2023 we just saw our winter winter
sets and uh well we definitely saw some
of the best players go to Lucy's bracket
here and it's that's right shark
infested waters and uh it only gets
worse and worse because we are now going
down to the losers bracket to see who is
strong enough to rise to Glory that's
right I mean shark infested waters
indeed but we're definitely all in the
deep end at this point when you get this
far into the brackets oh yeah you know
it's expected at this point uh and it
looks like we're gonna go to the losers
quarters and we will have slash GG
versus bum correct and as on the other
end we will have JFK going against
iPhone yeah so we're gonna get to see
our first two siegfrieds here in loose
bracket right now
um one of the things that I was
personally looking towards was seeing
all the Siegfried right yeah Siegfried
was a very popular during the beta
online it's hard not to do a Siegfried
beer you know right like just like it's
how hard it's not to get excited for
this top six thank you so much guys here
for joining us at Evo 20 23 you guys are
awesome
so it is going to be slash GG versus
Buzz so we saw the ferry a little bit
earlier Siegfried we're gonna get to
talk quite a bit about gurgle time
they both have a sign I know you got one
too flash don't look at me like that
so I should try to focus try to focus
yeah yeah so uh you know thanks thanks
to the n a uh PC Graham blue Fantasy
Versus Discord with all these with all
these signs I already know it I already
know it yeah they're definitely
representing right now
and yes yeah you say you're going to get
a fairy versus sick for you here see
what secret can do
well there's there's quite a bit to talk
about honestly you know I mean okay so
this character obviously we've only had
the beta to try them out right like it's
a 15-hour character yeah yeah so I got
to try them out I've mostly played
Siegfried throughout the entire beta
okay and immediately shot up to my top
five funnest characters for this game
like no questions asked I love this
character what was it what was it that
you liked all right so well the problem
is this is a bias for me right okay so
one of the things going on is that I uh
either only play characters that hit
really hard or I play shadow wizard
right and so this guy just hits really
hard okay
straight to the point I like that so
yeah you're gonna see one of the
stronger Fireballs so he's getting ready
to pass Fireball and he's got another
Fireball it's very slow but you can't
Dodge it right right or well you can try
but it's not a great idea
that one right there it is yeah yeah
it's also correct oh yeah punish buttons
but they have high recovery as a result
in a lot of range too yeah you don't see
the range on that 2H right there with
the anti-air didn't get the full combo
but boy that stop slash GG's attempt at
getting away from the corner nice Dodge
but immediate Dragon punch
yeah forcing the 50 meter out of Slash
though I I like that because you spend
25 meters to take a break and 50 bar I
think you're winning in that train yeah
yeah that's worth it getting a lot of
resources for it losing a lot GG
stopping uh
I love the effect on that swing
you also just keep it just uh nice and
civil you know so you're keeping them at
the mid-range that's exactly where slash
GG wants to be in front of space the
problem is being a foreigner also sucks
so yeah trying to get Indiana Jones the
way on how to like that technical term
technical terms yes uh disclaimer I
don't know what I'm talking about
it's gonna set up GG again and yeah so
GG um has it been less and less useless
like a set play and more and more uses
that way to stop jumps right so oh way
to stop jumps right there Bebo as well
Victory on that one and is not gonna get
it it's actually gonna die for it yeah
actually to be honest with you slash GG
yeah uh qualified for top eight on
winter side off of a one-hit confirm
into Super skybound art so you know try
to maybe uh Miss input saw something uh
that thought was there was just just
wasn't sick if it hit oh yeah if it hit
him yeah
this has just been all slow gameplay and
I mean this is what fairy does to you
right she forces you to stop and think
about literally every action you have
you gotta play her game oh the dash
attack everywhere oh and there's the
ultimate TP that's gonna get blocked and
punished
[Applause]
[Music]
fireballing happens
there's a block stun on that it's crazy
yeah yeah it's real good yeah
frames right there but I think trying to
jump out I'm not sure it's kind of got
clipped uh oh behind Rick then up okay
here we go I'm Magnus that was not
intentional I think that was meant to be
ultimately personally but I could be hey
good calling okay
what so the thing is it's actually a lot
easier to tell now because an ultimate
move requires you to press the unique
action and Magnus when it's activated is
just unique action right so
allows for an easy confirm right there
and because it was a light oh my God
no full conversion though
early wow I mean right read just wrong
time
her reaction I should say
okay yeah there's a mix up right there
so rekka Series has follow-ups for every
single button right so uh the medium
follow-up is a Perry and the unique
action follow-up is a command grab so
you gotta watch out for them that's a
good mix very nice yeah and then there's
that with punishability we talked about
also has a dive kick I just love it I
can talk about it
everything you can want in your
character
yeah actually I do it personally and
Barry still doesn't care though yeah
Harry does a lot of pushing me away for
sure no confirming to ssba but there's
that 2m one of the furthest reaching
just normal guys who ends you've ever
seen
okay plus Prince a little bit on this
one yeah The Bravery counter just
getting out of here and we're setting up
the big Fireball to get in
oh big fire but yeah I was trying to
answer with a spit Fireball right but uh
just just a little bit too high you know
Ferry is very floaty when she jumps
especially on the super jump it's crazy
but there's the DP I don't know what it
punished but it got it
[Applause]
yeah so I mean that's another crazy part
about Siegfried too is the dragon puppy
is massive and the medium version moves
forward and then so like you do the ex1
and it's just it's just gigantic it
moves forward it has a secondary slash
on it there's wow it just gives a free
jump in no anti-air gets to combo off
this and face does so gets a magnet
second one right there and now you're
gonna see the increased damage on having
two back nience plus all the counter
hits missing the link unfortunately but
I mean you gotta notice that it is
absolutely his most favorite right now
oh yeah Buzz going crazy right now
right right
oh that makes sense and yeah suppose
just timing that jumps perfectly
[Music]
yeah I love using pepper back right
because any Siegfried would want to use
fighting absolutely it's just the
perfect button for that distance oh spot
that's just a little bit too early
getting caught oh no
so you can't get the follow-up hit
screen unfortunately but I think uh you
know you'll take the corner carry at
least
let's friends here oh yeah that's full
conversion skybound all right big damage
yeah finish it off
congratulations to
I'm making it through defeating slash
got the gurgle gurgle for the rest of
the tournament now right
yeah we got a congratulations to uh the
slash GG making it this far in the
tournament Yes yes again this is the
first time we're getting to have a big
old tournament for gambling Fantasy
Versus Rising before the game comes out
thank you so much cygame for putting
this together thank you so much all of
you out there for sitting here in the
stands and watching it with us and
everybody at home as well this is going
to continue being just as good as it has
been I'm sure of it
it is I love this aggression yeah he was
on a roll right here
yeah this is where it really kicked up
enough right like just ready for a spot
hit and this is gonna finish it off
because this has happened to slash GT
multiple times now if you haven't played
against Siegfried enough maybe maybe you
know maybe you're not privy
um so he can do the big slam down with
the sword yeah but he can also charge it
he does not have to let it go
immediately right so some people have
been spot notching expecting an
immediate one and then they want to get
a punish yeah but or take the turn back
depending on you know what the situation
actually is and so because of that you
actually get ended up getting caught by
the charged one yeah which is also Plus
off block if you charge it long enough
by the way it's good uh you probably
just needed to delay the Dodge a bit
right but yeah yeah
it's a guess at that point yeah you have
to really really either be play uh know
the player Tendencies yeah or you're
you're just a gun yeah
I can tell you're gonna tell it's being
held but uh yeah definitely uh yeah
congratulations to but on that one and
we are going to go into our next match
which will be JFK JP versus difo yes so
Lancelot probably gonna see another
Siegfried um out of the iPhone so so
suddenly I'm like
it's diaphragm so yeah I could you just
pick a character and he probably plays
it right okay but again you mentioned at
the very beginning of this uh the iPhone
really only got so much time yes
yeah yeah give it up for never
surrendering I love it yes believe in
Victory that's right
we also like I I usually expect uh you
know the iPhone to be able to play
anything you know maybe oh wait we have
a character matchup oh what's that
Shilling his YouTube channel
hey make sure you guys like And
subscribe
Channel there where you can see all the
different characters that die from
that's right yeah he he didn't enter
this tournament to when he entered for
the contest I respect it well I mean uh
you can you can absolutely expect the
video that's right yeah there's no
question well there should be multiple
honestly but uh yeah so but because of
the the fact that iPhone had only played
so much recently right yeah like just
kind of practice for Evo a little bit
yeah you said what it was it like 12
hours yeah 15 hours probably yeah I
think you know so I don't actually
expect another character yeah because of
that I think I think like the muscle
memory is too ready for Siegfried yeah
uh which I I never thought I would say
that diaphone would not play another
character
yeah iPhone's super strong and just
about everything does I think I think
they're maybe asking for a button check
oh okay yeah okay yeah yeah so it is a
butt check okay cool
or at least I thought of it yeah you get
this far into it you want to make sure
everything is perfect no I don't want to
take any chances I totally understand
yeah I mean uh we actually had a
somebody during the the Fool's match the
ABS right you will let them know
but they did the button track and so
they found out and everything was fine
did they play the match out no no oh
okay because they asked for their butt
checked it was like yeah yeah so you got
to be real careful watching you're
watching your buttons that's right I
know I know people don't like uh
watching the button checks myself
included yep but but yeah there's a
reason why some people at the top level
right it's like every all their
conditions are perfect yep and they're
never gonna mess anything up if they can
help it okay
that's right
oh the iPhone
versus the iPhone losers quarterfinals
here we go
already with the uh with the with the
movement right we're talking about the
four and again
messing up JFK to the point where it's
iPhones didn't even react to the second
one
see if there's any uh yeah difference
here in the play style between the
iPhone yeah yeah that's an easy punish
too you know that's one of those boots
that was always like that and now you
have to deal with this uh raging strike
yeah look at the damage afforded
that wasn't a fair comparison because
this is very you can try to control the
space in there oh yeah oh no oh no
no didn't
you possibly oh come and grab all right
we're good we're good the iPhone's
laughing they're leaving some hits you
know on the floor
yeah I mean iPhone even went for the
delayed to a uh 12 pickup right which is
actually something you only get if uh 2x
hits by itself uh you won't get that one
that's like they'll flip out and try to
do it in combo right
um so I I thought it was ready for it
but evidently not right there yeah slide
punished through the space ain't it's
using that okay Dash attack low that is
a completely new mechanic for this and a
lot of people are just not ready for it
it has one of the best and I am saying
that with confidence that is all I saw
when I was playing online
I see that from Secret but uh obviously
at this point it's not going to be
overly used yeah but the iPhone had
success using it twice okay well you
know what else is over in America is
absolutely a raging track
a launch do you think it was impunity
really and JFK may have brief counter
the second third one yeah but it didn't
matter because the life total was just
so much of a difference at that point
JFK seemingly not ready for this place
time yeah
here it is now trying to go for the
Ruckus to be able to uh you know frame
trap we're always getting mixed in there
as well and yeah iPhone does not have to
early Tech right because the thermostat
window is so much bigger you can't
really get that movement option uh to be
able to help them trick the opponent
trying to throw attack and then punish
right three for three yeah it's working
it is effective it is it is a it's a
very uh because as long as it's space is
not functional which you're you're only
trying to use open space right
um whereas if it's up close
[Music]
yeah it is
to change it see if it feels worth it
back into the corner though is a
champion oh got frame trapped there's
the low again that's that's what five or
five I think it's actually six okay six
or five okay but six or five
okay all right all right I got you I
speak words
engage
but being though is uh you know I can't
tell if it's because JFK isn't ready for
it or if they're expecting the overhead
because it's been low almost right yep
that's true
yeah again you haven't had that much
time to really see it you know yeah but
I mean it's just one of the best I
personally I think Vera is also another
really really strong one
um but you know we don't have it here
currently so you can't see it
all right I'm all set up right now
trying to catch the chocolate Sidekicks
that's a really good option for oh wow
Ultimate Dragon functioning on the other
side
again trying with these low base right
here is JFK it's just so I won't stop in
the tracks
no no okay I was gonna say there's no
way I've tried to react to it but uh
good you know I think Super skybound but
you know you don't have that like you
have too much help yeah win last that's
right
come here comes are you ready
you know what longer invincible
it's gonna do an iPhone we have our two
sigrees moving on So You Know
we have a Siegfried face is it gonna
happen we're gonna find out who's about
six inches that's awesome that's right
he's gonna happen right now in the world
because as we know your matches are the
only way to tell yeah that's right yeah
that's the only thing that matters it's
the only thing of importance yeah of
course but uh again shout outs to JFK
for making it this far in the tournament
uh but we will see uh diaphone ampa
later in the losers losers yeah yeah so
it's a little bit later but before we're
gonna be getting into that everybody we
are going to kick it to a quick break
before we get into our winners finals
which will be three out of five and it
will be shuabu versus Gamera so please
stick around because that is going to be
a bar inverter we'll see in a second
your Chipotle order just got extra
fighter coins from Street Fighter 6.
order any entree in the Chipotle app
using promo code hdkn 236 and received
250 fighter coins with your order visit
chipotle.com sf6 for details
I asked for an equal
this is what you find
sir perhaps a new hunting ground
Creighton wants a hunt I've given one
he'll never forget better take him out
before they find the lizard
gunship will quit I do
I do know
Red Bull gives you wings
oh no
super Lola
Victory feels good
right here
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
y'all have
a question
and asking why the hell I would risk it
I'm basically different I'm everything
they say that I is
all depression
test that choice ignite the Fire have a
brand new
like
oh till I'm more than what they ask of
me
until I fly in ways you can't believe
[Music]
back here the Evo show for its Evo
connections presented by a t my name is
vicious with the man who really needs no
introduction but just in case you didn't
know it's my boy my brother the
legendary tasty Steve what's good with
you boss man you know me man low key to
the people need me enjoying Evo 2023 it
has been spectacular already I've been
seeing you doing your thing you've been
on the big stages too you talking about
me but I'm looking at you on the main
Evo stage I ain't even been up there yet
but as you can see it's been amazing bro
we standing in front of Tekken eight
Mortal Kombat one is right here project
L's right there it's a lot of stuff
happening I'm just happy to be here bro
you've mentioned so many games just off
the rip because you've played almost
every game that's here in this Ballroom
by the way you're a man of many talents
you're masterful on the on the
microphone you must know a lot of people
right you are the mayor of the fgc so my
big question to you is what does it mean
to you being able to connect with every
single person here how much does that
mean to you being here at Evo this year
well I'm gonna tell you right now the
thing is is that like when I go and I
you know I travel a lot just came back
from Saudi Arabia I was in Pakistan
before that Singapore two I love
connecting with the communities I'm a
culture junkie I love to see how other
communities survive and not just you
know in real life you know but in
fighting games but when we come to Evo
we get to see everybody all at one time
we get to see all these people at one
time and some of the people you know
this we only get to see them once or
twice a year so it's like we get to see
family again when we come to Evo you get
to see all the homies I get to see you
you know what I'm saying like what else
do I need it's the fgc barbecue and
everybody's pretty much invited right so
my other question to you this is gonna
be a little bit of a fastball because
you've been almost everywhere at every
single moment what has been your
favorite moment thus far here at Evo yo
I'm gonna tell you right now it's been a
few uh one I just did uh block a
commentary for Ultimate Marvel versus
Capcom 3 with the legend
IFC yipes and I'm gonna tell you right
now anybody who knows me knows I'm a
Marvel fan and if you know marvel then
you know yikes that's God like and I got
to open up my commentary for Street
Fighter 6 with the boys say jam it's
it's just amazing to me that I'm still
able to one operating in space and two
you get to see legends operate at their
highest form I know I'm all right on the
mic but when I see other homies go up I
see the yikes I see the same Jam I see
the Justin walls I see the level up your
game grips I see those guys it inspires
me my favorite part and one of my best
part about this is connecting and
working with a lot of the homies from
the fighting game Community as well as
seeing all the beautiful people here you
already know what it is it's all love
full transparency by the way he is a man
of the people here at the FTC hopefully
you can catch him on the main stage
which is exactly what we're going to
take you back to enjoy even more of the
fighting game action
welcome back thank you so much everybody
at Evo 2023 for waiting we are back with
more of grand blue Fantasy Versus Rising
top six we have actually narrowed it
down to top four now right and we are
going to be getting in to our winners
finals that's right it is going to be
Us's own shoe Abu versus Japan Gamera
winners finals was not you know I'm very
proud to see shubu making it this far
again yes I'm openly biased just to see
that website
but yeah you know going against the
toughest and greatest Grand blue player
of all time is going to be an
interesting match interesting challenge
to see if shubu can figure out the tools
to get around the Beast the monster
himself yeah I know the greatest part
about this Winner's finals too is that
everybody in the crowd is joining him on
signs and everything yes they all got
the signs of course they got the sign
I'm sure rallied in the crew distributed
them thoroughly
buddy look at him everybody waiting to
see some high level Graham blue oh yes
oh no somebody crying
no but I'm sorry bro like if you need a
hug let me know I got you
oh oh
it's your recess right yeah okay we
zoomed in enough for two reasons okay
yeah
so don't tell production but I'm playing
PBF right now
[Laughter]
just you
playing on that gold stick yeah yeah
just letting you know please let them
know it's the winners finals three out
of five
Gamera USA Japan let's go
three out of five set here we go
so you know honestly if we're talking
about rambling Fantasy Versus yeah I
would never I would never say yeah this
is totally winners finals absolutely
well versus Andre no he would never hear
me say those words
yeah I'm paying attention
you don't know when it's coming right
yeah yeah it's nice I mean it's just a
common option if you actually know how
to fight on right that's like one thing
right right the thing is you actually
have to know how to fight right oh
taking the turn back right there using
the Ultimate Dragon punch
on block right there
I don't know
before but I feel like when she was keep
playing it right now it's not using
Perry it's fun so that it can be kind of
off the table and come out of my opinion
and then start to bust it out yeah
you gotta train your opponent hold on
yeah yeah because raising strike
completely messed and there is just
enough whiff recovery on that that's to
be the case
[Music]
I understand if if like somebody tells
me Romero reacted to raging Spike I
believe okay
17 frames my king
good Dodge
America
[Applause]
no bravery counter either because you
didn't have the 50 meter so that was
free for Gamera that's why they went to
the option that's an expensive founder
absolutely but it's also like well do I
want to die yeah right
looking real strong in that first game
very solid first game
I mean it's
it feels like he has the complete
package when it comes to playing this
game right there's always a good punish
the reaction is always there there's
just the the conditioning that puts the
opponent in such a bad position yeah
that you know it's all common as a
favorite
really all there yeah I think it adds to
something too it's uh it looks very calm
and relaxed up there oh no no pressure
at all literally too tired
that is another thing that people are
gonna have to adjust to once this game
finally comes out okay that is a new
Option and that will allow for
knockdowns normally
for you
can't frame try me if I'm just
adventurous that's right
respect the rules yeah I mean as long as
your meta has a 50 meter you have to
think about it and well the cooldown
available of course but how nice
oh but the active frame that's the Dodge
yeah I think she will lose started to
recognize that there was a ton of
dodging yep and it's like okay so we
just hit as many active frame Cuts as we
possibly can stop yeah I'm gonna get
around all of the stabbing
what's that
okay and I mean a Subaru can actually
free trap there with uh with no issue
right because the the ultimate dragonfly
wow caught the back jump is that
calculated
is that a call out I'm sorry I know you
want it back though that was impressive
Beyond impressive yeah but okay it has
all these plus frames just continuous on
the pressure normally you consider Andre
to be the anti-zone or annoying guy but
like I mean look at this he looks like a
satellite character right now that was
really good too I like that
the space
counter because you don't want to lose
that chance we've seen what Camara does
when you give them a hitch right
you should do it
what it has
what happens
one game a piece right back on
yo let's go I mean it's winning final
for a reason right
uh scratching his ear
making some adjustments gonna get the
wall bounce on this one so
version of the Foxfire but the question
is what happens it's Gotta Be raging
strike right oh okay well never mind
okay oh Pig drops no
I was thinking it's raging strike
because at the time shubu did not have
50 meter he couldn't do anything if he
got hit by it
well I guess he could try to Parry and
wake up right
it's a risk
knife just I mean keeping that mid
screen game
for now I mean he doesn't have the
Lively though so his feeling nice kind
of pushed to the corner yeah I like this
oh okay step gotta watch out for
ultimate DP though oh what a Dodge on
the Raging strike
you know I'm starting to wonder if
people are just watching the meter to
see if it acts better than you know
right I mean yeah that should be in uh
you need that information is it coming
it's possible I mean oh why would they
randomly just lose 50 meter right like
or 25 excuse me
hmm it delays it and I mean there's chip
here yeah basically any any way that
went forward yeah was Chip territory
right because you're you're no longer at
the the amount of life that allows you
to take at least one chip damage yeah no
you were just done
I mean this is not set point we are in
three out of five territory I don't
remember that that's right that's right
bounce here
okay so again we are Justified
[Music]
too
I'm gonna have to deal with it
the dog Sly Fox
oh but there's the hashtag low you know
I mean we saw a lot of that with
diaphones right yep
comment are presenting new options
that's crazy like
do stuff
oh no not blocking low yeah I probably
tried to jump out right there right
because a really strong option for Andre
is to do um uh instant air dive kit
right uh very very good uh because you
can also you know try to get the plus
friends off it or what have you or you
know or you just get the hit right just
get out of the corner
you haven't seen this all weekend
character select it's six oh
Reese's book
you're welcome thank you thank you thank
you
[Music]
yeah so here it is I mean you know we
saw a lot of this character from Buddha
throughout the tournament
pools and stuff like that so there are
changes and there are things you do have
to adjust to you know I mean this this
is one of the characters that you pretty
much had seen to be very relaxed yeah
and uh there's not always that situation
anymore due to the knockdown change you
know six has to change things to make it
so that he can continue doing it but
right now you're not even on offense
Thunder flash means nothing to Gamera so
far the Foxfire connects and that's
always going to be plus range
right now
I finally get some some rooms and some
distance
and the best defense is a great offense
right right no punishment especially
with a character like six that's what
you need to make happen just go in you
don't want to have to block this
character for very long
yeah throw would normally be just such a
great mix-up story in that situation
right you're only really getting Chip
damage okay plus here
yeah that was guaranteed once you block
the five H right
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
so currently set point for garment right
now
I can punch hey I mean you know that
actually stops from uh should we were
imposing the will even though it traded
right yeah so I I think that's pretty
good oh my God
no yeah
badly placed
yeah it's basically just been looking
out for Thunder flash but there's not
been a single one
no Parry whatsoever
yeah
I'm gonna recognize it there's gonna be
a wall I feel like yeah
oh wow full extension and good stuff
right there gonna move on to Grand
finals yet again
you know and I mean of course you and I
are both a little biased of course yeah
I mean you know
gonna have to go into losers finals now
yeah so I mean somebody's gonna have to
have the fun of fighting uhubu and loses
finals which I mean you know we are
poised to figure that out here as we now
have the fabled Siegfried mirror you're
gonna literally fight with your inner
demons right now that's right internet
dragons
that works okay we got diaphome versus
bug coming up Siegfried versus Siegfried
uh both players looking phenomenal as
you saw earlier I think diaphone is
looking really good
partly because I'm more biased
commentary here is I like the way he's
playing Siegfried I like that I like the
dash lows I think it's super effective I
haven't seen too much of it but every
time it happens it hits
can't argue with stats he's got a 99
yeah do it just keep doing it don't look
out for it I mean the thing that I I
also want to add to that is that uh it's
a mirror yeah all right character yeah
Bond knows this character but is it
going to be enough time to really know
I mean they both had to watch each
other's matches at one point
okay you're right
right so I mean you know Siegfried
mirror uh we could just see a ton of
Nationals I I don't know right that
would make me happy
right now right so a lot of people are
getting their instant Dash attacks that
they do want and uh you know as as we
get more and more access to the game
there is a chance that we are going to
find some hilarious possibilities oh for
sure but it's it's definitely a
possibility right gas macro is a good
help with stuff we could maybe maybe
like our routing completely changes to
always incorporate some kind of instant
Dash attack you know it's we've got time
to figure this stuff out right now
so right now their time is out because
they gotta perform right now like unless
they discover it mid-match some new tech
[Music]
okay so if they're finally getting into
it Mike bro you just gotta you gotta
yeah you can't handle me
it's coming from Left Field sometimes
[Laughter]
that's right you're right yeah
that's right you got to hear it you're
here yes it is yeah well you know what's
funny is uh considering this character
actually you know another thing about it
iPhone has been playing so
victory
good yep I mean it looks like it yeah
there's the dash low it's starting
here's your favorite mic that's right
loser semi this is two out of three here
yes we have to move right back yeah so
that doesn't make crouchers I don't
think yeah uh I could be wrong but it
might have just been a horizontal
distance thing instead
yeah
I think Bud doesn't care about this was
expecting him to be quite honest
thank you it's okay I feel better now
[Music]
yeah I love the dash break right like
you're trying to stay outside of the
Siegfried range yeah because you know
the character very well right so you
know the rate right
here's the record series tried to jump
out that's an excellent move in Catching
shots very very good because there's
just enough of a gap to another jump and
then you just get clicked that's what
you're talking about it's very difficult
to spot Dodge
Oh What A Catch right there to confirm
so that was actually thanks to the
counter hit slow down here that was an
easy confirm for both
first round buff
[Music]
and for for all those Dash loads they
can't connect I guess it wasn't enough
at the time
oh the range oh was that a blocked one
yeah
I didn't see it so it didn't happen
you miss timed it all night spot dogs
yeah oh that was a dragon Punch Yeah if
I recognized it yeah so that's the light
version of the Dragon pots he does not
make the jump right so he if he stays on
the ground when it happens that's the
meteor version right there right I love
seeing the dp's just rock it's a dragon
you gotta show me a funnier you're
willing to bust out a little bit that's
right
as soon as they put it right in their
mind
that you can and you will know the dive
kick saving the life of uh right there
trying to Magnus I think that was super
skybounder not gonna but finally gonna
hit it watch this animation
animation dang it
I wanted the animation I was excited
strong over diaphone right now tattoo it
just don't know me what was what was
getting a lot of mileage for guyophone
definitely was like you're 100 correct a
lot of the mileage for iPhone was Dash
low yeah but if you're if you're getting
hit in the situations that are less and
less about the dash low if you're
getting knocked down less you're taking
a lot less incidental damage here and
there and so it doesn't add up as much
you're not being pushed to the corner as
much Etc et cetera right
and there it is
I mean you know when somebody is
specifically looking for it yeah right
then yeah oh ultimate DP yeah because
you know you recognize how big dragon
punch is for this character so so the
dive kick is no longer going to be a
factor if you're just command the skies
yeah
a lot of success on the jumpers but no
follow-up there for the iPhone it's that
low yep and I mean like instant
dashboard can even be a factor around
here because you're playing in that
mid-range where you're trying to walk
forward a little bit Yeah straight
walking through it right right
[Music]
my heart
okay so the iPhone coming back in there
I feel like that's a good morality right
because you're not immediately having to
go down around when when your opponent
is up a game too so you don't have to
worry about coming back from set point
right like you can you can slow down
your heart rate a little bit as a result
yeah
okay okay
remember you can't go for the eight
follow-up off of a Rebecca if you did
the light record which you can't combo
into the medium version of rekka without
like a better star in the legs out
so it actually creates an artificial
wall really interesting I like that yeah
Own It Again
[Music]
[Applause]
with no reaction s
oh that really had a hundred bar had
three bravery points put it absolutely
I've done it but yeah I mean you still
do have to react maybe he has a
confidence it didn't need it and we'll
just sacrifice the round running back
right now it's possible
[Laughter]
okay
down on this one right here and now the
iPhone currently coming this is just
such a great position right because you
know what the defensive options for your
opponent are to play the character do
you know what you can do to keep them
there however finding the way out you
see that fireball is just a method of
pushing the opponent forward and yeah
we're just straight up back to the
screen
okay yeah I couldn't convert off the
crush medium because the ex was already
gone
tonight
oh you cheeky person you yes very smart
great reaction that was just that was
just the best way to go about it
there's two stacks of magnets so
actually Buzz doing a massive amount of
damage by comparison to an iPhone right
now
so close to if he survives yeah he's
possible
[Applause]
oh no attack bait right there and that's
gonna finish it off diaphone for the
first time was antsy enough to try to
early throat yeah which I mean in this
game we were talking about it earlier
the third tech window has been heavily
increasing right so a lot of people
they're not even just packing up like
they're just waiting let me just react
to it yeah yeah
which you you actually can like yeah I
believe in you yeah it's realistic yeah
it's a realistic reaction here
and as we're gonna see it right here
yeah the moments
that made it yeah so I mean strong play
typhoon was very close to me getting
those comebacks right but continuously
fighting out and yeah that fireball
trading right there was so important
because that allowed for Bud to jump out
get the dive kick and then immediately
start to clash hit that super skybound
art and mark the life bar we're good
hmm
don't give it up for dial phone for
making it uh what do you take it is that
fourth place yeah so the iPhone is uh
should be walking away with fourth place
because we our next match will be
winners finals so that will be Bob
versus shubu that's gonna go back over
to three out of five but before we get
to that Mike Ross we are going to take a
quick break to you know recollect
ourselves and get ready for these
massive two matches that are getting
ready to happen so please do not go
anywhere steal yourselves it's gonna be
a good one
that's Sizzle that's the soundtrack of
the soundtrack of Chipotle oh yeah you
come in you're gonna be hearing that
Sizzle that's how you know we always
have fresh food
fresh is what you stand for that's
exactly
[Music]
oh no
super Rola
[Music]
thank you
registration for Capcom Pro Tour is now
open over 2 million dollars is on the
line for the season with the first place
prize of one million dollars to the
Capcom cup 10 champion
winners of the online and offline
Premiere events will also Auto qualify
for a spot at Capcom cup 10. open to all
players in good standing so check out
capcomprotour.com for scheduling and to
find a qualifying tournament in your
area
all right welcome back everybody we're
about to resume going into the losers
finals here for Grand blue Fantasy
Versus rising and we're going to have
shuabu versus
it has been a long time coming they've
made it this far they've been playing
all weekend and now they're here in the
final moments here possibly can go on to
one more mattress there only one of them
can do yes yes I mean there is one very
interesting statistic Mike that I want
to put out there for everybody at home
everybody in the menu is that these
players
went through a bracket of 256 people to
make it to this point that is right and
Not only was it 256 people but when
signups were available for the 256
prison backup and it was capped at that
it sold out in two days that's insane so
that is absolutely insane so yeah
nothing but hungry hungry of the
hungriest yes everybody's looking for
Grand blue Fantasy Versus Rising right
sure I know you all are ready for losers
finals right now we are back at three
out of five territory it is gonna be
shoe boots versus let me hear it
yes the signs are up you know no Gran
blues at a tournament when you just
start seeing them everywhere yeah that's
how you identify look for the signs of
the crowd I see it's like it's like it's
The Witcher statuses they're checking
the ground and they're like
Grand blue players were here
we need to investigate yeah
nice ah yes all right so these are going
to be our last few matches no more
breaks we are going towards it this is
it showing everything if you saved it
for Nationals this is National stop yeah
this is it
you only get one shot let's see what
happens no no I don't you don't want me
to do it don't do it no I didn't mean
that
yeah erase that out of your mind I think
that was copy oh man that was close
yeah
foreign
in real time how does Siegfried go up
against this lesser-plated character in
the previous game right like you know
not a ton of people have that Andre
experience right
I mean I would think the way especially
the way is rocking with uh Andre is that
you might be able to keep Secret at Bay
did right there was just
the hammer down right like because it
was the charge version and so we saw
earlier a big problem with people were
trying to dodge it too early and just
getting bodied for it raging strike
immediate breakdown no it doesn't want
to deal with any of that
right there yeah both jump ins are
absolutely insane yeah I mean it's been
it's been twice now right uh we've seen
a different matches that uh the jumpins
are affording quite a bit wow well
really trying to make sure but that
patience the stoicism
anymore
oh my goodness
that's always been a great button for
catching people trying to dodge people
love to dodge and then Henry just five
inches and wow so that actually would
have built uh skybound already in the
previous version of the game but due to
the meter change oh that no longer does
it because there were several ex moves
there right so you build less meter on
the X moves now
battle two engage
second round
um
like it's kind of ridiculous just not
getting antired
we're recognizing the space perfectly
exactly I mean yeah I mean that was an
unfortunate space and another drop as
well for sure wow definitely a tough
moment so I can understand the anxiety
but that's probably coursing through
Vegas
[Music]
stack so one hit honestly into
skybounder I wonder if that could kill
okay well it definitely kills now yeah
but before the command grab
[Music]
like
that's how much extra damage would have
just been happening there
oh I think it's here yeah you were
talking about it
father you're right yeah okay
I love that love that massive swing yeah
yeah personally I'm forgetting that
these names because they're like okay
I'm not talking with different languages
[Music]
because like you know they did change
the life level so I just don't even know
what you are
there's that 5H right there
oh my gosh
[Applause]
yeah I do love that they gave him the
combo option into Magnus so it's not
just like oh I have to leave right now
you can actually just get your stack
with punish
[Applause]
oh there we go
use them I can't wait for A1 of the
rising verses that's right Rising my
cross is just gonna win a tournament
sliding all around them
no Tech this time
that's fun it's going up around here in
the second game
[Music]
so overall too with this with this uh
version of the game right now you think
with the answer to throws is you just
gotta wait yeah I
I uh they made the changes to throws to
allow them to have late Tech uh
so extra damage now on the hits I mean
the character already does pretty good
damage yeah
ultimate TP dude huge
absolutely dynamic
he's got a big sword yeah yeah he does
not afraid to use it either
oh
yeah
100 meter that's easily gonna kill no
question and uh I didn't see the
indicator so I think that may have been
easier input yeah which I think it's a
very smart decision for sure if that was
the case that's right because yeah you
can react a lot easier if you don't have
to do a full motion right two quarter
circles versus just interaction yeah
yeah surprisingly it doesn't do too much
damage
Dash up blow blocks
oh yeah
I mean it's just really awkward time you
have so much you have to look out for
you are gonna be ready for the jump
beautiful usage of the ultimate skill
right there you know I a lot of people
we were
just about how to use ultimate ultimate
there's two ones two ultimates
everybody knows
[Applause]
that's right
okay oh yeah
another Dodge
does not want to deal with those
situation right you know you're very
very close to chip being a factor do you
not want to deal with it
oh but no hold on
one second
she will be perfectly playing the time
on that one oh my goodness
but I can't handle it you don't see her
timeouts too often no actually it's very
surprising for like for the the patient
gameplay
I mean characters that allow for running
away for sure
but no that was just yeah there they
the hit
Oh No Escape could not attack that throw
if they wanted to because they're
already doing it
[Music]
I like the indicator because it interest
rate of tells you like you didn't detect
that bro
how disrespectful right
wow this is going in so this is one of
the few times that somebody's answered
it not meeting for the charge yeah right
yeah so because as a result of that you
know I mean that's coming causing a
mental stack up oh yeah
yeah yeah
it doesn't matter about the health grade
upgrade because the damage also got
upgraded yes
good balance
battle two engage I feel man this just
feels like one of those matches that I'm
probably gonna go down to it you know
what I mean play this is down to the
wire it's real slow it's real
intentional on just about every replay
that's right okay
that's right
either he's probably falling asleep
the block on the ultimate skill no
punish though tried to go yeah I you
know we don't know what the frame bit on
on the ultimates goes down right because
we didn't you have that access to your
beta we know that it'll be in the final
product but um we don't know the exact
punishment you get so Schubert was
probably trying to get them both damage
awesome
protect
okay here it is mix up time
yeah I think she was starting to
recognize that uh the 22x is is a buzz
option for mix-up right Rebecca series
oh yeah
absolutely 100 that was clean that is
one of the fastest like advancing I
think it actually is the fastest game
and it goes really hard too so
I don't know character's got it all yeah
it's a strong character yeah
secrete just definitely came to uh not
to play around I should say serious
business
gonna have to put safe on the game to
counteractive
very good momentum right now for sure
yeah pretty much uh
just checking every dot checking all the
jump spot until that last one right but
uh I mean that afforded a lot of damage
oh yeah only had 48 meter before it
happened that's okay I couldn't do
anything about it with a reactor right
leave that 50.
[Music]
nice narrative yeah it's finally time
the time yeah
pray to it oh my God enlightenment
hey there
yeah unfortunately could not get the
full follow-up it had a loud that's a
punish
um oh too far for the counter to also
come back to you
is trying to present new options to be
able to deal with this stuff but I mean
it's just not in the right spots
oh wow
like oh
that's good get off of me in exchange
you know for not too much damage I had
to stop it from even happening by
hitting the 2m but for once and I can't
believe what I'm saying this but
somebody was out of range of the two
houses
yeah no follow-up though yeah
other things you got to keep in mind is
that when sigris jumping and also uh
alter his uh yeah
on that one
but it also hits a little bit behind him
and that's exactly what we saw right
there
a true anti-air yes
you know the trade-off is obviously it's
a little slow on top okay sure makes
sense fair enough
not gonna say I'm not gonna not gonna
say it's very slow though right because
honestly I think it's in line with some
of the better like antiers of speed
anyway
so there you go
zoning here
but we'll crack first oh
yeah definitely but I I like the
decision right because there's so many
Fireballs that uh seeing they're like
okay finally I'm gonna be able to do
something about this
and now we're just stabbing at it taking
a crack over and over again at shuabu's
patience as he is on set point right now
I think smelling the blood in the water
and it's starting to act just like the
shark that they are as the skybound art
goes through the block string it was not
completely safe and eliminating shuabu
and now has the honor of making it the
grand finals
fun has got to be happy about his
performance right now Siegfried is on
point taking out shuabu advancing into
Grand finals versus Gamera this is it
this is it you are a hundred percent
correct it is going to be gamada versus
I know y'all are excited to see this
sick free grand finals completely new
character we already got it in that's
crazy that's actually crazy do you think
do you think you might be good uh you
know I will say the character probably
has some some strengths some strengths
for the character but we also got to
give credit to Pho oh 100 you're getting
into working right now Buzz doing all
the you know it's the master behind the
the puppet no no for sure for sure I
mean like we saw a lot with buh in
regards to just being able to play um
proper conditioning right you can
condition with any character in the game
right right it didn't have to be
Siegfried but like you know as long as
they're a fireball character right
because you know throw Fireballs wait
for the opponent to try to do an
anti-fireball strategy and ran up and he
just hit that far hitch and he's got a
rip a damage off yeah yeah no yeah you
got a five eight you got a fireball you
got it yeah
foreign
[Laughter]
so I'm not 100 sure if there's a button
check but yes we are in Grand finals
territory so for those of you who may
have beaten into this
um fighting game tournaments
and so as such camera has two chances
still right you have to lose twice and
then again so uh has the Herculean the
sisyphean task of having to defeat
Gamera twice right now in a three out of
five set
totally doable it's happened many times
yeah not specifically
not yet but you know
yeah like I mean like if you just go
back and look at the history of brand
blue Fantasy Versus like check out a
bunch of the Japanese tournaments
because Mario's is always there he may
not always win yeah but he is always
there right yeah
this is what he knows
this is all he knows
there's four there's four constants in
the world okay taxes Gamera being highly
placing and kalisto's Catalina being
nice that's right
just in case you didn't know
all right so here it is on the staple UL
Fargo also Staples Siegfried this is it
Grand finals Grand blue Fantasy Versus
Rising top six Evolution 2023 let's get
it
already with the fireball stuff like
that we were talking about earlier it
paid off so well for the previous set
but you know Camara I mean no stranger
to a fireball War right you may not be
able to play it with UL but has played
it plenty of time with other characters
too so like just being able to get
around oh you want to do a couple of
fireballs that's fine I'm back in there
yeah I can do it yeah I can deal with it
oh yeah that's okay of course is the
brave count yeah you know and I mean
that's fine because like gamera's like
okay he was like 50 meters yeah
a lot of resources used but you don't
want to deal with the alternative
you know we've seen so many people died
at something to dodge that at this point
that I'm just surprised
okay yeah so that's like a spacing trap
right normally you're a negative
therapist has no range right oh
that's weird
[Applause]
remaining calm you got plenty of more
work to do if you are trying to take
this step away from gamera's hands
yes and again okay so there it is again
a couple of fireballs trying to see how
Camaro responds like Fireball is never
the end-all feel it is always the thing
that makes the opponent want to react
yeah caught the jump out
yeah that's the condition yes the
shampoo already is that's right
okay yeah I caught on the frame strap
right there but because it was a frame
trap the flip out happened uh but
whatever Gamera press causes No Escape
there could not touch that door if they
even wanted to do right back nine snack
on Deck some more damage available for
butt and it's already got the life lead
yeah like I don't know it just feels
like this is great for fun a lot of the
respect you've got the conversion right
into the skybound art great damage on
this for sure and he also get the setups
right
[Applause]
the first game
winter bug first game with the book I'm
just saying he's throwing that one out
there I'm watching on another level
it is money that's five more to go yes
yes
again another Dodge from Gamera
you know
it was just he's just one of those
people who can truly react that's all I
can say
oh the Commando and that's another true
reaction right there not a neutral jump
on the command throw
okay
okay and the unlocked on the H follow-up
right there oh my God
[Applause]
to be able to get out wants to keep that
pressure going right how do you use 50
bar for it but I think it's fully worth
if it pushes away
patience
oh nice nice Fireball time another Dodge
on it
I mean if it's always going to be ex
it's it's a lot easier to deal with
right but if it's a medium version
yeah
Fireball yeah see we're switching it up
right now but I started to recognize the
Gamera it's just just spot dodging just
just willy-nilly yeah
[Music]
oh wow had the right idea but that's not
fast enough on that but
it comes out but yeah cancelable so keep
yourself nice and safe right
[Music]
they're the only reason you're still
alive oh oh there's damage
an exclamation point at the end of the
sentence
wow so that is a rare
um incorrect uh reaction right there
from Governor going into the Super
skybound art right there was you know
looking for one thing trying to
replenish it uh with that exact option
and no it was honest immediately
oh yeah the classic the absolute classic
take your turn back with the dragon
punch because everybody's like oh it's
minus I better press button yeah
completely ready
because I get the Dodge on that oh that
one actually I think was punishable I
think I think it was close enough uh I
think it looked like it
well I mean I guess we'll never know
yeah that's right
until it happens again okay I guess the
DP that's on we'll try to put the jumper
I think a camera maybe was looking for
intro but the uh Dive Tech maybe messing
that up
whatever the case may be now Governor
fighting out of the corner finding out
the racing strike got the Dodge I got
the punishing the skybound art but again
just on another level
counting down the games right now
camera didn't like that one camera has
to think about it
the world
I only saw the phone I tried to look
past the phone I was just so infatuated
yeah I can't stress enough but it's just
absolutely whoa even trying to stop the
command grab there but it was just a bit
too late or too early excuse me
he's waking up right now do you realize
what is that that steak
actually no I think that's that's what
it is he is you're right he's waking up
that's why it's worse he used to be
asleep
IRL Batman that's right
we have the dive kick getting blocked
right there in it yeah you know I don't
even know the frame
so I don't even knows right now that I
think about it that's a good point
you're learning the matchup as you go
which uh is not an easy feat whatsoever
yeah okay so that's a classic thing
right you air juggle into combo limit
and then you rage and train but the
thing is his boat was ready for them
because any one hit in the super
skybounder absolutely has the ability to
kill right now
okay I got it
finally is that the first round that is
Camaro's first round yes
oh the eyebrows
I think every match I've seen Gamera win
in in previous evos was eyebrows
that's the sun
if the eyebrows are down you know it
ain't happening right
yep the dp's are hitting
okay
five Eight's coming out yeah okay so
starting here's the medium instead of
the ex so it's creating a mix-up
opportunity now Gamera is not feeling
just free to spot Dodge the community in
that situation
you're not allowed to leave the corner I
would not allow this no no no you're
locked in
okay we take the turn back yep
I mean Camara had tried it previously
that if you want to take a turn back
right right yeah it has a capability to
do it hit
is on Deck
both yeah
I'm scared of the damage yeah it's
coming it's coming hope I just left it
got tired of being there but yeah I
think this is uh going to be enough
damage here there it is yep that's
skybound art uh damage increase coming
into play area has done something
throughout the entire tournament Camara
has put the first aid kit on has got the
gauze
that's right and uh now starting to play
gotta focus on the gamepl
[Music]
ate
I think people all around the world are
definitely gonna be like all right what
was bug doing once the game comes out
yeah
you don't want to give him that five
minutes right there because that was
definitely gonna lead to that
okay chip damage is a factor now
okay hold on wait a minute
wow
Dragon punch is the option right but the
problem is his Ultimate Dragon punch is
different it has that extra flash that's
horizontal none of the other Dragon
punches have
oh you have to account for so many more
things now
eyebrow got a little higher on Gamera
after that one yeah definitely back on
reset Point as well you have to remember
that well I've been fighting for this
pressure going the throw Tech at the
latest possible moment here steals the
turn back it's gonna be able to get out
of the corner has a result or you know
could get my diets I'm not sure but oh
that's low there it is
skill back nine stack applied
oh yes oh right there but the recovery
is insane
counter play like actually it looked
like the right idea I'm so confused what
is the counter play there well I mean 5H
is gonna connect on this one I should be
a kill as long as there's no combo
dropping yeah of course I said it
commentators cards that's right
the throw coming in trying to go for the
dash immediate Brave kind of route
yeah no I mean the brave kind of makes
sense right because we talked about this
a little bit earlier Rave counter will
do damage to the person taking it so
that's fine the chip range and that was
when Camaro was looking for I see I was
like okay so I can Brave counter now
I'll always take the internet but like
you're gonna get chipped out right but
whatever I think
choices yo the choice is yeah
I'm not sure
[Laughter]
adaptation pushing another Brave counter
oh this is okay so here it is
okay so now we got the stacks on stacks
of players right wow
nice oh what there it is but we have
reset the bracket
let's reset the bracket versus gamana oh
this had to have been the hardest spot
bat the battle it was like insane
Buzz reset the bracket I better thinking
about what he needs to do what kind of
adjustments need to be made to get this
Sigma
you got some tech yeah but I mean like
for real though I actually do not know
the counter play to its ultimate skill
uh backlash or DP I guess from from UL I
have no idea what the counter play
actually is because like you know uh
both went to the Dodge and then it just
covered it got countered
I guess you got a hit before the jump
happens right
foreign
okay so it does the ground bounce on the
air that was that was one thing I was
curious about is if your grandpa's in
the air because that means you get a
full combo yeah you would get a lot of
damage off that which that might be the
best Ultimate right
okay that makes up opportunity oh the
messy guess who's figured out like I'm
gonna
watch
oh
I don't think I don't think he was an
intended he just kind of walked right
into that uh very very surprising how
sweeps in this game are universally
pretty pretty high recovery right I mean
that's just kind of how it is for a lot
of games yep uh no strings with that but
you can cancel sweeps so you're gonna
sweet Fireball sweet you know what have
you right and uh not doing so I guess
maybe trying to use the threat of
canceling I see as a way to steal
okay
I remember it was to the point where I
was trying to find like dance links or
whatever afterwards uh because I was
like well what if we cancel and you like
get to it
unfortunately that's nice here
twice in a row we'll try to do something
right yeah
yep and and that's the perfect time to
break camera right because you just put
your opponent in the corner with a hard
knock down yeah
but I mean 25 minutes and commodore does
not have 50. like if if this changes
into offense from uh that could be a
raging strike oh but instead of the
background not gonna be able to kill but
now you have the situation and yes see
we talked about this at the very
beginning Mike yeah you can't you can
try but it's difficult to try to dodge
it yes it just moves so slowly it it can
catch stuff like that and uh even in the
analyst it tells you like don't try to
cross over it straight up the command
list tells you like this is a move that
can't be Crossing oh my God so they
tried to tell you so you so but it
doesn't say it's a move that can't be
taught
[Music]
great
okay so I can punch out of the Fox Lane
that's been a pretty Universal answer
since this character came out right you
out here um because you don't want to
deal with the the frames that it gives
but it only gives plus frames because
there's a gap in between whatever you
did before and the flames
I don't know
okay okay
so I'm gonna jumping right there
preemptively expecting commands that
tells me earlier when gamada jumped in
that that was just kind of a free and
fancy it wasn't actually the action
[Music]
s
so hard to uh to know when he's in stock
well you want to stop him right because
you don't want to let somebody get away
with something like that but it's just
like not a dog
oh yeah of course the brave counter
another move back down to 50 meter
however this puts uh bruh back in the
other corner you know you're trying to
fight your way out of one of them yeah
anymore
[Music]
first time he's taking the lead in this
set
this is going to be as slow as possible
yeah because neither of them want to
make a mistake right Gamora especially
wanting to make no mistakes because the
damage
but what's snowballing can happen yep
you know
you no longer can give anything to
anyone
now trying to fight other corner and I
like that so camera has has it uh he's
just like I'm not gonna try to beat the
amusement right uh no longer trying to
go for the anterior instead we're just
gonna backlash try to get my close
friends okay stop it with Dash attack
[Music]
should be oh no
I mean there there is the uh the
weakness right to the to the far H
because rhs
yep so copper has identified the net
that is not a true blockship
uh taking advantage of that
yeah well I mean costing 50 meter I
don't know if you uh want to use that
every time
I don't know maybe I'm wrong
oh it's happening again yeah
camera showing why he's the greatest
player yeah so I mean I got to be real I
guess you know I I know I'm definitely
not as good uh but one of the other
particular things that uh that shows is
that raging strike
um when your back is to the corner and
the opponent has shown to be able to
react with him yeah it's very very
detrimental uh for once right like
because normally oh you have a resource
Advantage if you do that but the problem
is you are now at their Mercy because
they get a true setup on you yeah
to the table
normally it's like oh yeah it's like
yeah
I wanted to punish it but it was
actually just
so we got somebody that's reacting
there's a reactionary player yeah oh
who's expecting Dragon punch I think win
for it again but yeah
because it didn't happen either
that is the time to do it so shutting me
up real fast
I didn't do it again okay
jumps over the medium gotta deal with it
yeah I mean okay so Buzz is now taking
advantage of the fact that Canada is a
little bit afraid of the delay record
string yeah right and starting to use it
to take turn back and even to start like
we have punishing things but still in
this absolutely it may be slow it may be
a crawl but a victory is a victory
that's right
to try and make things happen right
right
people
[Music]
unpunishable
it definitely not all because again a
more time at dodging got the No Escape
throw on this one okay good situation
yeah and cover is still staying Star
Wars right now got the air hit full
conversion easy
definitely gonna hurt so that's one of
the few times that uh secret can
actually combo in h because of the hype
[Music]
it's right back at you
can you get the punch okay
[Music]
we'll crack on that punish uh recently
so oh and another time
I can understand the attempts right
because like it seems it seems like uh
oh oh camera doesn't understand yeah
yeah see that's what the score is two
yeah yeah it's uh two to one
chicken
should the stage manager that's right
but uh yeah yeah so so I can totally
understand TP right there
because
the the Raging change
the only I mean took away a a bravery
point but nothing else lost really
there's so many different blockets
these players are really not trying to
give anything if they can nope you're
going way too far wow I feel like uh uh
just just buffers that every time they
press the button right every time they
press uh far medium they're just like
I'm gonna shoot
getting the counter hit on that one
actually I don't think I think whatever
the case may be climb out in the sky
right
oh oh wow trying to
trying to punish the
dash low and got punished
yep take the turn back oh no excuse me
just go straight punished right there so
gamara did the uh the other vision
trying to jump out I think I'm not sure
but yeah that fireball is enforcing the
will
um
unfortunately that sequence was
ridiculous I think it was because uh but
did not have the cooldown uh because I
looked back up at it and it looked like
it was gone
okay EX on this one though it's gonna be
able to push out of the corner as a
result of this there's all raging strike
gets jumped away from there's the Dodge
No Escape on the third attack but hey I
think Buzz okay with that because that
gets out of the corner
back nyans back on the damage
possibilities I'm Not Really Gonna
matter but the chip damage is gonna
happen right
another one
I mean that's just chip damage
technology
[Applause]
a game
packing back into it but lock it in
right now
[Music]
I'm loving every second
well you know again like you probably
were mentioning it's
everybody's learning and watching Secret
at the same time right now so this is a
lot to digest yeah I mean even like even
uh well I have to figure out like what
do you do about ultimate skill TV right
like even though like the secret is the
new hotness right now yeah um there is
still other new islands okay so how do
you figure it out okay just DPS again so
that was the answer last time because
that was a read on comment or trying to
do stuff
but there's is there a true answer is
there something to stop it before it
happens
[Applause]
yeah you know I think Bo might be okay
with that because the corner is now no
longer his issue or their issue
oh
okay so sleep again but all fart medium
yeah since the Donna time that button oh
my gosh
[Music]
cabera is now sitting on Match Point
right here that's not a match point Mike
Wallace I believe that's the term
forgive me forgive me
well oh yeah if I go for that command
grab
I mean okay so this is we're logging in
gamera's doing the thing that I like to
attribute a lot to Tiger where it's like
uh they recognize that like this is your
final chance so I'm turning it up to 11.
my husband is never going to stop now
but I was gonna have to fight the way
out continues to push back forward and I
mean the the stonewitness of the defense
has been noted for for about many a time
you can never really count one out oh
they're DP oh God the counter hit again
oh wow I like that walk back fight them
uh has a bit more and more of a problem
as time goes on yeah so that was the
time where uh sweep was actually so
close that I think you couldn't even get
fireball at fast enough
[Applause]
Fantasy Versus
icing Evo champion
congratulations he does it again
add to the collection of snakes
your soul is fine
two
of all kept continues to rise again he's
looking at all of you who's next
[Applause]
or hello
yeah no I mean like honestly that
definitely did not seem like it was easy
for Gamera in anyway I'm just like kind
of kind of looks like America's like
they're sighing with relief at this
point right yeah well definitely uh push
Camaro to the edge right there I guess
oh my goodness yo that is
himself right there the creative
director of family fantasy all things
awarding the trophy through the champion
incredible
[Applause]
on the fences
as we try to finish the tournament as
quickly as possible yes yes well Frank I
I do gotta say that is has been the
tournament what a great event it has
been so I got to thank everybody at home
and especially all the people in the
crowd you made this a wonderful time
make sure to cheer for yourselves as
well as everybody else thank you so much
for enjoying Grand blue Fantasy Versus
now Rising is not yet out and it will be
soon though so keep it locked on
official side games channels to figure
out when that will be because I know you
definitely want to see more of what you
just saw that's right yeah thank you
guys so much uh everybody for watching I
hope you all learned something a little
bit about Siegfried and a little bit
about the the dash low because I'm
telling you that's going to be the game
changer I promise you that uh thank you
again ebonic plague so much you know
thank you veram thank you Maverick thank
you everybody uh for being part of this
and of course thank you guys for
watching and we will see you in some
Grand blue Fantasy Versus Rising uh
maybe later this year yeah
I'm not gonna say no dates I don't want
to get in trouble maybe maybe guys thank
you so much and we will catch you at
another date
[Music]
believe you could be so much more made
for the moment in the era I forged live
from the minutes where the Legends are
born and the myths are forever when they
pen our Lord
I hear clear I feel all the hopes inside
of the same fear Shadows
[Music]
is everything y'all have prove yourself
worthy I live in the impact
[Music]
my spirit
ignite the fire of a brand new age when
I hear my voice
[Music]
you can't believe
got extra fighter coins from Street
Fighter 6. order any entree in the
Chipotle app using promo code
hdkn236 and receive 250 fighter coins
with your order visit chipotle.com sf6
for details
Red Bull gives you wings
[Music]
done
oh no
super Rolo
Victory feels good
PlayStation
[Music]
scope because I've arrived when it's the
only option second is
defensive practical this is the
beginning imagine your boy your level
two my brothers
on the floor my style is revered like
art on the wall if they ain't in the
know better keep them before evolutions
can't final form
[Music]
My Voice keeps on my soul keeps Rising
as I sing
[Music]
brush it down
thank you
[Music]
foreign
tell us
[Music]
foreign
so much more made for the moment in the
era I forged live from the minutes where
the Legends are born in the myths are
forever when they pen our Lord I hear
every Echo inside of the world clear I
feel all the hopes inside of the same
fear
[Music]
s
99 seconds is everything y'all have
prove yourself worthy I live in the
impact as soon as I push forward and
tell them to hold
I'm basically different I'm everything
everything
[Music]
of love till I'm more than what they ask
of me till I fly in ways you can't
believe through
[Music]
in a dream
beat down this is the rebound awesome
scope because I've arrived when it's the
only option second is
incredible
too
I know it for sure
on the floor my style is revered like
art on the wall if they ain't in the
know better keep them informed
Evolution's constant and this ain't my
final form
till I'm more than what they ask of me
till I fly in ways you can't believe
[Music]
brush it down
next I'll be strong
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Horizon in a dream
foreign
[Music]
inside of the same fear
s
99 seconds is everything y'all
and as soon as I push forward and tell
them to hold that roll back I don't see
any limit they lacking the vision and
asking why the hell are we friends get
them basically different I'm everything
they say that is
all the pressure gets too strong feel
like I was born here for something to
prove wrong what was that moment when
you felt that sound I heard the crap
Crown screaming one more round let
the light flash over the main stage I'm
still Brave battling the Giants are
still made the real face that's that
choice ignite the fire of a brand new
foreign
[Music]
I can't hold myself
this is the beginning
and this ain't my final form
till I'm more than what they ask of me
till I fly in ways you can't believe
[Music]
run this back
brush it down
[Music]
thank you
here we go
[Music]
come on
foreign
[Music]
as soon as I push forward and tell them
to hold that roll back I don't see any
limit they're lacking the vision and
asking why the hell I would risk it I'm
basically
ignite the fire of a brand new age when
I hear my voice
[Music]
you can't believe
music
foreign
against us at least
for sure number one content
door her jaw in the wall now jars
on the pleasant beard like art on the
wall if they didn't know if I'm informed
Evolution's constant and this ain't my
final form
[Music]
blue Horizons
I'll be strong
[Music]
I'm fine
here we go
[Music]
in a dream
thank you
[Music]
believe you could be so much more made
for the moment in the era I forged live
from the minutes where the Legends all
born in the myths are forever when
they've been our Lord I hear every Echo
inside of the world clear I feel all the
hopes inside of the same fear shadows in
the same years when they tell us that
it's gone
I have a brand new age when they hear my
voice
[Music]
My Voice keeps on my soul keeps Rising
as I sing my song
[Music]
go because because I rocked when it's
the only option second is
the big boy you're level two my brothers
revered like art on the wall if they
ain't in the know better keep them
informed Evolution's constant and this
ain't my final form
till I'm more than what they ask of me
till I fly in ways you can't believe
[Music]
on this back
brush it down
next I'll be strong prove myself
[Music]
Frozen
thank you
[Music]
till
I fly
[Music]
believe you could be so much more made
for the moment in the era I forged live
from the minutes where the Legends are
born and the myths are forever when they
pen our Lord I hear
inside of the world
comes out of the same fear
[Music]
s
99 seconds is everything y'all
worthy of living
as soon as I push forward and tell them
to hold that roll back I
basically different I'm everything
foreign
[Music]
till I'm more than what they ask of me
till I fly in ways you can't believe
[Music]
My Voice keeps on my soul keeps Rising
as I sing my song
[Music]
because I've arrived when it's the only
option second is
defensive pregnancy
on the floor
has been veered like art on the wall if
they ain't in the know better keep up
keep them evolutions
[Music]
My Voice keeps on my soul keeps Rising
as I sing
[Music]
brush it down
relax
[Music]
foreign
tell us
[Music]
foreign
ignite the fire of a brand new age when
I hear my voice
till I'm more than what they ask of me
till I fly in ways you can't believe
[Music]
defensive
Direction
so coming against us is utterly special
I know it for sure
like art on the wall
From Evolution
till I'm more than what they ask of me
till I fly in ways you can't believe
[Music]
brush it down
next I'll be strong
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
till I fly
foreign
[Music]
all the hopes inside of the same fear
s
yourself worthy I live in the impact as
soon as I push forward and tell them to
hold that roll back I don't see any
limit they lacking the vision and asking
why the hell I would risk it I'm
basically different I'm everything they
say that I
like
don't tell me to move on as soon as all
the pressure gets too strong feel like I
was born here for something to prove
wrong when was that moment when you felt
that sound I heard the crap ground
screaming one more round Splash over the
main stage I'm still Brave battling the
Giants are still made the real thing
that's that choice ignite the fire I
have a brand new age when I hear my
voice
till I'm more than what they ask of me
till I fly in ways you can't believe
[Music]
against us
sure
the floor has been feared like art on
the wall if they ain't gonna know if I'm
informed
I'm at the final form
till I'm more than what they ask of me
till I fly in ways you can't believe
[Music]
brush it down
next I'll be strong prove myself
[Music]
thank you
here we go
[Music]
Horizon in a dream
foreign
[Music]
I have a brand new age when they hear my
voice
[Music]
till I fly in ways you can't believe
My
Voice keeps on
songs
[Music]
I'm still here
Corners down
[Music]
here we go
foreign
they say
tooth was born here for something to
prove wrong what was that moment
screaming one more round
so brave battle
under the will face
the five boys
[Music]
Brothers
second
is
10 just so coming against us
on the wall
[Music]
s
as I sing my song
[Music]
oh
run this back
brush it down
next I'll be strong prove myself
[Music]
thank you
till
I fly
[Music]
foreign
My Voice keeps on my soul keeps Rising
as I sing my songs
[Music]
no you got to do better you got to do
better you gotta do better
Evo we gotta do better
all right are we ready
for some Dragon Ball fighter Z top sex
all right before we get started to the
intro video we all know that this is a
franchise that probably touched all of
us growing up that is still doing it
right now today in the form of a
fighting game so let's get this video
for Dragon Ball fighter Z let's kick it
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you swallow
no
you ain't always
[Music]
all right are we ready to get these
players how to start this top six or
what let's go
all right bring this energy again for
the entire top six let me get garlic
bread on this stage
oh
all right Nitro where are you Nitro we
need you up here
Flex on him
all right our next top six contestant
Hikari
[Music]
all right let's go make some more noise
for Kai
all right keep it up keep it up
our last top six competitor one more
time for Yasha
before we start one more time everybody
noise for this top six noise for this
top six
all right I'm gonna get up to our
commentators Tyrant and Damascus take it
away more thank you
what's up everyone evil are we ready for
Dragon Ball Fighters toxic
yeah I like that turret how are we
feeling but that's what we like to hear
let me tell you every one of these
players that made the tops here top six
here four for it so hard I watch those
matches man these guys are fighting
tooth and nail and you love to see it
you love to see it man some of the very
best in the world and we are guaranteed
a new Champion today as all of the
previous Evo Champs are not in the
bracket today we Crown a new champion on
evil with an entirely American
immunoside an entirely European loses
sight movies
yeah of course there was a lot of talk
going into this tournament who's gonna
win who's gonna win nobody knew and some
of the main
top six but boy do they deserve it with
the part of some of these players have
taken and you'd like to see some of the
players that have been right in Dragon
Ball Fighters non-stop are here to
represent the game absolutely it's been
a long ride the patches for the reason
the meta has been completely changed
recently and we've seen such a huge
character variety throughout all of the
bracket from yesterday to today let's go
guys
of course the crowd is that I'm counting
on you guys to carry that entire top six
please
look at the Mandalay Bay Convention
Center everybody pulling up to watch
some Dragon Ball Fighters you love to
see and the energy in the room is always
so electric it is and let's talk about
our first nice good winner semi-final
tarant garlic bread versus Nitro garlic
bread hanging from the west side it's
West Coast versus east coast today
garlic bread who has been the recent
sensation of Dragon Ball Fighters
constantly doing better and better and
look at this
you got it on stage there we go and who
could forget Nitros historic run last
year taking the second place finish of
course at Evo 2022 garlic bread one of
the players that has really been on the
Forefront of everybody's mind in this
meta this meta a lot of people are
saying was designed for him the
characters that he's been playing for
this long are finally
finally blessed and able to be at the
top tier of Dragon Ball fight as you can
see it's going to be uh I mean these are
some troll teams this is a button check
right here no don't don't lie to me I'm
just checking them I am done getting
high buttons
I am done I'm waiting for the game for
real for real but of course the biggest
version of a guided bread Nitro he's the
one man he's been you're grinding
finding team has been playing with so
many different teams recently he settled
to the team that got hit all the way to
today's top six last year as you said we
remember that absolutely ridiculous
finals he fell shortly so short of
getting an evil title it is the big run
back this year as he wants his title can
he reach
[Music]
let's find out Nitro of course has
switched this team recently uh switched
over to Gotenks as a lot of the players
Uh current Australian game have done
goten's one of the strongest characters
in the game bro I thought that character
was super strong even beforehand so that
bug kinda held him back slightly they've
removed that bug and added a whole host
of extra Buffs for him yeah so that
character kind of eating good right now
and of course uh backing up with the
Android 18 and the adult Gohan two
characters as well considered uh to be
in the top tier of this game at the
moment excellent character an excellent
team right he's one of these teams I
feel like that's what made up right now
is like having the team there's no more
already like anchor place right now you
need a team one everyone can actually
end up that's kind of this team any of
these three characters as an anchor
position does well it's fine there is no
team specific order to finish the game
no that's right that's right that's
right and I feel like you know some of
the top tier characters from the
previous match let's say you know the
blue Fusions for example and labco
especially you can still play them in
this game we've seen it bro look at
Hikari yep my man making topics here
yeah sure in top six as well still
playing double fusions those characters
can still cook yeah you just have to
think about playing them a little
differently and perhaps go for you know
those three tough situations rather than
rather than two times yeah it's not the
end of the world you're still
ridiculously neutral because a lot of
things you just have less damage you
need that one more touch but the
characters are so good in terms of usual
that you get that touch but we'll see
these ones a bit later of course the
players are getting ready for the first
set of these top six I'm absolutely
stacked up seats from players who have
been grinding for so long a lot of names
that we were expecting to see of course
in that window stop and of course in
curry bread is one of those that we
really cannot stop talking about but
ever since he started playing you know
he was doing wine on the world tour he
was too young to qualify yeah that was
so that was a heartbreaker honestly like
like he technically qualified but I was
unable to uh to make it out there at the
end due to a a uh you know like a little
catch so it's a bit of a shame but he
has a chance to redeem that an excellent
chance in Winning Side here but he's got
the East Coast monster Nitro in his path
so garlic bread is gonna be a tough one
and I can't call that match honestly
that's going to be hard it's really hard
it's hard to say and I feel like it was
really hard to call top six anyway
because so many different names right
like K was in top three last year he
didn't make it to top six this year Wade
no way
absolute favorites as well no Shanks no
Shanks so many big players were entering
this bracket it all boils down to six
from 874 entrance yesterday all the way
to six and only one can be crowned the
champion who's your champion
super tough one
um I'll go one of the young goats man
for me it's got to be Eva
garlic bread or breakfast I got a chair
for The Underdogs I actually would be
happy about that but growth is just
having the new generation getting the
wings it would be fitting but you know
somebody's players in here are just
looking so so strong it's hard to say
for sure who's gonna take it everybody
deserves to be here and I'm so happy
that uh these players have qualified for
this spot yeah it's one of the first
standards I watch your top eight and I'm
like your top six brother I'm like
everyone can win like anybody all of
these names and I don't see one that's
that has a clearer chance than I know
any other one yeah they've always been
so good like for the entire weekend for
the entire last few months as well it's
been so good to watch these players all
the way to Evolution 20 23 not a few
matches left for garlic bread or Nitro
to take the win if they want to get
straight to Grand finals on the winner
side and of course all you know first to
two formats and of course a reminder for
you guys watching this kicks off the new
Dragon Ball world through 2023 2024 the
winner of evil is qualified to Dragon
World Tour finals we've got seven direct
qualifiers with seven Dragon Ball that's
right that's the best trophy to get man
bro this is one you can keep forever and
you can you know you can put that in the
cabinet and be like that is one of a
kind yeah you know you earn that and uh
yes this is the only Power Plus event on
the world tour so very important if you
want to qualify for that finals uh that
is kicking off here at Evo of course
we've got a bunch of other stops on the
world tour as well yeah
um but Evo bro that's just something
that's a big fight feeling the air there
is something about you can't beat it
yeah but walking around and just seeing
like whatever is the station with many
people behind and just like try to scoot
in and you know yeah thankfully I'm kind
of tall so I get to see the games but
it's kind of hard you know sometimes
have such big amount of people there you
know to try and like people to watch I
was watching earlier that was the Kane
versus k-cycle I was such a close game
managed to clutch somehow but not such a
close one everyone was behind trying to
cheer you know for their favorite and
that's what we like we're always trying
to cheer for our friends for our
favorites it's been a very loud evil so
far so many stages right seven stages
yeah and all of them have been
absolutely ridiculous like yeah we've
still got some games going on here we
still got some tech going on we've got
the Marvel's actually going crazy
of course all of them and are absolutely
popping but here on the main stage is
all about Dragon Ball Fighters top six
thank you of course everyone for joining
us in the crowd and in the chat as we
are getting ready to launch the very
first match of this top six between 9
Nitro and garlic bread the other side of
the Luna's bracket will have Hikari
versus kite and I'm really happy to see
that this top six is really rewarding
the players who have been consistently
grinding the game because there is an
elephant in the room that needs to be
addressed right a lot of the players
have been playing sf6 lately it's really
hard to be good at two games at the same
time it kind of takes away from your
focused time on Dragon Ball some of
those have grinded consistently the game
and they're all here in top six yeah and
we're seeing that I mean a perfect
example of that might be fenrich not
here in the in the top six you know like
of course I I have a commitments SFL
going on right now as well so it's hard
to focus on on this many games at that
higher level yeah but yeah like you said
the ones that are really grinded out
really focused on that game like I see
gropers playing this game every single
day that's why he's streaming this game
every single day that's why he's there
yes exactly that's why he made it all
the way there man he's been a super good
road for him as well and it's so good to
see him as well you know the first time
that he goes to America his first evil
uh you know he's not a person who has
been traveled that much you know he's
still kind of dealing sometimes with
tournament nerves so I'm glad to see
that he beat his tournament nerves
throughout the tournament to go all the
way I mean he's an evil champ but he's
an EVO online champ so he you know he
transitions yeah he wants to try and get
that offline trophy as well and uh but
it's gonna be tough it's like we say
it's not gonna be easy any one of these
six guys could be there at the finals
it's so hard to call right now who's
going to take it and yeah man I can't
wait to get on with that first game here
absolutely we are just working out a
couple little issues guys that's why
this yeah we are hesitating right now
but don't worry we'll get in that first
game up for you guys in just a moment
yeah absolutely I'm really happy to also
the character variety you know that you
know top six as a you know Dragon Ball
Fighters has been victim of a couple of
metals that were very prevalent in a
couple characters
snap fusions
sorry guys I just had a cough really
quick I had to just go through it but we
have Snapchat
it was trash don't even talk to me about
it that was the worst two characters not
playable yeah
oh my God that's me that's one but at
least you know now we get so many
different teams right you know lighter
is on the uh adult 18 train garlic bread
because a little superbic Krillin you
know Krillin in top six
ridiculous he's low-key Heidi like
everyone has been forgetting about cream
for so long and I feel like the only
reason why is because there wasn't
enough people who were world-class to
show him to showcase exactly yes right
he's like sometimes have this like have
a character who's so good but there is
not a single person who is like
world-class at the game to Showcase how
good the character is yeah and that
person is here now it's garlic bread
showing why you know Queen's good one of
the best assistant game and that's the
Bronx bro the Rocks the Rocks there we
go the assist does it all man but then
you can see garlic bread he plays that
team specifically uh to make your your
day a living hell honestly like the baby
again you Krillin team is so scary he
really body swap anytime he would listen
he would body Swap and he will have the
optimals with your character if bro CEO
top eight there was like three or four
body swaps I swear like it was it was
wild yeah
yeah it's kind of crazy he did this one
earlier in Brackets he body swap to
zamasu then immediately
he's been having so much fun with all of
the ginu offers Gino has been uh it's
he's always been like decent but very
technical and now he's strong he's crazy
it's really hard to deal with ginu now
and it's the kind of character that if
you're not ready he can catch you off
guard so easily and I want to see you
know how this ginu can do and of course
you know the super baby on the side as
well I choose with a baby it's him and
rupees in this top six and yeah I mean I
know you like that character he's he's
so cool super baby for me he's one of
the best designed fighting game
characters of all time right he is just
too sick incredible and we're going to
see some optimal plays up on this on on
this uh top six for sure like you said
with garlic bread and grope is both
optimizing the hell out of that
character yeah so that's gonna be
beautiful but we've also got some of the
old with the new comes the old we're
gonna have double fusions two players
rocking that team you know you've got uh
Hikari of course double fusion and Yasha
and yeah they've been you know sticking
with that they build a bit less meter
but you know they're in top six so at
the end of the day for me yeah the the
characters are still the same they still
have the same options yeah you know they
still have the same crazy damage output
they just build a little less you know a
little less juice so you can still you
can still do well with them you just
have to play them have a different
mindset around playing those characters
but they can still do work and you've
still got the battery Android 17 there
as well to build that bar if you need to
so yeah yeah exactly like that's that's
pretty much the role of the character
now you know come to build the bar and
then give and then like give away to uh
the players with a bit of a better
neutral yes you know plays now and of
course in the last you know in this
topic talk about I mean on the winner
side uh is kite
is easily the most improved player over
these last two years I've said it
multiple times every time I watch he
plays better than before every time I
watch kite anything wrong that he's done
in the previous tournament is completely
wiped out of his gameplay and he's
coming back with a new plan yeah with a
new and everything and I was really
happy for him like really seeing him
especially the fact that he beat fanwich
today because he's mentioned multiple
times that was huge he meets fenwich in
multiple tournaments and he's always
that close his Heroes does well doesn't
get it today he got finished down he
took down the world champion himself wow
qualify to that top six it's so deserved
and the way he plays has been so solid
he's shown today the the level of
defense that he can show it's absolutely
insane he's been really good at
switching it up you know like you said
between the defensive offensive style
and when you saw him qualify I believe
he defeated KJ pixel to make that top
six like seeing his reaction shows how
much he meant to cut so kite you earned
it man Make It Count you played out of
your mind well deserved man much love to
connection it's always good to see him
run he you know he's not stopped he
doesn't stop the grinder look at the
reward he gets you know playing on the
biggest of stages in the winner side
then of course on the side on one side
we have yashai to mention him right
double fusions you know coming all the
way from France he has always been one
of the favorites he's still looking for
his absolutely massive major title right
like he won a couple Majors he hasn't
won a Super major like evil a huge upset
for him at the World Finals not able to
achieve the goal that he wanted he
worked so hard all year round last
season to qualify for that World Finals
and you know in his heart of hearts that
was his but it was taken away from him
of course he unfortunately did not make
it to the the top eight stage uh of the
of the World Finals and you know this
could this could be his chance to
correct that mistake yeah it is
competition of course last but not least
the kid from Spain you know came all the
way from Spain is his first evil a kid
from Spain I love rugby of course we
know that the Spanish girl is going to
be there I've seen Sharon I've seen him
go crazy the Spanish crowd are the best
you know absolutely they're gonna be
there
the group is know what to say group is
like one of the you know nicest person
you know bro like he's the nicest kid
ever super super cool playing the game
has been grinding has always been
playing the like wacky but low to your
character I still remember meeting
groupies in season two and his team was
uh zamasu Frieza and jiren back when
these characters were terrible
but he was still like better in people
still smoking people with that team yeah
and eventually arches blessed him with
Buffs and now he plays a team that he's
always liked right super baby Frieza and
beerus but now the team's actually you
can make it count now exactly that's uh
that's that's place for him so uh he's
been doing really well in multiple
tournaments he qualified through the
PlayStation road to evil tournaments you
know there so he won his trip online and
look at all the path that he went
through to go all the way they're
beating in them to qualify to this top
six bro to come out here your first uh
International first uh
American event best U.S event and to
make any U.S event right Evo bro this is
incredible yeah this is the biggest
thing that you could get as a player
guys it's absolutely uh ridiculously
like how good these players are and
we've been really enjoying that's pretty
much the first Super major on the new
Patcher we haven't had that many
tournaments on the latest patch you know
we had CEO personal challenge yeah
that's about it no had couple like
tournaments but we still like adapting
The Meta we're still learning a lot
about the characters I'm really I've
been learning a lot you know throughout
the weekend as well just watching the
characters watching the the how people
became Specialists of the the new
version of the characters watching jiren
who is now becoming parent Gotenks who
is now becoming parents characters that
you get to learn more as you watch them
and that's what I've been liking
watching for the entire weekend I do
think that we have filled the entire
Bingo this weekend the all of the cast
has been represented on stream roshi or
yes
yes everyone then all of the characters
have been represented on stream for
these two days there you go what more
can you ask for that is such a good sign
you know like it really is yeah that's
uh that's what I like to see you know
getting all the characters nobody is
unusable yeah nobody left behind while
you know a couple characters are a bit
left behind but uh they're still
playable that's out there you can still
uh have some fun even trunks somehow
even trunks even Bardock but Bardock is
the biggest fool From Grace we saw him
so often yeah in that first season at
level three is like burned into my
memory yes how many times you'd see that
level three per match
yeah that's uh that used to be a you
know the classic it's a it's only been
like this GT Goku in season two where
little uh run with UI Goku uh then you
know they're obviously with the lab
growth that's been terrorizing the
entire world for so long and I do feel
like Taran this is the first time that
we are in a meta in Dragon Ball where
there is no like one or two characters
who are clearly better than everyone
else right because season one everyone
had like maybe the same two characters
on the third one right season two same
thing you know that GT Goku was pretty
much like Kung Fu story you were
trolling for if you are not playing GT
Goku usually with Super Saiyan Goku with
another uh you know then season 300 the
UI Goku stretch last had the lab coat as
well
now I don't see a character who's like
compulsory in your team yeah you could
you could say like you know you could
you it's between like I don't know go
tanks like 18 jiren is up there as well
like these characters are all like you
know it's all debatable but yes the the
the the top top tier is very debatable
right now yeah but it's like this is
there is no one that's clearly
compulsory
back in season two right literally like
if you don't play GT Goku you're
trolling yeah you should know there is
this is the situation now where any uh
character you play you can make it work
you can create a team you can build a
team around the character and make it
work and that's what we like to see
seeing just the character variety that
is in in this top six you know Krillin
in top six evil winners characters are
crazy who would have thought like you
know a couple years ago yeah yeah
Australia that's right that's true like
he's been a character that everyone was
waiting to see and I know that you're
gonna have the high plays from uh garlic
bread that are against Nitro Nitro
recently picked by a flyquest yes shouts
to him man Nitro really earn that like
you know
my kid's been killing it for a number of
years so you'd love to see him uh get
what he deserves you know and that's a
good sponsorship on his belt yeah to
help him travel out to these events yeah
definitely it's a really good tour to
have this as fly quest of course they've
been uh joining the fgc in fourth later
you're sponsoring a ton of players
as well so we have a lot more presence
as well yes uh that's what I want to see
man like want to see more players
traveling around more players coming for
the events especially now as we start
the new world tour for Dragon Ball
Fighters absolutely 2024 is a fresh
start a fresh patch yeah let's go fresh
past Fresh Start we are all waiting to
see how this world tour will go because
fenrich was the previous Champion found
it right now as you said right he's now
focusing on the street fighter as he's
one of the members of the Street Fighter
league in Japan so like seeing his his
immediate commitments are Street Fighter
6 there is a chance that we see a new
world champion again you know this year
so there are a ton of objectives to
grind for for the players
yeah there's a lot of work towards
absolutely and uh it's like we said
earlier at the start of the show a lot
of these players here you know they're
the ones that have really been
consistently on the game really you know
developing their teams really pushing
the meta and uh seeing what they can
create it well with this uh sandbox game
like Dragon Ball Fighters right now is
really is so you can you can kind of
play it however you want like yeah
there's a lot to it yeah it's reached a
point where like you you can literally
make the game you want right like
another character you play you can still
make a strategy that works around the
character and that's kind of why we can
see right now you know this top six that
is still getting ready guys it's been a
nice podcast here on the main stage in
the Mandalay Bay Area for bearing with
us we're kind of nice we want games too
guys don't worry no no I'm good let's
talk one of them okay all right okay
what do you want to talk about tyrants
we had to talk
you know what I'm talking about we are
patient
we are patient my brother
I don't know if I'm patient but I'm
being patient my patience is Aaron tight
bro I am grn at this point I've been
sitting down meditating for God knows
how long so I'm gonna wait for a few
more minutes for game number one
Fighters players yeah it's that duty to
remain patient you know what I'm saying
but yeah yeah we're just under making
minutes right now yeah
can we show the stage please please show
us something to commentary production
let me commentate on an actual great
match actually playing rock paper
scissors between
Nitro and garlic bread deciding to go
for the true mix right now on the stage
first to ten that is a long rock paper
scissors that I can't see understand
production hey
oh my god there have been just going for
this let's see let's get the camera on
are you ready for rock paper scissors
commentary at the biggest stage in the
world
let's go are we doing this is it time to
stall in the best of ways give a sign to
talk about man
the crowd is loving it man let's go rock
paper scissors within the players the
fastest one they're going so far I can't
even see who's winning I can't even see
who's winning current they're just going
[Applause]
do you have the reads you don't have the
reads how many times in the row can
catch one as we win we wait for this
what's the first two done actually win
are we good nice of the goats I mean to
be fair trying to fight is is basically
fast-paced rock paper scissors so yeah
that is block the assist RBS there you
go enjoy have fun
it's always
memories
which team plays first yeah there's
always the key that comes like I'm good
at RPS I'm gonna win
[Music]
like
[Laughter]
the players are checking of course the
PS4 as we are waiting guys for the match
to start show us the crowd of course too
uh for being patients with us to wait
for our first session
it's been a wonderful experience as
always man it's like just coming back
there I mean absolutely everyone his
biggest eagle to date right like the
massive brackets that are around just
going around and meeting with one
special kind of feeling right it really
is man like public so many different
people here like like I said earlier Evo
big fight for you yeah you know electric
uh atmosphere
so cool everybody coming together here
you know 11 000 attendees here at
Evolution 2023 which is just insane it's
insane man that venue is absolutely
gigantic the amount of steps I clocked
in today I have no idea to check on my
phone so much but I've been working so
much from one station to another uh you
know that's the distance that there is
in this video that is absolutely
gigantic and the amount of games that
we've seen today and just like being
around like recognizing so many faces
around the thing like oh this guy
haven't seen you in a while especially
with this F6 that's bringing you a lot
of the sf4 revenues oh yeah yeah that's
true yeah well I haven't seen for years
as well it's been a lot of fun to just
catch up with everyone and have fun of
course we are closing Sunday in style
fighters in time ready I see the players
getting ready on the stage I'm waiting
for the green light
shroud are we waiting for that first set
of the crowd cannot wait anymore we are
out there waiting for our first sense of
these top six it's gonna be Nitro versus
garlic bread and the hands are shaken
turrets it is time for first set of the
day winners semi-finals
please let's go for the first set it is
time
yeah
yeah okay let's go guys
[Music]
I'm scared I might I might have
in kosaki I might have a good one
there's no way people have to check I
don't you know what I wouldn't I'm
scared I wouldn't put past these two I
have actually a couple of trolls I don't
want to get mixed live on stream I'm not
playing I'm not the one who gets mixed
today
players are getting ready
[Laughter]
on these intros are working right now
and are we having the game just yet it
looks like they're playing having the
game that's a swap to the game so we can
go for game number one off let's go
let's go let's go
checking we're good okay good to go we
are good to go
right
[Music]
that's what I see or beside the eye
that's it that's it
it is time garlic bread oh my goodness
and look at this in this short plan of
time good things already so the end of
his first game as darling red takes a
commanding lead to start the set okay
set up to a fantastic start
they're here
okay 18. this character probably can go
to level three oh yes never a bad time
for this level three
[Music]
[Applause]
what's up
yeah Dr
yeah oh he just waited the purple Comet
crash landing
combos
[Music]
[Applause]
okay here we go
for that level okay one
ah I spent all the discs into the
Revenge death ball but he took away some
blue life on baby but it was worth it
because Gohan and that level seven is
gone
all the pizzas and all of the money
invested in the Gohan is gone right now
and Nitro is down from 480.
garlic bread
to try and win yeah
The Challenge from garlic it goes by
that newly buffed crouching like so
strong
because it was technically a combo
barrier over time
oh no this is the 2mm bars
wow
[Music]
[Applause]
what an opening game there for garlic
bread look at this young man
be one game away for making it into the
Winner's finals of Evo 2023 here we go
game number two guys
[Music]
firing off there
baby such dominance of the screen
oh my goodness
yeah
[Music]
this is huge right now look at his shout
cancels we got those here we go quad
cancels you ready
that's dead right there
[Applause]
was fancy new roots
between
[Music]
him
oh he got it
Miracle punches
[Music]
super Dash let's go all right I've got
the roots knock down into the ghost okay
you thought this was gone
oh
he's way towards the perfect right now
just extending and kidding will give you
garlic bread he's down to Anchor feeling
nitroen branded news
what a clap back from Nitro look at this
he has not been touched just yet working
on a perfect
oh my goodness Krillin and this
character could play defensive so well
yes
the movement he gets
is amazing and goes straight to what
about three yeah maybe get the first
character without you this far
just again Miracle punches
over here
[Applause]
to do that man died
[Music]
[Applause]
himself
a knock down situation garlic breaking
out the guess correctly
oh 2s
Nitro takes the second game one one now
guys
Coast versus West Coast here
and winners top six
this was worse than garlic bread is
trying to eight teams
get composed again
Nitro has been there before he has he
knows he's just looking to do it again
there's something about this big stage
that really motivates Nitro you know
he's a very relaxed guy but like when it
comes to these big Mass situations he's
all business
okay here we go
we'll knock down brings it Captain you
know what's coming now
[Applause]
can you force good double overhead block
Berta another block back as well
[Applause]
Squad
character and that's going to be the
conversion for Nitro now
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
so hard to approach
oh that Gohan assist paying dividends
[Music]
three bars for the mix I like it I like
it the force earlier here with the
crossover attempts he might be trying to
cross up again let's see where do we
block where is the mix
the baby assist
[Applause]
ance
yeah man
landed and it's time for super baby you
can come in and you've seen earlier
right Nitro abusing the barrier
happy birthday that was that was that
was the assist
that was the happy birthday that was the
baby yeah yeah the parasite yeah
it's in the corner we go and that's
gonna be a great take by garlic bread
gonna try to go back to using the key
blast game all right acid rain out here
mix yeah oh my goodness that mix is so
dirty
so hard to see this mix
my Consumers Market let's see he does so
goes behind all the train
oh this is stubby two eight right there
T-Rex range
Krillin okay cash in the ROM VP out
okay backs off
the situation watch out because that's
the first time
[Music]
all right it's black the fight at home
[Laughter]
keeping up with the with whatever the
last name I don't know keeping up with
acrylins
man forgot to do the dishes
Housewives of West City let's go live
all right TV such evil
oh okay here we go oh reflects he's been
pretty good at this man he hasn't been
opened up after this let's go okay
oh to the corner Nitro
that's gonna be a huge one as of course
the disc is there to close the combo
Nitro sending garlic bread to his final
character looking to be in Windows final
all right evil once again
okay I'm just stepping to The Grand Tour
let's see
thank God make it happen with baby
damage as well
I don't think he can but level three and
listen garlic bread has blocked every
single level three mix now is the time
to block one more garlic bread block for
your life guest for the game
qualifies for winners final wow it's
hard to happen eventually Nitro has
consistently tried this level three and
there we go Nitro will be once again in
winners final of evil he was there last
year and he's back this year in a full
force only him and Yasha the
back-to-back top six there we go Nitro
celebrating of course the well deserved
win with wincy garlic bread a bit later
on the loser side Nitro in winners
garlic bread goes to losers wow you can
see the crab right there everybody
amassing to watch some Dragon Fighters
and Nitro yes he did make it to the
winners finals last year but
unfortunately fell short this is his
chance to correct the mistakes of last
year and he's got an excellent
opportunity to do so like you said
garlic of the day he's getting ready and
that is going to be an interesting one
man Hikari versus kite the East Coast
Representatives you've seen them playing
in so many tournaments if you follow the
scene of course it's an absolute classic
kites you know I've said it before I say
it again I think like most improved
player in like around like he
consistently goes tournaments does well
does better and better and better
recently broke the top eight barrier and
now he's there of the top six winner
side of Evo against Hikari very similar
to kite as well two players who have
been waiting for the time on the
spotlight for so long now is your time
yeah you can see for both of these
players
their reactions for qualifying to this
top six said it all yeah you could see
how much it meant to both of them two
players that really like you said are
really looking for that breakthrough
performance and here it is at Evolution
2023. I don't know man I can't call this
one
um these two like honestly I can't call
it between them and look at you guys out
there in the crowd let's go you having
fun watching some Dragon Ball
that's what we love to see man the
entire crowd gathered to watch something
who does dragon ball right here at the
Mandalay Bay we are ready for more games
we are ready to pop off we are ready to
cheer for our favorite players as this
crowd is absolutely ridiculous
all right
everybody feeling the energy in the room
right now
Dragon Ball Fighters your main event of
day two of Evo and let me tell you
there's something about Dragon Ball Hero
Evo is this always feels so special
absolutely love it
kites getting ready
to Curry getting ready are we going to
button check are we going straight to
the game to Curry
stick users all these stick users only
stop it uh uh yeah yeah
for us to stick users you know we boom a
squad Boomer Squad antique
I'm not hitbox for this game now but
yeah I can still pick up the sticks of
my stuff on YouTube
that's the one no button check current
we go straight Hikari versus kite and
you can see you mentioned it right he
carries on that double fusion and seven
whoa It's a team that doesn't mean much
meter but it's still extremely dominant
on neutral yeah excellent add to pick
things off with kite
dead Chase all the pick up here like you
said both these characters that these
gentlemen are playing on point not the
best batteries anymore and you can see
not a lot of here being built but the
next hit oh my goodness
lives
a couple changes but there we go kite so
foreign
gets his own picker yeah yeah of course
that meat again is back to normal during
the spark and you see how he switches to
Andrew 17 to go for those key last shots
killed so much Meetup with that Andrew
17 one of the best batteries
level three oh
always a great one to have to rely on
and for now trying to build more videos
oh the mixed plans
Carrie gets his own opinion heals the
ball got one assist to extend the combo
let's see here
down that should be I mean I think it's
enough
if you're one into level one and then
the follow-up with the details here we
go here it is yeah swap
he carry with the optimals getting kite
character down
and there we go Vegeta versus
risky as hell or attack
remember that we that was dark time that
was dark time sorry to remind you that
the crowd carrying an entire top eight
there we go
the movement right now is movement from
kaidas he's trying to get away
[Music]
be happy to defend for a while and
defend successfully as well
for now he's the corner he's just trying
to get away and he's forced to block him
he Gates Park alone to get hit by the
pressure on Android 17 and there we go
the low is going to be reflected he
carries defense is absolutely Immaculate
and the Vegito a is gonna catch his
opponent slipping he carry with the
Dragon Ball Fighter's masterclass yeah
let's see what super goes for him which
level three is it gonna be okay Android
17.
there we go fighting down the timer on
the spark
defending in the corner now
oh my goodness that was so hard to take
my word
and there we go 17 that should take care
of Andre 21 and his only lab coat left
right now kite had such a strong start
to that set but he carry video that's it
brought it back
on the back foot now oh
all right because it was a keep last
night it's not going to be the most
damage Curry might not be able to get
the kill I don't think so it's gonna be
scale of Hell unless not yet One Touch
One Touch
block around right now nice movement
bike height gets the key blasts
okay here we go
right I guess the grab into that level
three
should be giving himself a corner mix
here believe it does have a space for a
left right let's see what kite goes for
what's gonna be goes low
oh my man waited and delayed dragon
versus Hikari was way too ready for this
and Hikari is not taking wrist man I
really appreciate the patience approach
right now doesn't really have a reason
to take a risk he's just happy to just
wait lock and wait for kite to run out
of options absolutely no you can you can
run the clock right now if you have to
yeah you've got 90 seconds
take that
yeah he carries way to activate it right
now he's looking really good
more pressure free age record pressure
here sorry
once again putting on the pressure oh my
goodness
blocked all of that guys this man is
blocking for his life listen kite's
defense he's ridiculous as well look at
this the man's in the corners
oh
it is all up to Vegito after all of that
the patience is paying off Hikari now
needs the opening watch out
should not be too much in a hurry
because guys got time he got 78 58
seconds
at the wrong time
[Applause]
take that one for Hikari and hold it
down but that was almost oh my oh my God
that was a Heart Stopper right there at
the end
Hikari is showing man this guy's defense
is always Immaculate he will be happy to
wait and blocked for so long
Unfortunately they got caught at the end
but have you seen how close he was from
an absolutely legendary comeback talents
Mark what okay he was thinking about the
place of gear on coins
okay
switching out slightly here
all right switch
see Curry
he's just warming up
getting ready plays with music in his
ears
he's just getting ready
for game number two one game away from
joining Nitro
in that Windows final
all right let's see who is it gonna be
it's gonna be hikario kite
stop barrier what a start there for kite
no follow-up though
okay
the movement here
kite taking a more defensive approach
around start backing off slightly but
Hikari the pressure is on right here
all right now
oh you're trying to be patient homing
missile you can run but you can't hide
always water look at this the pressure
is Relentless before we carry right now
all right forced to spark look at this
this is huge
that's unfortunate a drop there
okay Hikari gets to Here There you go
[Music]
this character is still victory of
course he can this needs to go for
different routes now the main mix having
me nervous okay okay
oh we actually had to hit there
Gary showcasing you got a good defense
but so do I with the 5m
landing on that 21 kites in trouble
right now he needs to find some momentum
because he carries the mighty confidence
he's really in his own right now
based Vegeta right now for kaido his
chance just flies off the keys last
all the float mix into the Dr Great Tech
oh I just think here
okay
oh all right EX
actly
straight through yeah probably not ready
though to punish
magic 17 in this is gonna be a great
situation Curry just in the driver's
seat I feel like the whole time wow a
preemptive 2H
AB
try it again go back to that defensive
approach but Curry really turns up the
heat when he sees that yeah he is on boy
doesn't mind having Kate waiting he will
keep the pressure on anyway oh
look at the amount of time this you have
spent blocking right now they're still
looking to get a single opening on each
other but it's so much effort to open
your opponent you know much of this
level whoa there we go but the opening
amounts to no damage Terrace is going to
be more for pressure than anything else
yeah the key plus star is never going to
do a regular damage it just goes
expenses
number one the Geo again Dragon brush
okay let's see
once again
pressure off he after the delay making
him think maybe a Dr or something else
and then catches him with the ID
beautiful play from Hikari
yep
it's worth getting the extension and
that should be more than enough to get
that 21 down Hikari is looking
absolutely unchallenged in this game
number two kite absolutely struggling
and gets down to base Vegeta by himself
seven bars to try and make it work not
of Dragon Balls to potentially call
Shenron but at least good enough to go
for level three into a mix got to watch
out because these super rushes are kept
unchecked currents yeah he's been
getting away with that a lot quite finds
the hit though let's see here should be
able to get that kill throw him up into
level three that should be enough this
does get a big damage boost off the
throw just enough
okay kite I see you
okay try to bring it back he said he was
close to a very big comeback in game
number one might as well try it again
right now as he's trying to back dash
but gonna get caught by the Klee blasts
Hikari going back to it knocks down time
[Applause]
those Wreckers sliding knocked down
quite uptakes
oh my God
she's so close right here Curry smell
Victory there it is
gonna do it right there
yeah he's done
all right all right all right we get
this anyway he Curry saves it big smile
on his face as he Curry reaches winners
fighting off Evolution 2023 joining
Nitro right there
that is going to be Kites on the loser
side we have got a winners final set and
that's gonna be a hype one tarantee
carry versus Nitro 4 spot in Grand
finals winners wow two favorites from
the East Coast gonna throw down there
it's gonna be an absolute epic battle in
the winners finals that means we go and
decide so loses bracket we can see how
look at the offense right now the way
that he carries playing bro if you've
seen how he's been playing today yeah
like his match against Zayn earlier this
guy is just on it yeah he's been really
ready
the happy birthday I cannot believe he
got the air level three into Happy
Birthday that was so incredibly smart I
got to love the kind of play where the
defense prevails not what happened right
he defended for like almost a minute
straight and then was like that's the
opening level three he just knows man he
just know he's looking for his
opportunity impressive play for both
players with that guys we do have our
winners final set those two are
guaranteed the top three at Evo 2023
Nitro and Hikari bar we need to decide
who's going to be making it through the
loser side so we're going to be back
right after this very short break with
more exciting dragonfly's action here at
Evo 2023 top six don't go anywhere be
right back
Chipotle's new Chicken al pastor is fire
on every level fresh chicken hot off the
grill a rich marinade of seared Marita
peppers and ground acchiode balanced
with a splash of pineapple all combined
for the right amount of heat Chipotle's
all-new Chicken al pastor is where fire
meets flavor
thank you
[Music]
don't heal me
oh no
super Lola
Victory feels good
[Music]
they told me
[Applause]
all right Evo Evo 2023
are you still with me
all right
before we get back into this top six I
do have a couple of questions for you
first
are we down with Dragon Ball fighter Z
that's first first and foremost
okay
second how many of you guys like
Chipotle burritos
one more
who likes potentially free Chipotle
burritos
all right guys for real Chipotle is
proud to support Evo and bring
incredible opportunities and even better
incredible food to the FTC there is a
lot of people out here I need you all to
do me a favor everybody take out their
phone we're not starting DBZ so
everyone's phone is out phones phone
yeah raise them up phones up phones up
phones up phones up there should be
there it is right there everyone yeah
phone's up I want you all to text that
code right there right now for a chance
to win a free burrito or a free ball and
I want you to do one more thing do me
one more favor if any of you guys win a
free bowler burrito I want you to come
up to me when you see me on the floor
and we're taking a picture with a free
burrito code all right
oh oh you can't see they can't see my
head's in the way sorry
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
guys ready text this
can you see it
[Applause]
oh I'm sorry guys
you ready for it
[Music]
[Applause]
there we go cameraman let's go cameraman
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
all right it will eventually work all
right guys again if you see me on the
floor and you win a free burrito or a
bowl you owe me a picture
are we cool
are you guys ready for some more Dragon
Ball now are we ready for my Dragon Ball
all right the mask is tiring you guys
with us for the last go
foreign
's top six moving forward it's the loser
side oh yeah and an exciting sense
coming up right now bro we've already
decided the winners like you said but
it's time to see who is gonna make it
through the bottom bracket they're the
losers bracket we've got a great one
coming up bro like we've got a European
uh hello sorry sorry you do not it's
gonna be a European player Yasha no
European team kill yet could potentially
happen down the road but we are gonna
have garlic bread versus Yasha coming up
in just a moment yep and after that it's
gonna be kites versus gropis this is the
loser side as nitro and Hikari are
sitting down on that Windows final both
of them looking to play first two three
looking incredible man to get straight
to Grand finals but garlic bread versus
yashadam that is
a match that I've been wanting to see
for a while man how do you prepare
Virginia
if you're European right yeah right now
there's a bit of a shortage right like
it's like there's always been a few
around but they're active guineus right
now I witness you know that's the thing
groupies plays a bit of Guinea on the
side but hasn't been playing him for a
while and that's one of the characters
you really need to be ready for because
you've seen garlic bread you've seen how
good you know he can be with this but
more important guitar how do you prepare
for Krillin yes Krillin is definitely
the the rough one right here that's
going to be tough
um yeah I don't know man it's gonna be
extremely difficult for Yasha this is
definitely going to be a
time did you prepare for this specific
player type of matchup you know what I
mean absolutely let's see Yasha who was
sent to losers quite early by your
Adrian Riven earlier today and then yeah
Adrian River let's give a quick shout
out right beat Yasha on Dragon Ball then
went on to be Chow high in Street
Fighter 6. that's like a ridiculous
thing to do back to back on the same day
on two different games absolutely
ridiculous shout outs to him
to do an absolutely insane losers run to
go all the way here garlic bread just
drop to Losers
after his winners semi-final versus
Nitro
Yasha versus Garlic Bread button check
between the two players
and then we can be ready
yashar presenting team Solari in France
and the last French representative
in the top six that's very different
from last year
since last year was having quite a few
more French candidates in there today
it's only one and that's yeah
that's right of course
unusual characters
the one
you want to be playing against in Europe
if you want to practice again right yep
but it's not going to be easier this is
the problem that it comes down to right
if you're Yasha
bro everyone knows how to play against
your team oh my God
mixed bro
all just shy of 20K of you in this dream
chat you'll press white if you've got
big stuff just got hit press one if
you've got hips
don't even don't you
anyone can get it
nobody's safe
garlic bread I see the what he mixes you
in and out of the game a classic
a classic we thought we were just
watching a button check little did we
know we were getting mixed yeah garlic
bread is definitely a troll let's go
just look at his team
let's go here we go buttons are checked
and we are ready
yes I speaking
his vibe
for that
loses quarter final
here from such a long way right he's
been really doing well but he's still
looking for his super major win
of times you mentioned it earlier
counter performance from him
you know in the uh World Finals yeah
right here we go you see him he's made
it further than his French teammates yep
Wade and Kane falling short of course
but here he is Yasha stands tall as the
solo French representative here in
Dragon Ball Fighter's top six
very different look from last year yeah
where we saw so many French flags
in that top eight of course they're
still ready to fly the flag for Yasha
lots of blood Stephen you know the
crowd's gonna behind him there's quite a
good group of French players here a lot
of them including the uh last year's
Champion Wawa he is here yep after the
he actually played Gucci today but on
sf6
evil guys it's a different time guys won
that one it's a different time yep so we
got a
we got this one let's get ready players
are here fist bumps
on the way and we can go straight to the
sweat Games Arena
the one stage
to rule them all yep that's garlic
breads this takes on Yasha this has
become the catalogs island of Dragon
Ball Fighters the Cell Games Arena the
one stage everybody wants to play on
yeah
all right
gonna be interesting one Yasha of course
is the one he's the maker of this team
of this meta let's see yep
you see yeah Hikari taking it to new
heights and win his final yes sir
regardless whether you like it or not
he's the OG
the OG but the students might have
overcome the master Tyrant that's what
I'm saying he's part of it it's only
looking that way
look at this character bro Step Into The
Grand Tour
he's sick
there we go
straight to the Gogeta blue point he's
so cool look at that waistcoat please
let's do this
let's get it oh yeah Evolution we love
you man let's go garlic bread versus
Yasha
losers quarterfinals and Yasha is forced
to block four stars he's trying to
challenge on this gets hit but no
conversion just yet this movement on
yasha's side trying to force him but
water block garlic breath defense remain
solid and the rocks assist can be so
scary
now
ah you thought it was a low
again
extends send the money to the corner
that is a strong start but look at this
the bar builds is so little that the
tutor she's pretty much not possible and
yes you want to use spark oh not
incredible spark right now and yes I
immediately changing him to reflect he's
going to be baited Yasha potentially
going for the longest combo he can just
to beat that part-timer yeah yeah sure
his execution is so on point
this guy is
such a complete package as a player man
defense offense mix execution patience
he's got it all
here knock down time
there we go for Stardust oh yes he is
there we go level two Yasha sending
super baby out
and if you like any time you kill a
character the next one is even more of a
threat on garlic bread science yeah it
is a scary team to deal with for sure oh
free jump oh no
oh for a second there he had to
again reach out look at your execution
so on point
always has to go for the optimal man
especially now with the team that means
much less meter with three bars so the
next hit should be able to kill and he's
trying to cover an answer from garlic
bread perfect super Dash there yeah
could potentially decide to go for a
body swap on the next opening
if he decides to but just goes for the
music it's a bit more tricky you know
unless unless he doesn't unless he has
the baby b assist yeah yeah and that
body swap can be a bit awkward but there
we go Yasha finds the hit and that's
going to be enough and guess what that
meter game
it's back that is the old gmail again of
course for news Fork
you read that much and guess the sword
Yasha so far barely worried by Gary
Brad's team he has been playing
absolutely ridiculous
whoa
so scary bro dishwasher gloves this is
scary man like every time but I'm
telling you they can clean up man them
gloves okay
from the corner right now or we trade
money for the corner once again and
that's going to be a bit more the
barriers he's gonna be there in the
Dragon Rush he's going to open garlic
bread up Yasha just going to
extends level three into the mix vanish
see
to him
my friend you got mixed oh my God you've
got mixed Vision I guess in game yeah I
don't think he's done here the extra
garlic bread though
oh
let's go let's get back some life here I
don't have a seat that's okay yeah
because the bloody Hopps are still gonna
open you up that's gonna be enough yeah
okay krillin's there in line for a
second
gonna have to restock my man
gonna have to restart but got to get
that cheeky senzu Bean in
character on the brink of elimination as
Yasha is looking extremely
focused and composed right now after a
very early one-way trip to losers
brackets all he's looking forward to is
complete a full losers run Khan Yasha
let's make it work as the crowd of
course is ready to get high for game
number two of this loses quarterfinals
look at this The Mandalay Bay is packed
the infinite Hall it just goes and goes
on
you can't stop this man from pressing
buttons
and he's going to get his opening and of
course that team used to be team to
touch it's not anymore but
yes I decided that should be enough for
him to make it work
keep the attempts okay okay okay
I respect that he made the right choice
okay
all right darling great is the one he's
standing right now
[Music]
this is there
no Canon level two and he gets an
extension on this one gets the extra
frame Advantage there it is yes parking
there is a very good one obviously
because this mix I mean it's pretty much
a guess you can't see where ginu is
landing it's high or low it's a good
luck so you spark and get out of jail
free for once using your own Spark
trying to put more pressure but garlic
bread defense is immaculate right now
watch out Josh I still have another
fence right now he's trying to punch
super baby Up the Volume finally after
37 attempts yeah he opens up his
opponents
oh no choose the assistant instead level
one
into the spirit sword
that's then
done
you out and it feels like this game you
failed to really grind yashas gears man
garlic bread never really got to being a
strong offensive position with that ginu
he's still looking for his rhythm is
still happy to block and waiting
methodical composed
yeah some baby pressuring away with that
improved Frame data that he received in
the most recent patch what a conversion
of the straight key blast there we go
these combos in the corner senzu Bean
are we it yeah are we eating we're
having a snack with combo we're hungry
we're hungry let's go
ah invisible mix where is he at oh oh
and the road tag is going to be the one
winning it over but a weird interaction
there giving garlic bread oh my goodness
what a conversion I love it I love it
conversions garlic bread is looking
optional right now and of course time
for The Rock
yeah she's gonna wait manage to escape
the corner tap tap putting more pressure
yeah and that's going to be the opening
again Yasha it's playing with garlic
breath defense right now oh yeah yeah
stop moving look at this
challenges
yeah what a choice man it feels like
Yasha always presses the right button
guess what Yasha was to win three
characters Yep this baby does not have
those extra assistable could be in a bad
way right now gets hit off the super
Dash yeah
right now can set up the One Touch
situation
foreign
defending for his life in the corner
right now
yeah he's still defending a look at this
yes
finishing the combo playing once again
with garlic for his defense the defense
was not strong enough to hold the
absolute offense the absolute pressure
over garlic bread right now and with
this Yasha will qualify to lose the
semi-final as garlic bread will take
fifth place at Evolution 2023 big shout
outs to garlic bread for an absolutely
amazing run today yeah guys give it up
for garlic bread come on
what a run here for the young players
putting in an absolute shift making top
six City vote we'll learn a medal for
that one
and the respect of his peers War
performance a well-deserved one but this
is the man on the mission right now
Yasha after falling into losers quite
early
composed himself and just went back with
a huge huge loses run and he is still
looking to continue he's moving forward
to Loser semi-final absolutely he's
gonna be there there's an opportunity
man to correct the mistakes of years
prior and it's the same for a number of
the players here in this bracket you
know Nitro as well uh gonna be looking
to take that one but yeah Yasha gonna
have to work his way out the loser's
side we have got another absolute Banger
on the way for you guys right now
absolute Banger and it features one of
the players who has quite a particular
way towards here as he won the qualifier
to fly to evil and go all the way to top
six I would like to introduce you to the
PlayStation tournaments road to Evo
Champion grow peace yeah man what a road
[Applause]
yes
every year thousands of fgc competitors
try to reach the top of the Evo Mountain
Seer PlayStation's road to Evo offered
Gamers a chance to win a trip to compete
at Evo 2023
representing Spain gropis looks to
complete his Redemption Arc after barely
missing out on last year's Evo care
package
then ladies and gentlemen after losing
the grand finals last year and narrowly
missing out
now in the top six on the grandest stage
in the fgc he's ready to show the world
that he's up for the challenge but the
question is will the rest of Evo's top
six be ready for him
PlayStation
wow what a unique part for this young
player here absolutely and the
well-deserved One Man Group is
all the way from Spain he won the
tournament the pressure Tournament Road
to evil we won't commented for that and
he actually won this by beating both
Yasha and Kane yeah that was the bracket
that was super super impressive that was
a crazy one to win the third one tell
you what if you might meet you again but
this time on the biggest of stages but
we'll have to go through a player who
has been so incredibly ridiculous over
the last few months and especially today
tight he's shown how good he can be and
he's gonna be the one to take on
groupies but just like we mentioned
garlic bread right groupies is a
different breed he plays a very unique
team he plays Frieza which is another
character you see a lot how ready are
you for Frieza kites yeah yeah we were
very close to having two Frieza players
here in top six of course shout outs to
KJ pixel yeah Seventh Place finish and
amazing Frieza player gropers as well
gonna be representing that character
here today in this top six and here he
is up against quite one of the finest
players out there right now grinding the
game
gonna be an excellent match guys super
baby Frieza and beerus for a groupies
lab coat 21 days Vegeta and Andrew 21
for kite kite came from the Winner's
side after he's exciting semi-finals
Hikari he's looking to bring it back and
maybe later offer himself a run back
against Hikari right now it is time for
the second move the squad for finals who
will join Yasha in the top four kite is
looking to get the first opening in the
group he's happy to block for now yeah
look at the defense right now okay and
reflects her away
21 the character that terrorized Dragon
Ball Fighters for the entirety of the
last season
yep and look at this he's filling the
screen he's absolutely annoying the hell
out of guidance there we go that goes
low kite not ready to block this one and
Grumpy's guess the first opening sends
him all the way down puts the orb and
it's time for beerus to put the pressure
on but good luck my kite he's got to
block again wow using all the oral
playing football out there oh
Steven character but no follow-up for
gropiss
now you have to thread the needle close
the gap against basically
to get away use Frieza to try and keep
him away but this is how there are more
pressure and now how can you block that
freezer the assists are not there but
are coming back and beerus is this
instead of a group is right now trying
to fill the screen and the super Dash
did interrupt breakfast and you get this
extended combo with Lord Frieza knock
down time sends out the slow orb and of
course that is one of the changes yeah
Frieza you can change the time
and you go gets the hit Vegeta goes down
there we go won't be the first time by
frieza's hands
definitely I've seen that episode before
let me tell you yeah but that's a win
yeah it might have been called you know
like not thinking about this because a
lot of people try to jump away from the
orb but in this case usually you come
super Dash not oh 21 not against kite
but it's time for electronic sport Flex
the Esports pose frees out with the new
golden phones for him oh live here as he
gets the opening there we go group is
going to go for a bit of an extension
right now how much damage can he build
up
and he's been doing these combos for
years like he's not a new Frieza player
he's been playing this character for a
long time here we go
sends out the disc and that's what it
takes to become a baby oh my goodness a
baby Master is understanding how every
assist Works nope down I'm not gonna be
able to kill realizes it and of course
that time has been reset anytime gold
Frieza leaves the screen and comes back
there you go it's another reset it's
another timer reset group is golden
Frieza is looking really good right now
kite he's working with a couple more
seconds of spark if you can get that oh
he gets that's gonna be the good amount
of meter can he get the Kyoto from a
jump in
as much as he can
no I mean I don't think so no no no no
still alive oh oh no big damage coming
up it's a medium open as well group is
how much damage can you do of this one
going to call the extension the Full
Source being applied by Golden Frieza
there is still appearance assist behind
but just goes for level one you have to
get freeze out as well because that time
I was about to run out yep we would go
Final Flash
okay there we go now he's just gonna
pepper the screen pepper Andrew 21 with
these keep loss and assists
yep just trying to fill the screen just
trying to use
groupies 21 against whoa oh it's gonna
be blocked all right more mix still not
kite showing that he will be happy to
block a time but you know what your
heart block that my friends no you
cannot want the droplets
three characters remaining on his side
that's the win the first game over quite
okay taking a moment taking a moment
have a little breather have a little
thought legendary breads giving kite a
couple words of advice naturally spread
he was there on the biggest of stages
last year giving some more to go to
Friend of course
there we go
the character specific combos working
out the gropis
all right sparked up probably wouldn't
early spark this time oh my goodness but
it's not gonna help him here against
grope is the onslaught
oh this is where you die
hey 6h pressure assist out
like how do you approach this is to be
Ah that's a good movement over here
finally able to get those on that six
stage is gonna open groupies up putting
him into the corner kite finally on a
good offensive streak
[Music]
now gonna go to work with Frieza knock
down time
oh what a choice kite the dash
okay let's see it's Vegeta in he's got a
ton of bar to work with spends once
all right gropers might consider
spending that spark let's see if he does
so or if he's gonna block it out there
it is I really like that Tyrant because
that's what he did earlier so kite
adapted to the fact that he's so grope
is using sparkly earlier he was like you
know what's gonna use Fork again I'm
gonna update it unfortunately the timing
was not the correct one so kite gets hit
by a solid amount of damage as well
that's gonna be the mix behind it oh
he's got the hit and that should be the
end of Vegeta
go level one it's gonna be Frieza in for
gropers
guys Unstoppable extremely solid tarent
tournament nerves that look like they're
a thing of the past
for the Spanish Contender there
oh my goodness that 5m goes so far it's
actually crazy it's crazy how far and
plastic goes
might be able to kill with this
oh my goodness you might be right here
okay
I tried but he got caught trying to
escape and kite is absolutely melting in
front of Ruby's offense right now one
more character for Kai to come back if
he can make it work group
[Applause]
there we go next
when you have three characters you just
like tag out yeah you can just you can
just swap around yeah rotate your
characters and that gold Frieza will
stay there he gets the hit parents he
goes for the combo
as long as he's under the combo Grumpy's
just finishing the cover right now into
the Dragon Rush just goes
he couldn't get the super in time it ran
out the heartbreaker he could have just
gotten any change anything to get this
one but you know what kite he's gonna
take this opportunity to the max get
that Frieza out of there no more golden
no more Frieza
this could be the start of a horror
movie for gropers
he actually went for a round star DP
Grumpy's despite all the hard moments
like this he's still confident enough to
go for this and groupies will move
forward to the loser semi-final but guys
before he leaves the stage please give
it up for kite what a performance
absolutely big shout out to kite you
will definitely see him once again on
the biggest of stages consistently
improving player but man groupies is
looking so incredible look at this good
but look at this man this one she
touched the floor she tried the Salt Bay
right as well we tried it I think you
need the the other one right the the one
that uh
when they're on the ground you don't go
for the right one that could have been
absolutely disastrous so you know like
for groupies but the fact that after all
this he still decided to go for the
risky opening why not yeah I respect
that and you so you saw it the downside
of that we saw the upside of government
Frieza and we saw the downside of golden
Frieza yeah that timer were enough can
be a real game changer for him but great
performance for gropers he's going to
advance on and he is in top four of Evo
2023 my young player from Spain what a
performance what a performance from
groupies our top four is all set guys on
the winner side it's gonna be Nitro
versus Hikari on the loser side is going
to be Yasha versus groupies American
winners Europe in losers only one
champion can be Crown today but what
we're gonna do guys getting a quick
break so get a drink get a snack and
we're back in a few minutes for the
winners final of evolution 2023 Nitro
versus Hikari coming in a few minutes
right here
your Chipotle order just got extra the
fighter coins from Street Fighter 6.
order any entree in the Chipotle app
using promo code hdkn 236 and received
250 fighter coins with your order visit
chipotle.com sf6 for details you got
this
only a handful of people in the world
can do it
you could be
the best
but it's dangerous these are incredible
steaks
you're going to be forced to make Split
Second decisions that could cost you
your life get out whether you like it or
not you are in this race
Gran Turismo based on a true story radio
PG-13
Red Bull gives you wings
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
the world
I'm Evolution's constant and this ain't
my final form
[Music]
run this back
brush it down
next I'll be strong prove myself
thank you
[Music]
welcome back it's Evo connections
presented by a t vicious here on the
floor for Street Fighter 6 as well I
happen to grab one of the premiere
players that we've seen transition from
four into five making a big name for
herself if you don't know well you're
about to it's Sherry Genex how are you
feeling today
I'm doing great I just I just need a
little coffee but otherwise I'm good I I
am right there with you now one of the
biggest questions on my mind I have been
seeing seeing you grind on your stream
Street Fighter 6 a whole bunch of times
I want to know what is that connection
like going from Street Fighter 5 into
Street Fighter 6 along with your federal
competitors here at Evo yeah I mean I
think learning a new game is never easy
right so it's it's amazing to see how
everyone's transition though everyone is
doing so well and I haven't seen anyone
go missing everyone from five
transitioned into six no doubt yeah
we're starting to see a lot of players
come back from the woodwork and it's
like a blast from the past essentially
my final question to you this hits a lot
of pro players I still feel it also from
time to time and I'm nor even nearer Pro
how do you get over your tournament
nerves before a match that is such a
difficult you think it's such an easy
question to answer but it is super
difficult I've come up with so many
theories on how to calm my nerves and
honestly the best one is just to be
confident in yourself and to take deep
breaths through the nose out the mouth
and just kind of meditate a little
before you go into the match obviously
I'm going to take that advice to her
hopefully it's just as successful for
myself as well as you guys with all of
us here again at evil connections
presented by at T we're going to take it
back to all the action at the main stage
hello guys and welcome back to Evo top
six Dragon Ball Fighters actually scrap
that top four yes Dragon Ball Fighters
Evo 2023 we are ready to decide who is
going to qualify into that grand finals
position such an important place to be
in this tournament right now absolutely
and that's going to be Nitro who is on
back to back evil winners finals he was
there last year and he's gonna go back
here this year versus Hikari on the
winner side on the loser side we will
see
so two returning faces and two new faces
their first time at such a high level at
Evo right now Hikari has been nothing
sort of impressive throughout the
weekend and he's looking to take down
one of the greatest Hikari versus Nitro
are we ready for evolution 2023 winners
final Nitro versus Hikari
let's go guys of course this is the
finals match so it will be decided in a
three out of five setting we're done
with two out of three for the time being
here we go we got longer sets more games
I'm here for it I'm all here for more
games indeed Tara let's see Fusion ha
we go
[Applause]
Super Saiyan 3. let's go
Go barber versus Sun fusions yeah
oh yeah let's do it let's do it oh yeah
electricity shout outs to the crowds
Nigel's TV Curry there we go
on the go tanks the battle of the
fusions here we go all the point War
M
air from Hikari and his neutral has been
so good he knows exactly when to
challenge when the opponent wants to
approach and we've been seeing it
throughout this tournament right there
Nitro no exception anyone can get it
hands-rated e for everyone
okay the challenge
hurry and of course
he's gonna have to try and build as much
power as he can
might switch into Android 17. yeah there
we go
Decay betrayed him he really wanted to
uh okay here we go destroy that two good
things but look at this Nitro is gonna
be the one now go Smokey coming telling
me no
you're probably gonna swipe them right I
don't know okay Gokey on the way oh my
goodness and oh all right he used the
normal level one not go slow that was
sick
yeah
so now we're just uh playing neutral
jumpers
maximum neutral parents maximum footsies
oh wow you can see the spacing right
there Nitro
really a Believer that'll go on and how
can you not be yeah it's hard to not be
considering how good the character is
right now yes goes to level three the
Double Dash is now unlocked for Nitro
there we go Mystic Gohan trained by the
gods bro
hey whoa
okay I'm gonna talk about God key right
there
Super Saiyan blue
okay behind wow using the AC using that
Double Dash yeah that was nasty you
wanted to I can't jump too he says and
there we go that's going to be the
re-jump he carry
level three on the way but when you use
those three bars with Vegeta oh you
better make them count because it's a
lot harder for him to get those in this
version of the game cross out yep four
bars now and he wakes up you know with a
dash dash blocks down that's gonna be a
nobody for Nitro extending he's got
enough bars to go level seven if you
want Sirens yeah he does indeed let's
see will he go for him
reverse beats he's now a lot that's
right really powerful adult Gohan gonna
let him recover in the back as well
while Android 18 Cooks on point
okay
with that raw tag
follow-up Dragon Rush knock down
help with the latest timing on that when
he saw it in the late wake up that was
so smart oh what whoa
super Dash okay it was a super Dash
okay here we go
all right corner to corner he carries
the one putting him down and let's see
I'm not trying to wait the barriers
gonna try to get the opening wake up
Barry would assist cool man again
just making his work that assist getting
mileage then Nitro we're gonna be able
to swap potentially yes because he gets
the Dragon Rush after this it's level
six turret the reverse pitch is there so
the block string can be absolutely scary
as hell and now it's good luck to block
and to know where the blockchain would
stop because it's 5x2m 5 h2m as much man
okay he's walking now and he's waiting
happily patiently in the corner just
happy waiting so he carries Mark to just
get away and there we go infinite block
strings no you can't get away from my
pressure I love the movement
[Applause]
yeah you got those oh no he missed the
assist timing
unfortunate for Nitro
yeah he's still gonna pressure away or
against the legs but no follow-up here
oh the overhead and that's level seven
time is time oh
maybe one okay okay maybe one to 18
again against the Geo yeah don't want to
go for the win condition Gohan just yet
ah okay got the hit this is huge
and let's see again I don't think this
is gonna be enough to kill that sets up
the meaty Android 17. oh no you can't
get away from that Nitro gonna take the
first game and win his final
very very clean first game for Nitro
Hikari trying to catch up right now but
the pace is completely set
by natural Curry has to adapters the
first three of course they're a bit more
margin of error for the players right
now and look at these debates this he
was looking for a2h he carries a
completely beating no conversion for
this thing
okay there we go that's 6s from Gotenks
the character can be so annoying to
approaching the neutral so many good
options so many good movement tools on
this character
oh there it is what a block
goes behind
okay Curry takes it back to neutral
oh my goodness you might be a neutral
but this character overwrites it pretty
easily I am the neutral my friends yes
talk about neutral I decides and with
this Nitro makes quick work of that
Gucci blue is looking extremely
confident right now Hikari is still
looking for ways to put him under
pressure
[Music]
Flex there and a challenge as well jumps
out the Dragon Rush attempt the 5m
go dishwasher gloves
in effect
yeah you can go through the simple stuff
here knock down Corner time safe jump
pressure perhaps
backs off
trying to catch something
wow
okay there we go Android 17.
that's dead yep that is dead carry out
this brings it back it's two characters
each now
if you're looking to potentially reclaim
that leads he carries looking to just
find the groove right he hasn't really
set the foot in this one as finally yet
that might be the moment where he can
finally build up some momentum
fine shots both players approaching the
neutral going for those air-to-air
attempts
so close
ah to him start the damage here is about
to be huge yeah follow up look at this
let's see if it goes okay maybe jump
back H boom knock him down set it up
all right
okay I see you that's rope is immaculate
and Nitro of course is going to extend
right now I'm not gonna be able to kill
but could I be able to pretty much
almost kill the sparkle that combo it
was for ages yeah
volleyball attack knock him down doesn't
get left right mix on this stuck in the
corner keeps it simple knowing there's
no sparking available for Hikari keep
the pressure on there's the pickup
though no another drop
oh
okay fast full follow-up
to carry 17 is fighting back right now
as he sends
that's at the corner against the swords
yeah there's no Oaky on that level one
it's just about swapping around your
characters keeping all of them healthy
there's the super dash for Hikari it
pays off
yeah level zero tyrants that's true you
don't want to be left with that yeah
that's your anchor it's gonna be tough
now comes in he's gonna get an extra bar
here so he's got three so any here he
can perhaps get three bars on the table
but let's see
neutral
one Cube loss against fire
look at these both players don't want to
overcome it to anything in the mooch
could be very very
oh jump s yep Kerry has found the right
ranges to a no-natural right now Nitro
is the one struggling to get to an
effective range against his opponents
and look at this is staying far right
now but when can you get an opening yeah
Hikari
trying to just stop Magic from doing
anything you see the preempted two s
attempts
oh okay there's the spark Archie doesn't
want to fight oh and you know what he's
about to get a lot of meter up on the
table here yeah level three
it is
17 the MVP they say two H bro they
forgot that Android 17's got a barrier
behind ready to stop you from even
considering punishing that super Dash
that was so smart that he carry playing
with nitro's reactions
go
oh he gets the pickup what up you saw
the
movements movement I love it that was so
complete yep has like what three seconds
of spark left let's go now trying to get
a bit more
he's in the Double Dash situation right
if he doesn't have a rose
hey there it is he got it
steals it back two zero
he looks confident man he looks composed
he looks good as you can hear the crowd
chance nitro's name chance the
champion's name their Champion that's
what they want they want nitro to get
there and Hikari is the one struggling
he is one game away
from the two peak
Evo winners for Grand Final position
[Music]
don't count this man out
there you go of course Vegeta blue he's
still with that amazing damage still
with those incredible options it's just
the meter game that you slightly missing
now
it's too far he optimizes this
is dead
[Music]
nice
the optimals
he's the one winning the point wall
that's the first time in the set that
the point wise won by Hikari and he's
looking to get away but again the
barriers will be stopping him whoa skew
it we go that 2s
there we go and she's blast split finger
shot no dice and again he's just
peppering away that does a lot of Chip
as well don't forget
you can play Lane with vegeto yeah you'd
have to go in
oh
5m Falcon hey at least they nerfed it
though right yeah
they did
pardon me never heard of that turret
that's right nice to be better man it's
hard to think that but yes it is
[Music]
he's got spark Nitro yeah
Hikari fine he's the one dominating the
usual tomorrow say what sometimes these
players come alive when they're back
against the wall when the chips are down
just like we're seeing from Hikari here
three characters to one what a pickup
off the video a assist that regular
meter build in effect right now he's
gonna get more than enough meter to
close this one out just has to finish
his play
yes there you go Hikari will get one up
on the board two one the win is final
now mean one from Hikari he's looking to
stay in this Winner's bracket right now
Harry waiting on the sides Nitro knows
on his one game to go to Grand finals
winners again
yeah Nitro knows what it takes to get
there he's been there before yep
last year in this very same building
Nitro
okay sorry though look at this this guy
is not going down without one hell of a
fight and one once he carry got the
momentum it's so incredibly hard to stop
him naturally to find a way
to reclaim some control there because he
carries starting to look very very
confident for the sets and I love how he
chases his opponent but he doesn't over
commit it's all safe pressure
[Music]
of times
all right there we go knock him down
Stardust form
into the spirit sword and that's that
and again he carries momentum
hard to stop right now Nitro is already
down to two characters Nitro has yet to
get started
okay in the last two games
after looking so dominant so
yeah wrecker knock down time
oh the option selects yes yes to get the
reflect after these if you do black SM
in this situation reflect comes out only
in the class situation
stopping him that's the way if you can't
challenge make him
do a mistake but do you see the lengths
that Nitro has to go just to get a hit
on Hikari right now he has to level up
the offense bring the layers
nice to meet you oh my goodness that
jump M is so hard to deal with
all right I like that Android 18.
she is a menace
both of them look at that holding that
score
you're just giving him free ball yeah oh
the movement have you seen that Tyrant
he back that's the fight and I was like
let me show you mine mine's better my
friends
that's gonna be enough right there
oh he's gonna spend more by them maybe
he needs to
yeah okay just guarantees it
two bars on the kill and with one of
these uh Nerf characters might come back
to fight him but Curry is still looking
excellent right now he's still got 17 on
the back a little bit more meter but
once again we put natural oh my God what
2s lands
okay goodness oh he's gonna go for the
mid screen if you want for M bring him
to the corner
all right Nitro it's not done yet though
oh though he carries Sparks up I love
that gonna get a ton of meter right here
look at this more than enough more than
enough on the way wait wait wait a
minute unless unless oh
he ties it up 2-2 and easy look at this
look at this coming of his face moving
the shoulders he's ready for that final
game as nitro is trying to find his
composure back he Carry has finally
found his Groove in his winners final
and it sees a game number five in this
final only one game to qualify to Grand
finals of evolution 2023.
let's go guys you ready for the fifth
game of the set
oh yeah I know you're ready
this one's going to be so crazy who is
it gonna be moving into the grand finals
the biggest tournament from Curry's life
and potentially Nitros as well
let's see
I love to see it it's the final game
Talent Nitro was so dominant but
something completely changed you could
see Curry just activated the defensive
mode and it's been so difficult for
Nitro you said it right to get a single
opening in this match now he's
struggling to find his Groove yeah the
lengths that he had to go through it was
like barrier and like some Next Level
mind game
hey look at that
you can jump nothing assist call he knew
Nitro was going to be active pressing
buttons and look at the reward he gets a
corner combo on this go tanks
oh don't reflect
bad reflect right there and he carries
should have enough I believe tequila 17
coming in 17 can come in no the assists
no okay just not just enough just enough
just enough he carries
for the last two to three games
We Carry has got his number right now
and Nitro is again trying to get
something and that's the main way Nitro
has opened his opponent up lately that's
it all backs off here oh gets to confirm
that was beautiful after the 17. and
then we go level three now sorry you
know he's got to be thinking about maybe
spark let's see what's it gonna be and
to Denise
oh the choice he caught the job best
attempt
knocked down we don't do that here my
friend we don't do that here I'm just
gonna chase you I'm gonna delete you
along with your spark another mix that's
gonna be blocked oh he took care of
Vegito wait a second
oh he got them you got them yes
that's fine anyway it's full screen
not what you can do I believe against
this as nitro is just floating around
trying to uh
this is how it would go for split figure
shots in effect
Curry oh my goodness
so tense right now this could be the
potential tournament deciding match oh
there we go gets it we jump on the way
of course
we've got those
and he pulled the extra yeah that's
enough yes it is Spirit sword's gonna be
enough to kill here Swap and there we go
once again Nitro is down to his final
character that's level zero Tyrant he
absolutely need at least one level to
actually unlock the character because
for now he's nothing much aside from
this jump keep last
it's gonna be tough right here you need
to get a clean hit you absolutely have
to it's imperative
oh my goodness Nitro trying to pay this
long little game bar you go the Esports
kicks are walking Hikari is on all three
characters and Nitro now he's got spark
he's got seven goals he's got tools but
yeah he's not he's not pressuring from a
range where he plans to get hit with
spark knockback yep trying to force
Nigel to activate in the neutral
here we go
reverse beats that's a good start and
maybe the next hit can get to level
seven if he gets it
is
already one step ahead and he has
completely
attempt to counter he carry with a
massive reverse sweep from 2-0 to 3-2
Hikari will go to Grand finals with a
side of evolution 20 23.
wow what a show right there higari from
the brink of defeat zero two down the 3p
coming back and earning his spot in
Grand finals Winner's side yeah sorry
boy you earned it celebrate your earned
it
you want to earn it so so strong right
there for Hikari the turn around like I
said bro some of these players these
young players when they're back to the
wall when it's looking like they're out
down and out they come fighting up
see it there Hikari with the performance
of his lifetime winners fine a grand
final now what a complete turn around
man incredible he carried his first
Grand finals in a big major
and that's an evil
on the Winner's side that's right I mean
what here he is yep
2023 and he's gonna be getting that spot
grandfather from the side impressive
impressive stuff but right now we will
drop down to the losers semi-finals and
this is no longer three out of five this
is not a top three match so we're going
back down to two out of three and it's
gonna be a European team kill we're
gonna have gropis from Spain going up
against Solari Yasha from France yep and
we mentioned it right group is one the
PlayStation run to evil yes tournament
to get there by beating Yasha in Grand
finals there you go so the last time
these two plays that was on the
qualifier for evil
and those groupies taking the win it's
time to run it back on the biggest of
stages after a very long road through an
874 player bracket
groupies and Yasha are fighting to stay
alive in these tournament loser gets
fourth place winner goes to play Nitro
in losers final
[Applause]
oh what a top six it's been here at
Evolution man honestly you can just see
how far back the Crowd Goes everybody
pulling up enjoying some Dragon Ball
Fighters
on day two of evil that's what we'll
also see
that's what we love to see
Yasha this means a lot to him as well
he's been working hard he's been
grinding he's been getting ready
and he really really wants this evil and
even though he's been experimenting with
a lot of teams a lot of attempts I've
seen him playing jiren for example to
replace a Gogeta blue he reached that
conclusion that his team might may make
not mean no less meter he's still an
excellent team it's still a great team
I'm telling you those characters yes
they did receive that meat and Earth
penalty but you just have to play them
with a different kind of mindset you
know you do have to do a little bit of
extra work perhaps not keep them out on
point for as long you know use them more
as Cash Out characters rather than meet
a build but you can see Hikari my man is
in Grand finals
of Evo and it's almost like he doesn't
care about that he just plays he places
Gogeta Blue Point yeah and he's still
absolutely cooking
yes sir the players are checking their
buttons
just making sure that everything is fine
you have to bro he's doing this to me
final I am not missing a single button
I'm checking all of that checking the
share button bro check the touchpads yes
make sure everything is working as it
should these players no they came so far
to get to this point
they don't want to leave anything to
chance
right here see you on the stage
I am really looking forward to see this
one Talent
I'm I'm excited for this I'm excited for
this man top four of Evo
it's gonna be a crazy one
oh here we go we're getting ready how
about you guys out there are you ready
for some losing semi-finals Dragon Ball
Fighters
oh yes talk to me people talk to me
that's what want to see losers final
it was a semi-final sorry of evolution
2023 on the player one side comes all
the way from Spain
groupies against solari's very own Yasha
that's right and let me tell you that is
a long trip back home yes sir for both
of these gentlemen but for one of them
it's going to be a rougher trip
someone's going out here in fourth place
will it be gropis or Yasha let's find
out
side we saw earlier baby Frieza beerus
not a team composition you usually see
of course we're a bit more accustomed to
how strong baby and beerus are in this
patch yeah but Frieza a bit more of an
anomaly
throughout Dragon Ball's lifespan you
know there's been a character that we
don't
ever really see a lot of yeah
it's never really been uh you know great
I think it's probably the greatest he's
ever been like in the current uh he's
been getting little tweaks and small
Buffs here and there never really enough
to push him to the top but character can
definitely do work yes sir big smile and
group his face he's enjoying always his
time of course he's enjoying his time
here in Las Vegas he's in top four of
the biggest tournament in the world
ladies and gentlemen it is time for
losers semi-final all the way from
France Yasha versus Spain's very own
gropy suddenly one can remain to go in
the face he carry potentially in Grand
finals but first Nitro in loses final
Make Some Noise follow the semi-final
let's see the characters are here
you can let the intros rock as we do of
course
of course
monkey returns rejects modernity
parasite
tuffles
here we go
[Applause]
you ready guys one more time
I'm the strongest Goku and Vegeta
combined
[Applause]
yeah yeah
that's what I want to see it's Evolution
2023. life on the Mandalay Bay in Las
Vegas
and groupies takes on Yasha the first
opening cause for the French man who is
absolutely on the mission right now
looks like he wants to carry on his
momentum
and he built just over one bar with that
full combo bro
oh my goodness but he's gonna build a
ton of bar right now look at this
all acid rain combos it's green all the
way to the corner throw him down
there we go that's two cents for the
price of one and you know baby ain't
gonna miss that yep
definitely a great day for him
can be a good way to counter it's kind
of very active old play style appearance
oh
I've L connects for a double trade from
instant air Dash air ends
here we go
now for the knocks down oh no big draw
okay it's back to babies
okay
oh we've got these of course we do
Ropers always with the optimals man
whenever he can yeah but that's a dead
Vegeta five bars on The Rook besides
get one into 100 full power oh
this guy's Hench bro this guy's training
this man's been lifting weights I hope
so it took him 40 episodes to get there
okay look at this conversion not freezer
freezers
more pizzas coming in oh yeah serving
them up yeah 9.50 the slice we're in Las
Vegas my friends
45 bucks
he sends the two pizzas up to one dollar
plus that's 100 plus tax you know oh
freezer making money today
yes up and down here we go here is
dropping him down here we go six orbs
set up oh
grope is you are a machine
well this is so good at stopping you
from getting away from the corner
death ball
hey here we go yeah he's down to a 17
after a very strong start with this
completely came back and look at this
that Frieza is putting so much pressure
on Yasha struggling to navigate the
screen
down sends out the slow orb nice box
there for freezer
look at this trying to prevent those
jumps oh did he get two I saw I saw
beerus beerus is dead this is gone there
is eliminated
after the happy birthday destroys the
freeze side to 1v1 right now what a
potential comeback from Yasha but he
needs to destroy that super baby as well
so we'll be getting the assist for the
super Dash yes here we go acid rain you
know he's gonna play defensive and just
cause the assist just chill he does have
access to those amazing video assists if
he needs it
by the way oh foreign
there we go there we go Yasha
soft bubble after a huge comeback there
and he builds up coffee look at this
crowd
let's go let's go Evolution this evil my
friends this is the biggest station
there is
just went for such an incredible
comeback man
damn Android 17 bro the most clutch
character in the history of Dragon Ball
holding it down for Universe seven you
love to see it and for Yasha there
yes let's go guys we're back in
Great Tech
okay that and and you know yeah she's
that kind of emotional player that kind
of comeback can really boost him up and
boost his morale yes sir
they reflects there for gropis
what an escape though he's opening the
corner we're gonna play beam you like
beams oh here we go we got him baby got
these combos bro
this kind of damage
this character is outstanding look at
this
oh oh
that hurt me bro
that's enough right one one yes Yasha
yeah that super does a lot end game
level one Spirit sword swap potentially
the last time we see baby it couldn't be
his top eight it could be a top six
freezer it's probably the character that
has the most pressure
there we go oh super Dash super rush
takes the wheel one of the mechanics of
all time
I was truly
if you can't disabled oh wow here we go
all right let's go knock down in the
corner
the orb okay Yasha Sparks up doesn't
want to deal with that freezer pressure
[Applause]
down
wow what a tech
oh oh you got caught trying to find him
that's it
Frieza is really the main enemy for
Yasha right now why no the Deadpool
missed what oh no not like this what
happened oh no no we've got to watch out
and of course he gets to tag in
the unfortunate drop
oh one group his side and now he's
forced to block immediate spark and
tries to chase at 17. yeah happy to
block there's an entire spark going in
yeah still blocking and that's a bit
more you can't block down the Dragon
Rush lands there's gonna be a lot of
meter build here for gropiss
with that so important
he's gonna be knocked down UK he wants
that level three he's gonna get okay on
this one let's see oh the raw tags Delay
from Yasha
yes Gogeta in safely
hey going to work now
okay let's see how Grumpy's the fans
we're going golden time to guess time to
guess the sports aren't now officially
electronic
teleport move there to get behind but
Yasha scoping it out and he's gonna be
able to get this kill yep gold Frieza
and you spent three bars to lose a
character bro
unfortunate outcome for broke his death
not a great investment on his side as
Yasha is sending Frieza out and Rupees
is down to beerus down to beers to make
a miracle I have seen him
oh yeah he could do it performing the
greatest comebacks with his
viewers don't forget but and defy them
opening goes to Yasha right now it's
gonna be huge damage
okay let's see here knock down time
with the power plates oh he got him no
oh he tried the Spanish level three it
had to be done before the ends were now
playing football we're playing football
let's go there we go no this time
and guys this keeps it simple as simple
as you can possibly get it right there
level one into level one and Yasha will
advance on to loses final and play
against Nitro wow
you have deserved it smelly
yeah sure going straight
to that loses final and of course
massive shutout today's fourth place
gropis with an absolutely insane run his
first evil his first time in America
going all the way to fourth place I was
absolutely insane but we have our losers
final set right now and this is going to
be
let's go guys give out one more time for
the guy all the way from Spain the
underdog gropius come on guys give it up
for gropis
the freezer Specialists putting on a
show Fourth Place finish at emo for him
what a show and what a performance for
him coming all the way from the realm of
online to fourth place at Evo incredible
PS4 online this guy has been through a
lot he's been through a lot from the PS4
online Fields all the way to Evo this is
what we love to see but only three
players remain in evolution 2023 it is
Hikari sitting down in grandfather's
weiner side and they lose his final
that's a remake from last year's winners
finals Nitro versus Yasha one of these
two will go and challenge Hikari in
Grand finals but before that guys we're
gonna get a quick break to get ready for
today's losers final couple minutes
break and then back with Nitro versus
Yasha see you in a few minutes for more
Dragon Ball Fighters at Evolution 2023
at Chipotle real food always starts with
real ingredients in real kitchens when
you order Chipotle real food starts with
you whether it's in restaurant pickup or
delivery however you Chipotle is the
easiest way to Chipotle
Victory feels good
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
hey what's up everyone we at tenno are
Beyond excited to announce the launch of
some brand new merchandise for Evo
beginning with our new officially
licensed Street Fighter designs which
include premium embroidered hoodies and
more also we have new officially
licensed designs for the King of
Fighters 15 Guilty Gear Tekken and other
fgc partners each 10-0 product is
carefully designed by fgc heads with
only the best material for maximum
comfort and style trust me you don't
want to wait to cop these
hello hello everyone and welcome back to
Evo connections presented by atnt I'm
Persia and I'm joined by Jade Lin who
crushed it today on top six multi
commentary how are you feeling about Evo
this year and connecting with the melty
community and so I have had so much fun
getting to see the players that I have
been able to work with over the course
of the year since lost Evo been able to
share their stories here today it's
amazing and after all your hard work
this weekend I thought we would swing by
the free play Arcade and play some games
you ready I'm so excited let's go hello
hello hello yeah you're using both of
the controllers could you use a partner
yeah
combos oh perfect
look at that combo honestly that was so
much fun if I didn't have other things
to do I would definitely be back here
playing this right now I can't dance I
have no rhythm but what I can do is Mash
on a joystick so I'm down to check out
the Sega collection it's that Street
Fighter I'm not gonna lie I've never
seen this version before no but it looks
really fun I think there's a totally
play you want to oh yeah
[Music]
this line though I think is for project
L are you serious we should check it out
hey how's it going hey what's up we
realized we weren't gonna be able to get
into the line so now we're gonna ask you
questions about projectile did you get a
chance to play yet yeah I've been
farming this line when I'm not in
tournament I'm just rushing back here
awesome who are your favorite characters
so far uh right now it's Ari and Yasuo
they just got they just got too much
sauce in the game I see your next in
line so I don't want to keep you up but
thanks for chatting with us well that
was really awesome connecting with
people at the arcade connecting with new
games and connecting with my pal jadelyn
thank you guys so much for hanging out
with us but now it's time to go back to
the main stage
hello guys and welcome back to Evo 2023
we are in top three right now of Dragon
Ball Fighters we are dropping down to
the losers finals and we're gonna see
who is going to be moving up to play
against Hikari in Grand finals right
after this game bro we're back it's
three out of five it's Nitro versus
Yasha oh and that's a match that we love
to see we all remember last year's match
was absolutely incredible and I was
nicer of winning this one to qualify to
run finals last time this time it's for
the same place in Grand finals except
this time it's not for losers Yasha has
been on an absolute mission after being
sent into losers early by Adrian ribbon
he has run to an absolute Gauntlet of a
loser's bracket and now he's one game
away from a position in Grand Final for
a tournament he's been looking for for
so long big shout outs to all of the
crowd of course looking watching yeah
come on guys
that's it you are correct my friend
Damascus it will be a new Evo Champion
crowned
here today
absolutely is and the players are
getting ready it is Yasha
versus Nitro
Yasha the last European representative
natural looking to make it first a run
back but also a on a entirely American
Grand finals
Yasha for now
it's taking some time is composing
himself of course he is all the way to
lose his final he only has two more
steps towards the biggest title there is
let's see
here we go guys
[Music]
tonight for taking his time and it's
time to pick the stage
and to go straight
to the game turn to losers final and
exciting one 847 players at the
beginning of the weekend only three
remain right now three of the finest
players there is in the world but with
this
coming all the way from France
representing team Solari Yasha taking on
the East Coast Champion the people's
champ Nitro crowd are we ready for
losers final of evolution 2023
oh yes that is a sea of people come on
guys give us your energy it's time to
get on with this loses final here we go
all right and you guys know what to do
no intro nothing these guys want to play
it's time to sweat Tyrant and there we
go okay number one starting between
Nitro and yes I guess the first opening
I want to start here want to start
see
and the fact that Yasha is playing the
same team that sent Nitro here into the
loose bracket could actually be a huge
problem you would have thought it would
be great to warm up against his team but
the way that Yasha plays competing
Hikari slightly different
spanner in the works the Nitro here but
let's see
yeah I don't think this is going to be
able to kill here doesn't have tag
available yep although let's see a bit
higher up bringing them down into the
level one one that should just be enough
I do think Spirit sword no he didn't
believe yeah
I think would it be hard besides to just
keep that vegetable point right now
sounds nice wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute
okay gets out interesting interactions
there that was a weird interaction
[Music]
you know what we don't block blocking
his cringe my friends oh look no tanks
though with a ton of blue lights
Nitro gonna make this count there it is
the pickup
is going to get the meter that makes
Gohan a real character no just goes for
the pressure after
that okay
all right there's level one Gohan
nothing
Dr the misdirection classic right you
call the assist to the opponent is
looking at the assist and doesn't
realize that Dragon Rush is coming out
here we go level three on the way
let's see Nitro probably considering the
spark there it is
[Music]
okay ah
Yasha with the almost solid defense
nearly buddy
hey here we go what's he going for oh
level three yep two 18. stands up on
level three and it's time for the mix of
course
I see you
[Music]
and Nitro wins the point after a while
mine's been like about 100 seconds until
one character falls down this is how
hard of a match it is for both of the
players yeah sure it's gonna be a long
game now and saw him go for a vanish
conversion there but with this team then
vanish conversions are going to be very
sparing for the defeated games really oh
he got two of them make it count
yeah man there we go
no one caught it
deleted from the archives
no footage
existence
as well
decides to be extremely offensive and so
far it's working Nitro down to go tanks
Gotenks can definitely fight though as
an anchor character let me tell you
be kind of scary
oh nitro with absolute neutral
looking around the screen the challenge
however
[Music]
we're gonna go for level three oh no the
shout cancel drop and that can be the
problem of playing Gotenks you've got to
have that super high execution sometimes
you go back
okay that's gonna be that yeah sure
first game up here in the losers final
1-0 for the Frenchman a very strong
first game indeed
Yasha
commending leads
and looking to build up the momentum
against his opponent as the crowd of
forces and enjoying wow extremely good
match there we go this is a massive run
Manchester
Evo 2023 is there in the first opening
goes to Yasha yep everybody here to see
a new Champion be crowned on the main
stage of evil the challenge again from
Nitro who knows exactly when to press
buttons
let's get another shout cancel drop
it's gonna be the problem with Gotenks
like I said
the character yes he's super strong but
he's still gonna have that high
execution every single time and it does
get training in these American
tournament scenarios yeah takes
advantage
oh okay come on grab lands
he's gonna get enough here to take that
go tanks down and make it three
characters to two
once again looking good
that's mine don't choose yours I guess
what her level three gets two characters
if you need it one into three
okay there you go
oh no wait 17 got away
oh no one guess what he's the last
character so you don't get that blue
life yeah Yasha is probably just going
to go around and wait with that Vegito
still goes for super rash immediately
that's the opposite just the opposite of
what natural would expect on this trying
to move around oh
each run out after the worst time yeah
you know he wanted empty vanish there
but he was unable to get it
right now
it's got to be such a thorny Nitro side
is just waiting now waiting for that 17
to be repaired yeah he's waiting bro
okay being fixed man yeah man being sent
in the Los Santos customs come back with
the fresh beans I've been ready
you come come back with Fair TVs in
there it comes back with it with a stick
Arcane stick included let's go opening
go straight to the spark here Yasha does
not want to give any momentum to his
opponent oh wait a second
[Applause]
more than anything else
he does get level up here and the VR
knocked down let's see what Metro goes
for
um
that was a good reflect as well
create some more space between them just
gonna try play with nitro's movement
Nitro is looking to snipe him under
super rash on the perfect timing
[Music]
always one of the most optimal on Earth
yeah
some of the best neutral people ever see
yep that's what we love to see
it really a battle to a final opening to
fight them but unfortunately the um is
not connected to this wow
gets out the corner vegeto still
incredible movement options but spending
those parts bring that bar to use those
movement options can be a little bit
more risky now yep
so much now and yeah he's just taking
his time wow risky risky you don't whip
punish those let me tell you oh
what a conversion oh yeah
here we go here we go
still fighting for his wife with Android
17. this is not gonna kill but it's
gonna be yes for your character Yasha
okay camera Geo stay alive where are you
blocking across it cross up
no no no no no no no no no oh oh no
brother versus sister here
oh my goodness
for any opening is
victory for this he's playing the key
Plus game and you can see Nitro the
thing
[Applause]
two zero
two zero and he's taking just some time
to forget composed to get a drink to get
someone to stay hydrated
I'm looking to bring it
actually potential frenulum Nitro
Nitro introspection time
lost in a row right there yeah to this
very team this is a difficult one he
can't solve the double Fusion 17 puzzle
right now
crowd getting behind him trying it for
Nitro if you want nitro to do this guys
come on support your boy Make some noise
that's what we'd like to see you guys
support him who you want to win
right now look at this look at this
your people
[Applause]
In Crowd enjoying Dragon Ball Fighters
finals I keep on Mission 2023. that's
what I'm saying man this is Evo this is
Dragon Ball here we go Nitro
trying to maintain that composure here
we go third game of descent
[Music]
oh my goodness Peck right there from
Yasha can't open him up that easily
wow a full screen he is really confident
man he's really trying to play with
nitro's movement he's been working look
at this my money's just shimmying we're
looking at the opponent walking back
taking some time wow
you see that super Dash
oh my goodness
action right now
oh unfortunately
I mean Nitro has been very actively
neutral and that's why Yasha is just
going for things that could be punished
but he's checking that Nitro is not
looking at the super Dash he's too busy
trying to find his own neutral for now
the Asha finds the hit with them the mix
has been working since Dragon Ball
Fighters beta
6m with assists there we go that's what
they minus one
finally
[Music]
and send it down straight level three
and you know what's happening after
Android 18 level three for the mix yeah
we know gonna pull you out the corner
left right on this cross up
yeah yeah I am blocking that I know
there's no way we don't do that here
I like how he immediately waited oh my
goodness
okay here we go knock down time level
three on the way final Kamehameha
let's see what's behind
Basha he's one of the best at least he's
not always at the Pixel Perfect position
to destroy spark attempts I have seen
Yasha fade Sparks in so many different
ways in so many different tournaments
and he does it once again on the bigger
stage shout out to Yasha okay
could be the final time we see Android
18 in this set
yeah guys anything to say about it but
not again again Taryn these four attacks
are not kept in check I know did he
taken a risk with that but he's so
confident like you said earlier Damascus
okay head to air oh the last second Dash
gets the hit overhead lands and now
we're cooking now you've got some bars
in these long tournament scenarios
Gotenks can be such a drain to play yes
ghost time
[Music]
okay hold the buttons expecting them all
at once
okay
gets away
is just trying to get away
[Applause]
big damage
guitar
[Music]
all right level three
[Applause]
I respect that
see the level three here what's the
pressure gonna be super nice with the
Nitro
he's gonna say goodbye to Gohan here
okay final character here for Gotenks
final characters
so hard
face Yasha who looks like on an absolute
mission right now yes let's see how this
one is looking to get the check yeah
with the mix it's gonna be blocked but
no another opening and Yasha provided if
it is in the combo just one combo away
from getting straight to Grand finals
Nitro could not weather the storm that
is yasha's opens and Yasha is qualified
to Brand finals of evolution
2023 what an incredible loses bracket
running that's right and Yasha already
with an improvement over last year of
course was not able to reach finals then
there we go one step at a time but it's
gonna have a brick wall in the way by
the name of Hikari playing the same team
there's gonna be a mirror match here in
the grand finals if you go I do believe
you can see him talking to his French
teammates right here yep that's great
flash enough cool gun
all the guys out there supporting their
boy of course we're gonna have a good
old friends versus America in finals got
to love the Rivalry man yeah came out of
like nowhere to be honest after his
lasting winners uh it was a difficult
path what a run so far what a run
definitely yeah he actually eliminated
tanks as well earlier yeah another
European teammate to get to this point
in the tournament and you can see his
pass right there green garlic bread
gropes
he did not lose it
he has yet to lose a game in that top
six bro
that is actually mad that's crazy that
is a mad run you see that sometimes
these these young players man they just
tap into that insane energy and we've
seen it time and time again we saw it
with Wawa in his year of dominance he
ran through tournaments like this two
zero two zero three zero Etc and right
now Yasha is picking up the pace as we
move into the grand finals it's going to
be Hikari versus Yasha
bro I'm looking at Joshua's path in
loses bracket Junior versus true awesome
Junior versus lucar tuni versus White
Knight versus Shanks q1 was just saying
that's the one AP drop and then two
little
so in the entirety of top 48's losers
Yasha only dropped a single game
that's the only game
that's crazy I think was it uh Adrian
ribbon that's in yep it's a losers yep
yes okay
[Music]
but of course
the American hope for this Grand finals
he carry the level of play that his
display today has been absolutely
impressive Taron the defensive plays
were impressive and I've got to say it's
quite funny and ironic that we've been
enjoying so much character variety
throughout the weekend and our grand
finals ends up being a very much a
mirror match double fusions
the universe is trolling us so so I do
believe I could be wrong here the last
time these two guys met oh look at the
crowd by the way let's go Evo God this
is Evo
what a crowd let's go Dragon Ball
Fighters I see you out there what a
gigantic crowd and before yeah like I
was saying right I believe the last time
these two May was uh at one of the NYC
tournaments I believe it was Heat Wave
or PSP one of those people carry one
yeah I think he carried one of those
time limit I think Heatwave he carry one
was it I'm not sure I know I know
they've had a two yeah they've met a
couple of times in tournament yep and
it's been very close yep let's see you
know
it was Master of students the student
might have overcame the master today
yeah Yash is the guy that made this
double fusions uh Andrew 17 team yep you
know made it so popular and he carried
big tits and made it better you know
fine-tuned it got ready but with this
guys players are ready on the winner
side
all the way from the East Coast
defending America
hey Curry
taking on
the French Hulk
the French representative it's been so
long that he's been hunting for his
major winscat
Make some noise
crowds you know what to do
all right we've got two of these on the
way
yeah that was pretty good that was
pretty good let's do better but I think
you guys could do better than that let's
hear it
[Music]
all right finals of evolution 2023 in an
electric crowd here at the Mandalay Bay
Las Vegas on the first opening go
straight to he carries the mirror match
is the student is the master but who is
the student who is the master right now
Tyron let's find out who's gonna get it
who is gonna be the new Evo Champion
Kario Yasha carrying the winners side
but Yash is the one that gets the hit
yep good job here rocking the green
color team
all right very nice we all knocked down
oh okay good defense but he carry right
now Yasha is going to try to be
relentless the good super Dash but just
is blocking unless he carries time to be
on the offense right now the first mix
is going to be blocked on the DP he's
going to stop